foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun happy seems
more fresh and I know he loves Todd of
Steel and you could just see the
inspiration in fabby's play
once again Vicon say starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to Steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is playing for a win and he
has to start winning fast if he wants to
re-emerge at the top half of the Cross
table the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish is
taking down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps elderbeck
just playing a modern brilliancy what a
performance
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
happy Saturday everybody and welcome to
round seven of the Tata steel chess
tournament we can see that beautiful
playing haul over in the resort seaside
village of vacancy 30 minutes from the
capital of the Netherlands Amsterdam The
Spectators the players in the open
tournament Milling about preparing for
yet another day of Breakneck action I'm
your host Jim Daniel nerdinsky and
alongside me today once again
International Master Yovan kahuska
Ivanka what better way to spend the
weekend and watching some more epic
chess action
yeah I know you couldn't ask for
anything more I mean we've been treated
so much spectacular chess and of course
we get to see what is essentially a
chess Festival so many people gathered
in one spot just enjoying the game I
mean I'm just loving every second of it
we talked about this yesterday it's not
just about who's leading the tournament
it's not just about who beats who it's
about the atmosphere and the atmosphere
in the Tata steel tournament is second
to none and the atmosphere is created by
a combination of things of course the
players but also just the amount of
Spectators the tournaments that are
going on on the side and the location
which is so picturesque and so
unmistakable vikon Zay means only one
thing and it means epic chess it also
means the world champion because he is
participating in this tournament he is
struggling mightily now Magnus was able
to somewhat stop the bleeding with
yesterday's draw against his former
second Jordan Von fares the Press caught
up with Magnus to see how he's feeling
and to ask about his approach as we
reach the midpoint of the tournament
let's listen in
um yeah it's probably not a good sign
um really I mean I
but I I try to
um
you know
not let it affect my sort of date today
routine too much just keep on going and
um I feel okay so hopefully things will
turn around but you know losing is um
it's frustrating
um well I mean I did take quite a bit of
risk in both those games that I did lose
so
I'll probably have to take even more
risk now
um but you know I'll try every game I'll
try and play and um we'll see how far it
takes me
um the tournament Victory is obviously
not realistic but um regardless of what
you're doing that's not what you should
think about so I'll take it day by day
and um
we'll see how I end up
well the world champion promising to
take it day by day tempering our
expectations by saying that a tournament
Victory is not realistic and as the
current cross table sits well that's a
pretty accurate statement let's review
Friday's results we had two decisive
games as Wesley so of course his first
win of the tournament the OB and Fabiano
caruana delivers a just a crushing
victory over the struggling gukesh yeah
and it was especially important for Fabi
to actually take down kakesh because it
meant that he managed to get revenge
over his defeat in the olympiads in 2022
and yes it looks like it was quite a
draw Fest and it was but boy were those
games so tense so thrilling and uh let's
have a look at the leaderboard to see
how everyone is doing and at the top of
the table we can see it is none other
than 18 year old Nordic Abdul sirov who
really is having the tournament of his
life so far he is on four and a half
points out of six and you have to
remember he actually defeated the world
champion Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces in game five he's just playing so
well
the uzbekian I'm sitting pretty on four
and a half I mean plus one two three in
a field like this is just uh stunning
but he's got half of the tournament uh
that he still has to play Let's see if
he can manage to sit Atop The Cross
table he's got some sharks uh trying to
catch up to him Fabiano Caron and Anish
giri two of those sharks they are only
half a point behind on 4 out of six and
of course a big contingent on plus one
that includes uh the Indian Talent
product Nanda and then of course Magnus
Carlson that's the real story of the
second half of the tournament cross
table he is in 10th place right now on
minus one let's see if he can course
correct today with a victory and he's
got a pretty good pairing he's got the
white pieces against Richard report who
has historically really struggled in his
black games against the world champion
will be bringing you those stats in due
course but mouth-watering matchups all
around prognanovan Forest I'm so excited
for Eric geissy Abdus the Torah of yovi
I mean any game involving Notre back
abdusitorov is just by definition going
to be exciting but Arjun is so fun to
watch yeah he's really been sharpening
his tools he's been playing razor sharp
chess and I agree with you he is
definitely a spectator favorite other
matchups that I'm particularly
fascinated by is Mark sudlu against
Fabiana caruana I think these two have
not played a classical match against
each other and well wherever you look
you know there are Duty pairings in
front of you
man kymer dingley Wren levonne Ronin
against Geary even the players who
aren't currently leading the tournament
I mean those games are still going to be
interesting we've had such a good
assortment of different kinds of
openings and different kinds of
positions to enjoy and of course the
quality of the chess has been high as
usual part of the reason for that is the
time control the time control in tata
steel is the most generous of any annual
super tournament the players have a
hundred minutes for the first 40 moves
then 50 minutes are added for the next
20 moves and on move 60 both players
receive an additional 15 minutes for the
rest of the game and of course there is
the 30 second increment 30 second bonus
that is added to each player's clock
every time they make a move starting
from move one so the time control is
generous we've had some seven and a half
hour rounds we've had some four hour
rounds I mean we've been all over the
map in terms of game length and I think
that's a good thing you know some games
finish a little earlier some games take
a while and no Rebecca justotorov
unmistakable there as he jots down
information about his opponent
levonaronian taking a seat always
flamboyant in the way that he dresses I
love it
[Laughter]
right okay that is level neronian yeah
there is no other player who dresses in
such a colorful style and I have to
admire the just the creativity you know
he's come here in a certain mood and I I
think that is an indicator of how he
will face off against Anish Anish is
incredibly well prepared and I'm
wondering how Lavon will try to crack
open anisha's Arsenal and uh there we
see Richard rapport to get sitting there
ready for the world champion to come to
the board and uh you kind of mentioned
it earlier
Richard Ripple has a really bad score
against Magnus Carlsen with the black
pieces I mean he's lost every single
game that he's played with black and
against the world champion so Magnus of
course must be feeling quite positive
and Richard report you know he's got to
break the streak eventually so I think
the statistics are on his side I don't
think there's a single reason and easily
identifiable reason that uh the now
Romanian Grandmaster has struggled
against the world champion Richard
report has been uh you know all over the
map in terms of his opening choices but
in the last couple of tournaments he's
played far more standard openings than
he did uh the first time he entered the
super GM Club he used to play the
craziest stuff with both colors
something tells me that against the
world champion he is not going to dip
his toes uh into too exotic of an
opening pool but we're going to see
first of all the question is what Magnus
is going to play C4 against nutterbeck
did not result in success are we going
to see something more mainstream such as
one E4 well we're about to find out
because the clocks are going to be
started any second you can see I think
all of the players have taken their
seats over in The Challengers and the
Masters
and Magnus isn't here yet of course you
know of course Magnus isn't here yet he
has to fashionably late
isn't it a sign of the world champions
that they come late isn't the kind of
psychological Ploy just to make your
opponent wait for you just to kind of
say Hey you waited for me I'm the one in
charge
um I can remember Gary Kasparov always
turned up late I mean primarily this was
to avoid all the photographers I wonder
and everyone getting ready and uh I have
to say that they did experiment a few
years ago with a zero tolerance policy
where if you were not at the board
when the Arbiters said start the clocks
that was it you lost and they go
handshake and there are off
opening with E4
and Gary not a surprise there E4 E5 he
is fine with a draw of the black pieces
but something tells me Lavon is going to
bring his A-game to the opening Knight
F3 Knight to C6 well we will not start
for Magnus is gay because the world
champion isn't here yet and in Italian
just a big surprise there Yogi I really
nobody thought we would see that opening
but Knight F6 from Anish giri Anish
refraining from the more standard Bishop
C5 and let's see if he puts his Bishop
on E7 no uh I spoke too soon we're back
to standard territory with Bishop C5
yeah and I wasn't really surprised that
the Lavon has been playing E4 I mean I
am surprised that it wasn't low pass I
uh this kind of
Italian Joker piano however you want to
call it is a little bit out of territory
for both of them and uh there we go D3
D6 and are we gonna see something Brave
and adventurous like we've seen in the
past with the bishop coming out to G5
are we going to see this is the kind of
I call it the Magnus approach A4 C3 take
as much space as you possibly can on the
queen side
this has been a Obsession at Super Grand
Master Level you said the name Magnus I
think he was really the first to
popularize this line but everybody is
playing the move A4 which used to be
pretty much unheard of I mean the old
approach is to tuck the bishop away on
B3 and then to play C3 but now this this
space grabbing approach on the queen
side with C3 and then B4 has been all
the rage now Black's Bishop is not in
danger Black's gonna play A6 for some
reason black rarely plays A5 in these
positions for reasons that I don't quite
understand fully maybe the B5 Square uh
is it you don't want to weaken but
there's a lot of positional subtleties
that hide below the surface in these
Italian positions and Gary taking the
first thing of the game
yeah and uh I have to say this is I've
in my opinion I feel that this opening
is perhaps one of the most complicated
openings it's so tense none of the minor
pieces get traded off early on and so
you're playing with a full set of uh
pieces and this just makes it very very
tense especially when you consider that
both sides don't have so much space and
the one thing that I found out is that
the game will eventually hinge on who
has the better bishop and there we can
see the world champion has entered the
building sat there and it was bored he's
getting ready to make his move what are
we gonna see
is he gonna be E4 D4 C4 Richard looks a
little bit peeved if I have to say
yeah like really are we are we really
doing this
Richard's and he's watching him write
down the information about the game
right can you just make a move already
can I already find out what you're gonna
play Maybe Magnus doesn't even know no
no no he's got a Justice pieces first
the knights have to be facing each other
ink Queen Bishop very methodical he's
not in a hurry
offered out of Pawns every piece has to
be adjusted and
oh yeah that's what I want to see
how we're using French from Richard
report report likes to play the French I
was gonna almost say pray the French uh
if he plays the French you might have to
pray because that would not be a very
wise choice against the world champion
but report really only one of the last
Super GMS who is still willing to play
something truly off beat even against
the strongest players in the world and
yeah not responding immediately
no he's certainly not and he does have a
big smile up his face as though he has a
surprise for us
and uh now Richard also
taking a pause having a think maybe this
is also a good psychological Ploy in
return make the world champion wait
after all Richard has waited for a while
it was but goes back to your story
yesterday if your opponent is one hour
late you do the same
a minute and 30 seconds
on this move now he obviously must have
expected you know Carlson has played E4
before in his life he might have
expected C4 or D4 uh and thought that
was more probable but obviously Richard
had decided before the game what he's
going to play against D4 so maybe he's
Gathering his nerves he's just
remembering his files you just never
know what the players are doing they're
not always just thinking about oh you
know E4 what a surprise I don't know
what to play I don't think it's that you
know I think it's they've made the
decision before the game
I mean you would certainly think that
um this has only happened to me once
actually that I haven't really predicted
what my opponent is going to play and
that was
it was my game against Fabi Karana and
so Fabi plays everything and so I just
had a look at the database and I was
like well what can I prepare and I had
seen that every single game that he had
had in that particular year I started E4
so I was like okay he's gonna play E4
he's gonna take me on on the one opening
that I have the caracon after all I'm as
predictable as they come and uh let's
battle it out in the advance so I spent
all morning and all the night before
just checking out my advance I was
actually really happy with the line I
had concocted
and I turn up and he's opens with D4 and
I'm like well that was my preparation
was just a complete waste of time and
Magnus is back and Richard has made his
move he too has opened with e45 903 and
are we going to see Knight F6 Petrov or
Knight C6
the Latvian Gambit no the petrol no no
no the Petrov and uh Richard kind of
saying hey I I want to play a solid game
of chess and now Magnus has to think
about what how he's going to respond
I mean of course Magnus have plenty of
experience in this in the world
championship match when then Napoleon
actually played this against him
yeah I mean the problem is she really
inaugurated a a second coming one could
say of the Pet Shop the Petro is a very
interesting popularity Arc it was all
the rage I would say in the first half
of the 2000s 2005-2006 Vision on Boris
gelfon they were playing it all the time
I mean they had like 10 games against
each other on on either side in the pet
shop then the Pet Shop really weighing
new ideas were discovered you know D4 in
this position uh became very popular and
then Jana palmyushi breathing new life
into some of those main lines and right
now the theoretical standing of the
Petrov is almost as uh healthy as as two
Knight C6 if not completely as healthy
it's it's a full-fledged opening and I
don't think white has found a real
advantage in the main lines in the last
couple of months so I'm excited to see
what Magnus is going to bring to the
table as he takes on E5 report is going
to respond with D6 this might be a good
opportunity Yogi to share the famous
story uh concerning vicious the shortest
game of his career I I know you know
what I'm talking about I I do know
exactly what you're talking about I
can't quite remember the moves though
but uh it's a very famous story
so the story concerns vishyanand I think
this was the 80s uh after Knight F3
Knight takes E4 there's a very popular
move Knight to C3 Magnus might play it
and in that position Knight F3 Knight
takes E4 Knight take Knight C3 uh there
was a game between two grand Masters
which went Bishop C8 to F5 and a draw
was agreed in that position and the game
was published in chess and format which
before the Advent of the internet was
the way in which Grandmasters learned
about what was popular and what
Grandmasters were playing was a
publication that contained uh all of the
theoretically important games and vician
on saw that game and decided to
reproduce this very interesting new move
in his game against Colombian Grand
Master Alonso Zapata but as it turns out
and I'm gonna make the moves on the
board here really really quickly after
Knight F3 Knight takes C4 Knight C3
Bishop F5 white has the move Queen to E2
and vishianan had no choice but to
resign because D3 threatens to win the
night and after Queen E7 the coup de
gras is Knight to D5 simply forcing the
queen back after which you lose your
knight now it turns out that the reason
Bishop F5 was featured in that other
Grand Master game which involved Larry
Christensen is that it was a
pre-arranged draw the players weren't
actually thinking about what they were
playing uh or whether it was good or not
so is she Anand he lost the game in four
moves as a grand master unfortunately
we're not gonna see this because Magnus
Carlson has deviated from the main path
with Knight E5 to D3
yeah he has and uh incidentally uh when
Magnus was tested on certain positions
and whether he could recognize them or
not he was shown just the beginning of
that game and he said that's uh uh
Zapata against uh Vichy Anand and it was
just incredible at the time I was like
oh my God how did he know that and uh
Knight D3 on the board Knight takes pawn
and now I'm guessing that Queen E2 is
going to be played or let me just check
the opening database Knight C3
Knight Knight C3 is another move I
wasn't displayed nicely it wasn't Knight
C3 played in the world championship
match between Magnus and Fabi
in 2000 yeah nice c3d5 is the line but
you're right Queenie two on the board
here so are we gonna get oh and Knight
F4 I think is is the move here if I
remember correctly setting up the exact
same trap uh as in the Zapata and on
game so maybe my story was pertinent
after all
yeah and uh Knight f4 on the board and
that is why Black's main move is
actually to push the pawn to C6 or if
he's feeling in a drawish mood and uh
just simply wants to establish a
blockade then he's just simply going to
go Knight C6
just start building those fences take it
into an end game
after Knight F6 I I don't quite
understand
why white is supposed to be better there
I guess it's a slight Advantage because
white can push the pawn to D4 in one
Fell Swoop White's got slightly better
development so Magnus rather than you
know going for something incredibly
sharp and there are very sharp lines in
the pet shop you don't have to trade
Queens he decides to stick what he's
most comfortable with which is a long
grinded out end game with a slight
Advantage he wants to play with no risk
he knows that he's not in great form
this tournament and uh when you're
struggling in sharp positions what you
often want to do is go for the types of
positions that you feel most comfortable
with I think that's exactly what we see
the world champion doing here
yeah suddenly but I have to say when you
are struggling
do you want to see an opening like the
Petrov when there are no Pawn imbalances
the pieces okay the white has a slight
Advantage there but it could fizzle out
very quickly
especially if black were well prepared
and uh knows exactly the path to
equality
yeah I mean I this is a surprising
Choice somewhat for the world champion I
take his comment about not having
chances to win the tournament with a
grain of salt and I I think if in so far
as Magnus still entertains prospects of
let's say finishing the top three he
cannot afford to make a quick draw this
game he has to he basically has to win
all of his white games starting with
this one and we will see if his strategy
uh Bears success but we've got a couple
of other interesting openings so let's
take a dive into our first bird's eye
view of the day eovi and we've got A
Feast for the eyes here
yeah I certainly do maybe we can start
with a tournament leader
um our nordeback he is playing with the
black pieces against Arjun arag icy
and uh we are seeing it looks like an E4
E5 scenario
yeah that is our second Petrov oh
another another Petrov
yep okay another Petrov so we've got a
lot of E4 e5s today let's count we've
got aronian Geary in the Italian
we've got gukesh so in an early D5 also
in Italian
so we've got one two three four E4 games
and then the other is either D4 or C4
chimer ding is a very interesting
opening which we'll get to in short
order but yeah the error guys have just
a tour of game went directly into a
somewhat less popular version of the
Petrov so
I agree let's let's take a closer look
at that one
yeah okay and uh go ahead
and uh okay the database is telling me
this actually has a name it's called the
steinens attack I didn't know this I'm
very bad with opening names how are you
when it comes to recalling those names
I'm okay with the sort of uh like I know
this is the Petra of but when you get
down to like move seven and eight I'm
always shocked by how many sub
variations I had names I'd never heard
of and sometimes you have the sinus
attacker yeah the capablanca setup and
they might have nothing to do with who
played the line first uh so I just
wonder who invents these names but
anyways uh let's rewind a little bit and
show how this was reached in this game
white did in fact play uh the second
most popular move before Knight takes E4
and D takes E5 already a deviation from
the standard Bishop F1 to D3 white takes
on E5 immediately there's a crazy line
here that goes Bishop C5 but black going
for the calmer approach with d75 and
whining white to take on passant but
that's totally toothless uh Eric is he
keeps the imbalance by developing his
Knight have a trade black develops his
Bishops grabs control of the center
white does the same and Bishop G4 rookie
one to defend the E5 Fawn in Black
castles one thing I'll point out before
I pass it to you uh eov is that Bishop
takes H7 check people are always tempted
by this move it doesn't do anything with
the bishop on G4 pinning tonight if you
play Bishop H7 and the Knight G5 we'll
just take your knight and you'll emerge
uh two pieces down so
hasn't blundered anything visually his
position looks pretty Pleasant I have to
say
yeah and uh the first pressing question
that I would be thinking about if I had
the white pieces would be very simple
how on Earth are you gonna unravel from
this pin this bishop pinning the Knight
and the Queen and it's not an easy thing
to deal with to begin with because you
don't you don't really want to be going
H3 G4 unless unless you're feeling
really Brave and some of us are not in
that category
and then the other option is just maybe
just a uh just to play around that pin
just developed the queen to E2 and then
put the Rooks in the center but there
will come a time when it's what happens
next and I do know that grand Masters
and in fact strong players are just
obsessed with where's the progress
what's my plan you've got to know what
to do because it's very difficult to
play a planless position
it is indeed and uh
you know in terms of formulating a plan
you often want to First identify the
area of the board on which you want to
operate and to piggyback off of what
you're saying it's it's hard to identify
White's area of superiority I would say
that maybe the center is is narrowly the
e-file is is really the only area of the
board in which we can operate freely so
I'm thinking about a move like E5 E6 at
some point maybe start with H3 and then
follow up with E6 the downside of course
is that if you allow f66 to pin only
intensifies and the pressure on the
Knight becomes truly unpleasant
so Eric I see taking his time here
obviously there are still games in the
database in this position and you know
you can confirm that but this is not the
kind of position I would I would want to
have with white if I wasn't very well
acquainted with sort of the typical
plans
yep the uh
there are no too many games of databases
in fact I'm just looking at it and
nothing has been played
um Castle's is a new move but I'm sure
I mean in in the previous games black
had always kind of developed the queen
for the queen to see seven or D7 but I'm
sure it will transpose into something
um I I agree with you it kind of does
feel like a standard position but also
if white doesn't do something now I'm
really afraid that black is simply going
to step forward with a queen connect the
Rooks and uh like you say you just get
good development and at the right time
break open with a potential F6
yeah and looking pretty pretty good
forever
yeah no I I am quite worried actually
and I
I'm just thinking of ways to do
something you know
I'm the kind of player that cannot do
anything I can't just sit there and do
nothing I want to do something so I was
thinking first of all first obvious move
is actually just attack the bishop just
ask it what are you gonna do and if
black plays Bishop takes Knight you
breathe a sigh of relief and you go
thank you for solving my problems but
okay H3 on the board but black will not
be so accommodating black will of course
step back with a bishop to H5 and here
it comes I mean how are you going to
unravel
well there's also the not so remote
possibility that black plays Bishop G4
to E6 because your idea could be okay
I'll unpin your knight but where is your
knight going to go C5 is controlled G5
that's the juicy Square that's
controlled so Bishop E6 looks pretty
appealing to me as well Bishop H5 maybe
White's idea is to reposition the dark
squared Bishop to F4 and open up the D2
Square for the queen and say at some
point I'm going to let you take on F3
and ruin my Pawn structure but on the
flip side that opens the G file and if
you assemble your pieces uh smartly uh
and expeditiously on the on the king
side
you can often turn that visual damage
around to your favor by using the G file
for attacking purposes so the email bar
seems to believe that white is slightly
better but I really think that in these
kinds of positions it's really all about
who understands the typical ideas better
yeah absolutely and as Brewing up for a
nice fight and if Arjun has anything to
do with it I think he will sharpen it up
by the time we next come around
he will indeed and we will leave notrec
Abdus to ponder where he wants to put
his Bishop he will certainly not take
that Knight but Bishop B6 and Bishop H5
are two serious candidate moves that he
has to choose from well we've got a
couple of other games to choose from
Let's uh take a look once again at our
bird's eye view maybe we can look at one
of the games that did not start with
e2e4 I will point out that in the
Iranian Geary game on your top right we
had an exchange of Bishops on E3 leading
to a very interesting and typical
Italian structure with that semi-open f
file in that pawn mass in the center so
we will take a look at that game as well
but I want some variety of you so I'll
let you choose between our our one D4
and one C4 games which one catches your
eye okay it will definitely be the
pregnant answer against Jordan van
Forest game because that one to me is
incredibly interesting because
pragmander has pushed forward with C4 C5
he's committed his structure and now
we're going to see a maneuvering battle
here is going to be whether black can
first of all organize the Breakthrough
E5 and secondly whether he can find a
good role for his Knight on D7 because
at the minute the Knight on D7 looks
like it's a good piece but actually it's
not doing too much it's just helping
with E5 and uh I I like these type of
positions for black I have to say most
people think that they're very passive
but that suits me fine
yeah it's incredibly solid I mean it's
almost like this game from a slav in
fact I'm going to rewind all the way
back because there are only eight moves
in this was a slav White playing the
very calm E3 variation of course Knight
C3 uh is one could argue the more
principled approach but E3 is also
theoretically topical black gets the
bishop out and this is the downside of
playing E3 if your knight was on C3 here
then Queen D1 to B3 essentially refutes
the bishop F5 line here Queen B3 is not
as effective in Black plays the kind of
chabanenko approach with A6 preparing B5
which he will play after between B3 so
this is super interesting actually
yeah sorry to interrupt but if we go a
bit earlier I'm I'm really surprised by
Bishop D2 because my understanding of
these type of positions is that you've
got to get something in return for the
light Square Bishop entering into The
Fray
huh you gotta chase it away
actually I'm talking night as soon as E6
Knight goes to H4
hmm here here here go after the bishop
now I'm not a slav player
but frequently in these types of
positions
frickling these types of positions I see
black going like Bishop to E4 induce F3
and then drop back to G6 maybe this type
of idea is what prognanada wasn't too
attracted by but I I don't know how to
evaluate these types of structures
yeah these ones are real blood vests I
mean they're great to play for both
sides you know it becomes about whether
F3 is an advantage sometimes you even
put your King on F2 I prefer to play the
position with the queen coming out to
either C2 or B3 and castling the king to
probably I would put the queen on B3 at
Ben Castle the king lengthways and then
it becomes like a real race and you can
see how excited I am about this position
because suddenly I've sprung forward and
sitting upright in my chair and
they're just fantastic because you're
always asking black what are you going
to do with your king if you go to the uh
Castle King side then you're gonna of
course just crack open the position with
H4 H5
I don't really care so much about
material is just all about exerting
dominance in the center and King safety
I think it's a great description and
these positions are very exciting
they're popular but instead Prague
taking a different approach Bishop D2
and then he locks up the center with C5
and now strikes at blacks
seemingly impervious Pawn Mass on the
queen side with a2a4 and you could say
well what's the point of this move B5 is
the most well protected point on the
board but the idea of a peace sacrifice
on B5 is totally not out of the question
in fact if white plays Bishop B2 and
then goes kingside taking three times on
B5 leads to a Pawn on C5 upon on B2 and
with blacks pieces relatively Passive A
connected Pawn mask a connected series
of passers on the queen side can be an
incredibly dangerous Force so I think
Prague is setting up some of those
exciting ideas for later in the game
yeah I I agree with you I definitely
think that is what he's uh angling for
with breaking open the position I also
think he probably was forced
strategically to do such a thing because
otherwise black was probably going to
play Knight to E4 it free up some some
uh space and also just you have to
follow the rule when you have these
cramped positions of exchanging pieces I
mean I think it was the American
Grandmaster Jesse cry who kind of CR had
this expression you send your kids to
boarding school because you know when
you have too many kids and you have a
small house
you can't everyone gets in each other's
way so send them off to boarding school
remove them off the board and uh
I do feel that we are going to be in for
a lovely middle game fight here
yeah I've been if so impressed with
prague's uh composure and obviously his
form uh in this tournament not only his
his black win against England which has
been the crown achievement of his
tournament so far but just the the
stability and the maturity with which
he's handled the other games we we kind
of almost take it for granted now that
these young players with not a lot of
experience in super tournaments are
going to handle themselves as well as
Prague has but that's not something that
we should be taking for granted and I
think now more than at any other time in
chess history uh young players players
from the new Rising generation are just
able to you know dip their toes into
this Cesspool of super GMS and players
who've been playing these tournaments
for over a decade and just handle
themselves incredibly well it's it's
just such an exciting time to watch this
intergenerational battle it's how to
steal uh is the best place uh to do it
so A4 by Prague and he's building up a
little time Advantage here we will keep
a close eye on this middle game but uh
I'm on the same page Toby this is gonna
be a very exciting one yeah I I think so
too and uh so where else shall we dive
into next
should we check out for a second okay
yeah definitely
and uh which one catches your eye so the
first move that kind of the first game
that kind of catches my eye is uh the
one on the bottom right uh Vincent
climber who of course has been
struggling playing against ding Loren
and of course ding is World Championship
candidate and uh he's gonna be facing a
big match in April when he plays for the
world championship title and of course
this means he has had to hide some prep
so for the first time in quite a long
time I think yesterday we saw ding start
off with E4
I haven't seen that one in a while you
know his Dynamic D4 Ding and that's how
I've always kind of called him and if
you go to this game I can just see that
Vincent climber has stepped forward with
a pawn and uh when one side initiates a
pawn breakthrough that always makes me
very excited
yeah and what upon breakthrough it is
the most ambitious one on the board now
this obviously did not come from one D4
Vince and kymer playing a very creative
opening uh a a ready is how this game
reached this position so let's rewind
all the way back and see how he reached
this unbalanced middle game we had
Knight f3d5 and E3 very popular system
where white delays the move d4 and you
often see white playing this with with
C4 so kind of a very cagey it these
openings they sometimes transpose into
D4 openings uh but Vincent actually
played this without D4 the pawn is on D3
so Knight F6 there's C4 similar to a
Queen's Gambit decline but different in
spirit with white often trying to fee
and keto the dark squirt Bishop here
white takes an even more creative
approach being ketoing the light squared
Bishop G3 you don't usually combine E3
and G3 but hey these 2700s they can do
whatever they want they can eat ice
cream at 10 in the morning it's all
Justified Castle's castles okay ding
playing Pretty Natural moves and Vincent
kymer rather than playing D4 he plays D3
and E4 this is how we've reached the
current position ding pondering how to
resolve the central tension and I will
say uh Yogi that the stakes are very
very high for black it's so easy to
blunder in a position like this you
might say oh let's go after the D3 Pawn
let's play Knight C5 not a good idea
because of E5
and after Knight takes D3 it's not the
end of the story but at the very least
white can get two pieces for The Rook
with a move like he takes F6 and When
the Smoke Clears white also snaps off
the pawn on D5 but Tempo this does not
look appetizing in the least does it no
that certainly doesn't so you do have to
be incredibly careful as you've
mentioned
and uh well
and also now you know there's a pawn
breakthrough so this means that there's
a potential for capturing a pawn in the
center and this will be going round and
rounding's head should he play this
position
by exchanging pawns and then resolving
the tension along the long diagonal or
is the time just to keep the tension
there in the center step back with his
bishop and the reason why I'm suggesting
stepping back with the bishop because no
actually Bishop sorry the other Bishop
because the the poor I was protecting my
Pawn in the middle
I don't I don't know why I thought of
Bishop f8 I I didn't realize that E5 was
in a threat so I didn't count the
Defenders and attackers you know uh this
is what old age does too
[Laughter]
no I was just thinking that and and the
reason I wasn't a big fan of playing C6
is primarily because this introduces the
option that white captures on D5 himself
and after Bishop B7 the capture on D5 is
far less appealing because it leaves
white with this this runt on D3 so it
was a really kind of maximalist approach
that I was going for I wanted it all I
wanted the piece play and I wanted uh
White to weaken their own Pawn structure
wow that's just that's just too
ambitious I mean you're probably known
for trying to squeeze the most out of
each position
man what he's taking his time though
he's taking a a very significant think
what could be some of his other
candidate moves well obviously you have
to ponder the idea of taking on e4 and
then putting the Knight not on C5 which
walks into the fork but also on E5 so
you could try to take this approach of
yielding Pawn control of the center but
occupying the center with your pieces
and aiming for D3 with your knight so
Bishop B7 nte I think are the two main
candidate moves that he's uh that he's
struggling to decide between right now
yeah and uh incidentally whenever I have
the option to capture I always think
who's going to benefit from this trade
and uh
say if you were to apply this rule to
this particular position I do feel that
this benefits white slightly more than
it benefits black because suddenly this
bishop on okay and we see Pawn takes
Pawn on the board
and I'm fully expecting the pawn to
recapture I just thought that the bishop
on G2 now has a beautiful empty diagonal
to start looking especially that Rook on
A8
obviously the threat is uh much more
dangerous than the execution but still
I kind of liked whites
position here better
yeah I think I think whites get better
central control and black will need to
play tactically and dynamically in order
to justify yielding a greater share of
the center Vincent what's interesting is
he's not recapturing automatically I
would bet my house on on D takes E4 and
when you see players taking their time
on an obvious move uh they're not always
thinking about the current move they
could be calculating a line two or three
two or three moves into the variation so
they already know what they're going to
play but Max irva uh the Dutch world
champion he always advised to play the
obvious moves for us as tempting as it
may be to take your time just play the
moves you know you need to play and then
once you reach a position it's easier to
think about and there's Knight E5 so
ding going for one of the approaches
that we outlined
yeah and uh well this is very
interesting battle actually because the
scent is all going to hinge on whether
white can
actually just uh off say for instance we
see a capture of Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight if white can get
away with doing things like F4 E5 I
think white has a fantastic position
obviously that's a little bit weakening
and I I again it's the English thing of
doing an understatement it is very
weakening it's slightly ever so slightly
weakening it's such a bad habit and I
don't know why I do it all the time but
uh yeah it's it's too risky right now to
do it but white will be preparing it and
it doesn't matter if it comes in an end
game or in a net middle game once it's
prepared it will be very very dangerous
yeah it definitely will be and you can
also put a bishop on F4 either
immediately or after Knight takes E5
which is slightly less weakening but
tries to do the same thing dislodge
whatever piece appears on E5 whether
it's a knight or a bishop after the
exchange so another Rich complicated
middle game in uh the German
Grandmasters game against uh the world
championship Challenger okay I think as
Vincent Ponders his next move a good
opportunity for us to quickly get back
to the bird's eye view but I'm pretty
insistent that that we take a look a
closer look at aronian's game against
era in the world champions game on the
the right hand side of your screen you
can see Magnus played F3 and Then
followed up with D4 so we are going to
be very likely to see a long drawn out
grinded out End Game World Champion
going for what makes him comfortable
Eric icy with an interesting move on the
top left Bishop D3 to F5 trying to
restrict Black's mobility in the center
and Aviano caruana para maxulu have a
pretty standard rogosin UOB so you think
it's a good idea to visit aronian land
yes and the reason I'm quite satisfied
with myself and a bit smug was I had
noticed when I'd been researching this
particular Parry that Lavon always likes
to play Bishop E3 and allow this capture
and take back with the pawn
I just noticed that most players kind of
prepare it they kind of put the Rook on
E1 and then they will play Bishop E3 not
our man aronian instead he just uh says
I'm okay with double pawns I will take
the activity of the Rook on F1
so I personally always feel like the
trade on A3 favors white because I like
open files over Pawn structure at all it
always feels to me that Knight H4 Knight
F5 becomes a lot more imposing and scary
for black once the f file is open you
can see Lavon taking the Slow Roll
approach lifting The Rook up to F2 well
clearly I think preparing to move the
queen out of the way and then double on
the f file he is not hiding his
intentions and the Italian is so
interesting because you can play it very
positionally but when the f file opens
it often gets incredibly tactical and
the fact that we only have Knights on
the board I think is adding a layer of
complexity and originality uh to this
position so we'll definitely keep
exploring I also want to explore some of
their fascinating head-to-head stats
because levonne aronian holds a monster
lead over Anish Gary he has not lost a
single classical game over 26 meeting
meetings yo that is honestly one of the
craziest stats that I've heard over the
last couple days yeah I must admit when
I first read that stat I was absolutely
shocked I was like no that is not
correct because Gary must have won right
I mean they played they've been playing
each other in classical chess since
2011.
Gary must have done something he must
have played a great game somewhere and
uh well the answer is no he's lost
um quite a few and he's not yet to win
but we have seen a scenario where Gary's
been like worse or sorry we've seen a
situation where Gary's been like that
before when he faced off against Magnus
Carlsen he hadn't won a classical game
against Carlson for over 12 years
and uh we just saw in game four that of
course Gary did in fact beat Magnus and
he kind of had this kind of comment
which really struck me he said you know
he knew at some stage he had to win a
game it was just a question of numbers
and maybe this is the same scenario with
aronian you know
anisha's just waiting for his moment to
come but if I take a look at the
position
I'm thinking Hmm look maybe not today
yeah it's it's it would be hard to
imagine I would maybe I'm jumping the
gun here but Lavon has exactly the kind
of situation that makes him comfortable
and he's just his experience level not
only in chess but also in the tournament
is is vast I mean he's a four-time Tata
champion this is the 10th appearance and
Anish Guri has had to share frustrations
and Tata steel he's never won the
tournament but he's a five-time
runner-up that is nothing to sneeze at
but yobi you mentioned that maybe this
is the game maybe this is the year and I
think that's how Anisha is approaching
it is approaching it from a statistical
point of view I've never won a game
against Lavon statistics are on my side
okay I mean this is my 27th game against
the guy eventually the gods have to get
on my side exactly eventually something
has to crack and uh yeah and looking at
the statistics again we can kind of see
that Iranian has actually beaten a niche
twice and if I can say and uh and I
onion making his tenth appearance and I
saw an interview with uh Lavon where
they asked him about his age and you
know the fact that he was a four-time
champion and he stays and he kind of
answered that someone had called him
uncle levonne and he was like no oh no
one's Uncle thank you very much I'm like
the youngest one here
and I thought way to go live on that is
the mindset and uh they also groomed him
about playing kids and uh he said no no
he corrected a statement he said he
never said he hated playing kids he said
he hated kids
oh that is brutal even though I think he
just had a kid
he has just had a baby yeah
that is disturbing him but Lavon is
great he's he you there's certain
players that you can just count on to
provide entertainment every time they
give an interview like you just know
that they're going to be game for you
know saying something interesting and
you know just filling the often tense
environment at chess tournaments with a
dose of levity and Lavon is definitely
one of those players okay what
conclusions can we make about the
position as Lavon drops his Knight not
to H4 but back to D2 and the reason I
think why is Knight H4 can be met with
the move G6 and when you don't have a
dark spot Bishop it's very very hard to
uh exploit a consequent weakening of the
dark Square so he goes the other way
Knight f2d2 opens the f file what do you
think he wants you over this you want
Queen F3 Queen G3 just sort of
assembling his pieces on the king cider
is there a more subtle uh reconstruction
of his pieces that he has his eye on
here yeah I mean I was surprised by
Knight D2 because first of all it's a
backward night move there's a very
difficult to spot and secondly it made a
Superfluous night sitting there on D2
maybe
um but
I just kind of had an idea that maybe
this Knight could actually jump back to
F1 and then G3 you know Grand Masters
are very big fans of over protecting and
then once the Knight has relocated to G3
then maybe the queen will get out of the
way the Rook will come to F1 and there
will be pressure like Freddie Mercury
and David Bowie saying I love that song
by the way
I'm gonna have to listen to it during
the break just to pretend that I you
know to fill the the vast gaps in my
cultural upbringing you've never heard
of it before
you never heard it I can't believe that
believe it no I mean I think you know me
well by now though I mean most
references that are worth their salt
like right over my head unfortunately uh
okay I'm sorry you definitely have to
listen to it maybe you've heard of it
I'm sure you have probably probably one
of those things that awaken an old
memory in me but Knight ftd2 very
interesting move it's getting anishagiri
to settle into a think and that gives us
a perfect opportunity to refill our
coffee cups and take our first break of
the day we are 45 minutes on the nose uh
through round seven this is the halfway
point of the Tata steel Marathon you
have a beautiful look at that bustling
playing haul all of the open players The
Spectators Milling about it's a
wonderful atmosphere and we are uh
getting ready for just an amazing round
as the games are slowly moving their way
out of the opening and toward some
fascinating middle games okay you're
watching Tata steel chess 2023 the 85th
edition of this historic tournament we
will be back with more coverage of round
seven in just a couple of minutes
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on
akam is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
montage and a view of the playing Hall
at the one and the only Wake On Zay Tada
steel chess tournament it's the 85th
year that this incredibly prestigious
and storied event Goes On It Is by all
accounts unanimously the tournament that
all of the top chess players and all of
the chess fans look forward to the most
every year we have a nice little
historical uh assortment effects for you
the inaugural year was 1938 before World
War II and moved to the town of iconzay
from I believe the larger city of
Pfeiffer Reich that's located basically
next door in 1968 and it's been called
Todd of Steel since 2011 Yogi it just it
when you breathe the air in vikon Zay
you just feel uh the weight of all of
the players in the world champions that
have gone through the rite of passage of
playing in vikante
yeah I have to say tattoo steel if I can
say it is the tournament to play if you
are a top player I mean it is where you
want to go to to live breathe chess
amongst the greats for just over two
weeks and uh yeah we can see the playing
haul I mean it's completely completely
packed with players I mean that is a
site that really gladdens my heart I
mean there are hundreds of people all
just in one room enjoying the game and
it's just about this just coming
together how chess connects us and uh
you have never seen so many people just
crowded around watching the top section
and that's beautiful to see because
usually they're kind of a cordoned off
and uh maybe they're on a stage
somewhere and maybe one or two players
are allowed to go there but here no the
players are right there among the the
bustle of the crowds and there we see
param walking up and down and everyone
can see everyone can get a bite of that
atmosphere it's just magical
there's a meme to be built out of this
someone says you know classical chess
OTB chess is dead hold my beer just a
view of the playing Hall uh with all of
the spectators that I taught a steal but
another reason I think that we all look
forward to uh this tournament so much
you'll be as we as we take a look at the
bird's eye view and adjust our eyes to
all these fascinating positions we get
virtually no quick draws in tata steel
and we definitely don't get any Berlin
draws would you say that that
substantively contributes uh to this
atmosphere of Fighting Chess and why do
you think that nobody comes to Tata
steel uh you know willing to conserve
energy with those quick draws that we've
all gotten used to
yeah I think it's because the organizers
are quite strict here and they say you
do a Berlin draw I ain't inviting you
back to the tournament so I mean that is
definitely something that puts off the
players but also you know there's a
reputation if you've been invited to if
I can say it means that you they've
acknowledged your fighting Spirit the
way that you play chess your talent and
you have to honor that you have to honor
look how many people are crowding around
to watch you and I I do feel it's it's
disrespectful when you've been invited
and so many people are just watching
your games in eager anticipation for you
just Agree to Agree a quick 13 move draw
that's been played before come on
use your brain and start pushing pieces
of wood I mean that's what the crowd
wants we want entertainment and so far
the players have delivered an every
single score
no you're I think that was very well
explained and you know this just reminds
me of of this tournament I've shared the
story before but I played a tournament
in in Corsica a beautiful place by the
way a couple years ago and it was the
first sermon I played in which there was
there wasn't a 40 move draw rule where
you can't offer a draw until move 40.
that's standard fare now in most
tournaments including the US
Championship but you couldn't offer
draws at all draw offers were forbidden
um if you offer to draw you potentially
both opponents could be forfeited and I
remember in the penultimate round I was
already feeling tired and I forced a
quick draw against Alexander reschenko
uh strong Ukrainian Grandmaster I went
for a theoretical line that leads to a
force drop we draw the game we signed
the score shoot of course repetition uh
cannot be forbidden but the organizer he
followed us out of the playing Hall and
I could see him just angrily huffing and
puffing as he walked up to us and there
was a language barrier but I think we
both understood the gist of what he was
saying and at first I was sort of
righteously angry like I can play
whatever I want but then you know I saw
it from his perspective and I put myself
in his shoes you know this is a guy who
organizes uh this tournament every year
all of the fans look forward to it we're
playing on the top board and you know
people are are totally justified uh to
be peeved when there's a game that says
anti-climactic as that and I don't think
that you can ever expressly forbid quick
draws I think that would be overstepping
the bounds but it is totally fair to say
that you know some of those games can
can definitely be somewhat disrespectful
to to the fans that take time out of
their days to cheer on their favorite
player and and watch on watch them
Fighting Chess
yeah uh I agree with you and actually
this uh no offering draws act adds a
very unique twist to the game because I
I'll I have also played in Corsica uh
quite a long time ago and it was the
very first year that they had introduced
this Fighting Chess no drawers allowed
and one of my friends was playing Vichy
Anand and vishi had a terrible opening
and my friend emerged like three pawns
sorry my friend emerged three pawns up
but before she held on you know as these
super Grand Masters world champions
former world champions tend to do and uh
three pawns down became two pawns down
and my friend really wanted to offer a
draw and then two pawns down became one
pawned out and he was like oh this silly
no draw offered because his position was
still so good that he knew that Mishi
would take it but you know of course the
flow kind of continued and uh if she won
in the end and I I just like the fact
that you are forced to kind of just
fight it out and let the position play
out to its natural conclusion and if
this means that you know your four pawns
up and you
steadily decrease the advantage to no
pawns up then so be it
you just gotta roll with it play the
game out the way it's meant to be played
and speaking of playing the game out I
just wanted to update everybody on
what's going on in this fascinating
middle game slugfest between aronian and
Gary we had some fascinating moves here
uh we saw Rook F2 and Knight fd2 here's
the answer to the mystery Yogi the night
was going and it was going to be won and
Gary does the same thing he goes to B8
this is I mean they're setting up their
pieces for the next game you know uh
enough is enough they've played 14 moves
let's move on no Knight bd7 by Geary and
they're going to different places for
different reasons aronian is going to C3
to challenge the D5 Square the reason
Geary moved his Knight out of C6 was for
prophylactic reasons he plays the move
C6 to restrict this Knight as much as
possible but clearly the downside of
that move is that he introduces serious
weaknesses to his center of the uh the
D6 spawn and of course to the queen side
the B6 pawn and we just have a very rich
middle game here
ah totally and I could not have
predicted that those set of moves in any
lifetime I just did not think that that
night was headed to B1 and that Gary
would also copy uh unbelievable such
imaginative play I mean
I kind of like what both sides have just
done you know I really like the fact
that black Snipes are now defending each
other which does mean that if need be
and each can now kind of just move his
Rooks over to the queen side and perhaps
initiate some kind of play there I also
really like what Lavon has done because
levono said well now that I've tied up
my nights look how lovely they are
sitting together as you've highlighted
the queen can come out the root can come
out and it can be gone zahoy over there
on the right side
for sure Queen could swing around to G3
and if I had to choose a side here I
think I would choose white I think white
has the more exciting end of the bargain
here uh the Richer King side play but
you also have to be very careful uh
about not allowing D5 Queen F3 also uh
prevents that move so I'm definitely
strongly predicting Queen F3 and we will
see if Lavon can squeeze something out
of this middle game but we've got some
other fascinating middle games uh in a
few of the other games the world
champion in Richard reports still have
queens that are staring at each other
we've got to stand a good old school
standoff on the e-file Richard has just
developed his Knight to A6 he's I wonder
where that Knight is going uh it's going
to B4 and it's going potentially to C2
so interesting game there and prognan
the van Forest you were talking about
that game during the break that game is
going off the rails
yeah it's insane that game you know
black has already broken out in the
center and Pregnant has uh immediately
issued issued a counter threat so it's
all happening there um shall we have a
look at one of the games we haven't seen
um I'm thinking about uh Mike sudlu
against Fabi or the other one is gukesh
against the Wesley where Wesley has
expanded quite significantly on the
queen side
I vote uh we look at Maxwell carwana
gukesh Wesley I still think is is within
the range of a relatively normal Italian
structure where black has played D5 and
black has a bigger chunk of the center
but that E5 Pawn is under serious
pressures kind of assembling his pieces
in hyper modern style to attack black
center now maxillo caruana is an old
school ragozan structure with that
Knight on C6 somewhat misplaced because
it blocks the C Pawn from building up
that uh Pawn chain we often see in Queen
spawn openings but on his next move if
Fabiano caruana can move his Knight back
to E7 and then play C6 and find a nice
spot for the Knight on the king side I
think he's officially solved all of his
opening problems so Parham exudo really
just has like one tempo that he should
try to use to make this process
difficult I like the look of Queen C2
you'll be to prevent the knight from
moving away maybe Fabi just plays her
kc8 oh but then Bishop takes A6 is a
nasty tactic
yeah definitely uh if this Knight on C6
is really makes a bad impression
actually for the for all the reasons
that you highlighted I can't stress it
enough you know night should not be in
front of its pawns and uh I I like what
you say you've got to tie that Knight
down you've got to prevent it from
moving and also you know the pawn
structure really is just like a Queen's
Gambit declines and an exchange
variation and all those rules are at
play in this particular position so if
the Knight does eventually find itself a
safe spot and the black porn were to get
to C6 then Fabi has sorry maxulu has got
ideas of playing B4 perhaps they're
trying to launch a minority attack and
other things that he can do is just
simply clamp down on Black's uh pieces
and just restrict them and I'm thinking
of that light Square Bishop you know
just prevent it from having any squares
so that's why I love your queen C2 move
I think is fantastic I think it fits in
with all the rules and of course Also
let's not forget that white has a strong
hold on C5
and I really like Max sudlu's position I
mean the computer might say pretty level
but I think on a practical level maxilla
is better
agreed completely and we saw Fabi
walking past the camera there he's not
at the board this is an unpleasant
position I think the evil bar well it is
showing a slight Advantage right Queen
to B3 by Parham he doesn't drag it all
the way back to C2 it's like that famous
anecdote Uh Russian players like to
share about Vladimir simagan uh an old
Soviet Grandmaster he plays E4 C6 his
opponent plays D4 he plays D6 they said
Vladimir you know what was that why
didn't you play D5 I didn't have a have
the strength to push the pawn two
squares so Parham didn't have the
strength to bring the queen back to C2
but in all seriousness I really like
Queen B3 he is inducing the move Rook ab
and then I think Queen C2 is even
stronger because Bishop takes C6 Bishop
takes A6 actively becomes a threat in
that position
um yeah I agree with you
um is the big question though
um is black obliged to play over kb8
because
I kind of we've been talking about this
night wanting to get away from the C6
Square it's it stood in front of his own
Pawn so the first move that I would
think about is I would love to get away
with Knight A5 attack the queen and if I
can put that Knight on C4 I am so happy
so the way I see it there's Queen before
but then you can maybe take and go back
to C6 so let's say I go Queen C3 and
you're saying stick the Knight on C4
yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to live
like this um because this is kind of a
common idea in in certain like Queen's
gamber decline lines and they if you
manage to get a A5 A4 in then you are
riding high with that Knight on C4
and if I take and if you take
and you can defend the pawn with B5 or
even or even in this position the Knight
is actually under the X-ray and black I
think solves all of his problems with C5
94 and CD counter-attacking the queen
here white is already worse
yeah okay
so if I'm not taking on C4 can I go B3
things get a little sharp here taking
there and then after Queen takes born
yeah you can even take and go B5 Maybe
yes idiot B5 yeah immediate B5 I kind of
like
you know who doesn't like it though
oh I can also I can also put the queen
on B4 as well I kind of keep the Queens
on the board and then threaten Rick
Casey eight
that's an excellent move no white can't
be better here
hmm
so not B3 not Bishop C4 I'd really like
this idea I think that is the serious
downside of trying to provoke Rook ba
you might have walked yourself into a
maneuver that actually improves the
opponent's position
well if it works I mean if it doesn't
work then
okay it's out of bounds but this is the
dream kind of response to Queen B3
yeah and I think for Fabi when you get
into these unpleasant situations you
want to CH I think the proper expression
is changing the course of the game you
want to do something that poses a new
set of challenges to your opponent and
Rook 8b8 is just too obedient right this
goes right down the path that white has
carved out for himself Knight A5 Knight
C4 really changes the tenor of the game
and it says hey I'm not just willing uh
to accept that my position is passive
and I'm not going to do what you say I'm
going to try to get active myself
and queen B3 might have offered black a
a rare and an opportunity that he won't
have again to whip up some activity
among his ranks I like Knight A5
yeah no it was just an interesting idea
because I've had I played this type of
position with the white pieces um it was
hampi Connor who did this to me she put
her Knight on C4 and then she followed
it through with a5a4 and I was like um
my position is not good and then Maria
Mazi took did exactly the same thing I
was like okay
the first time it happens you know okay
fine but the second time it happens
you've got to learn your lessons you'll
be so that's why I'm like immediately
looking at Knight A5 trying to get away
with it
for sure I I think Knight A5 might
really breathe some new life into
Fabiano caruana's position plenty of
time on the clock for both players he's
going to continue
pondering his next course of action and
we are going to take another look at the
bird's eye view Lavon grabbing control
of the center over on the top right with
D3 D4 very ambitious move the aragaisi
Abdus tour of game top left continues to
percolate as Black's Queen makes its way
to the queen size striking at the B-2
Pawn I mean wherever you turn you'll be
we're at that point in the round we're
one hour in and change where a lot of
the games really are starting to heat up
and get richer and richer as they enter
the middle game phase oh the kymer game
also getting very sharp Queen comes out
to A4 hitting the bishop on A6 looks
like ding has to be very careful to keep
the balance in the center
oh so much excitement
um
yeah my vibe is to kind of go to the
abduser tour of game but then I think we
should go back and check up on the world
champion and see how he's doing against
Richard report because there is still
that standoff with the Queens
and both sides are kind of shaping
themselves up for the end game and
what's going to happen there
it's a very kind of weird position King
F2 Knight A6 moves that you don't see
played on like move 10 or 11 very
commonly so let's jump into that game
real quick and then perhaps we could uh
take a look at our final game between
gukash and Wesley so King to F2 was the
last move what is the idea well Magnus
is preparing for the end game when you
have a queen standoff like this it's
almost a bygone conclusion that the
Queens are going to get traded at some
point so neither player wants to be the
one to admit oh neither player wants to
be the one to trade Queens themselves
and help the opponent bring a piece into
the game uh in both cases either the
light or the dark squared bishop and so
you're kind of skirting around the edges
and preparing yourself for the end game
bringing the king to the center
developing your pieces but what's
interesting is that Magnus doesn't care
about the prospect of Knight to B4 Yogi
he thinks that that move isn't dangerous
why might that be
it looks dangerous to me I wouldn't have
allowed that night ever to reach there
but uh the only way that we can actually
determine whether it's dangerous is to
put that night on our analysis board
take it put it on B4 and okay okay it's
a big threat of a knight C2
and then Knight taking the D4 Pawn so
you've got to handle that somehow
and
perhaps Queen D2 it's his idea declining
the queen trade
yeah yeah but can you not just go Knight
C2
and then okay
ah your ideas this move
oh very good
and queen takes and at the end When the
Smoke Clears not only do I win the queen
but then I'm gonna come back and pick up
the Knight yeah so this looks untenable
for black
so if you're not going Knight C2 why can
Castle queenside though and get yeah I
was gonna I was gonna say that
okay because it does feel it's slightly
artificial what white is doing you know
the queen isn't looking at his own dark
Square Bishop
now now Nazi too
I'll go Rook A2 and try to go B4
okay and then C5 I want I want to rescue
that night out of Dodgeville
um I realize that I'm giving away some
squares but
that's a great move because if I go here
then you have this hidden check takes
takes and going H4 and queen takes D4
winning the pawn with checks so we
talked about magnets going for what
makes him comfortable Yogi we were we're
sure that this is going to get into an
end game I still think there's a high
probability one of the sides takes the
queen but for the first time there is a
small inkling of hope that the Queens
will be kept on the board Magnus will be
the one to say you had your chance to
take my queen now I'm depriving you of
that opportunity but man this does look
very flimsy for White Queen on D2 also
blocks the dark squared Bishop from
developing that's not how Magnus usually
plays so if it's not Queen D2
is it Queen takes E7 and like just
Bishop E3 I don't know you don't want to
give away your Bishop there
yeah I'm
I like your queen d2 move I think
somehow after castles we have to
do something
yeah there's Queen D1 also same idea
just keep your Bishop open
okay clear Queen D1 I like that one
and doesn't look like I'm uh Knight C2
Bishop D3 isn't that
[Laughter]
yeah
made no impression okay so um parcels
and then again we go down the same path
Ricky too what a mess what a troll
you're a complete chaos on the board
very scary Scrappy isn't it also maybe
white could uh even go G5 I was rather
than rushed with C5 can go G5 attack the
Knight
jeez just stir the pot even more because
the Knight can't drop back to D3 because
you intercept the connection between the
queen and the pawn that's always a
Troublesome situation I like G5
yeah
let's go back to live board I'm I've
reached my allotment of you know chaos
at nine o'clock in the morning Richard
report is swimming in that Cesspool
right now as he considers the move night
before this is a game you'll be unless
the Queens get traded and things calm
down in which both sides could end up in
acute time pressure if I move 20 because
this is only move 11 and they've both
already taken about 40 minutes off their
clocks
yeah
um definitely and it's kind of funny
that it feels like Magnus is taking
risks because the position kind of came
from a patch off one of the most solid
openings it looked pretty symmetrical
now it's anything but symmetrical um
Magnus just by putting his King on F2
and allowing this Knight before watching
I do like your queen D do one idea and I
think it will happen I just
think that there will be Chaos on the
board and uh Magnus is just invited
every single moment I I can't
I think he had to do it I mean he wants
to win he wants to win this tournament
he wants to win points
he does maybe take the position away
from uh simple Pawn structures and
positional elements and uh just light
that firework
very provocative by the world champion
who has only lost one classical game to
Richard report Carlson leads their heads
ahead three wins one draw and one loss
his only loss coming a couple of years
ago in 2017 and an interesting stat
there each player has lost the Notre
back abdusatara earlier in this event so
I'm just a tour of this really the king
Slayer in the report Slayer and in their
last OTB meeting the world Blitz Carlson
came back to defeat Richard reports so
not an easy opponent for uh report I
mean as if Carlson is an easy opponent
for anybody Yogi as if oh some players
play well against the world champion
foreign
does anyone have a positive score
against the Magnus I remember it was
kind of said that napomiyachi was the
one who had a positive score against the
world champion but most of those
victories came from when they were
juniors
yeah maybe someone
I was just I was just thinking maybe
someone has beaten the world champion
and then Rage Quit
oh wind quick is the no more
that's exactly right when and then I've
had enough I'm keeping my positive
record against Magnus I think an
interesting question would be
for all players who have played four
games or more or like an arbitrary
number that's greater than one does
anybody have a positive score against
Magnus Carlson definitely something I'll
research uh perhaps after the broadcast
today so a good reason to tune in
tomorrow
yeah I can't wait to hear your stats on
this I was our producer said uh yes a
penko could be one person oh
yeah maybe
uh maybe
he's beaten Magnus a few times
[Music]
but have they played four games is the
question anyways we'll we'll test that
out
um that is a oh and we have a result
whoa whoa whoa
we already have a result in aronian Gary
a draw by liquidation
and uh there we see the players yeah we
have to check out how did this happen
um
it's
because while we left it it was all
Brewing up very nicely for this big
battle in on the sides of the board you
know Lavon was gonna align his Rooks on
the F line
something was going to happen in the
center oh and there we have it
the pawn broke through
and was met my like for like
yeah pace for Pace d45 that's the thing
with these positions uh these Italian
positions have a very high tendency uh
to explode but when they explode they
frequently lead to liquidation because
both sides essentially have a very
healthy position a healthy Pawn
structure uh so neither side really able
to gain the edge takes takes take Stakes
take Stakes take stakes and a dropper
with the move Queen D4 which is a
totally reasonable draw for this is a
dead equal position black and go rook
fde8 and a great result for anishikiri I
mean he holds Lavon aronian easily with
black he's adhering to his tournament
strategy and his preparation Yogi has
just been unimpeachable whichever
opening he's played
ah he's making it all look so effortless
and here it just seemed like an easy
path to equality it looked like he
sussed out what Lavon was going to play
and he had found a formula to neutralize
that
um I'm a bit confused about one thing
because I was under the impression that
the players were not allowed to offer
draws
it's it's basically because I've never
seen anyone offer a draw if I can say
and I've never seen anyone finish so
quickly
I was under a similar impression
um so I'd be curious to look into that
maybe the players don't even know
whether they're allowed to offer just
they're kind of assuming that they're
not but then levonaroni is like let me
test this out let me see if I get banned
by the organizers after I have for
trumpet this definitely was not a
three-time repetition so I suppose maybe
it's at the organizer's discretion you
have to ask permission not entirely sure
but we'll get that info for you uh in a
few moments
yeah I mean but this is the very first
kind of quick draw we've seen actually
during this tournament
yeah and
and uh okay looking at the position it
means fast I mean I would say a totally
drawn position but it's nice that it
would have been nice to see them playing
playing it out
it really would and we're gonna swing
around to the bird's eye view and then
overview with uh your blessing we can
look at the Wesley Sogo cash game
because we haven't looked at it yet it's
the last game uh we haven't examined but
before we do that just some bad news for
Fabi he did not play the move Knight A5
I'm surprised he moved his other Rook to
B8 so his position still looks quite
unpleasant a fun aesthetic effect
produced by Eric is these minor pieces
all of which sit on the f file he's
played Bishop C1 to F where there are
some moves you have to play not because
they're necessarily good because they
just produce you know a certain
aesthetic effect and I think Bishop F4
falls into that category
yeah it certainly does and uh yeah but
shall we so here we are are we going to
go to the um the cash game
and there we have it
and okay all the minor pieces still on
the board one set of Pawns have been
traded
yeah it's really tense
it's a hard position to make heads or
tails of because the the immediate the
most arresting feature is of course the
fact that black has a pawn in the center
and white does not but in these Italian
positions that pawn could be the bane of
Black's existence white is already in a
position to play the move B5 which I
think is the first thing we have to
calculate but I think after B5 Knight A5
in some situations black is willing very
much willing to sacrifice this Pawn
because White's pieces are more passive
and so if the Center opens up sometimes
white finds himself unequipped to handle
the resulting opening of the files so B5
should not be rushed as for Alternatives
go cash could take on E6 at any moment
he could try to push C4 at some point
and open up the dark Square bishop or if
he can combine these things so one thing
which comes to mind for me we're
bringing them to now sport is Bishop
takes E6 let's say Rook takes E6 B5
kick the night away
and then follow up with C4 opening up
the bishop and of course here white also
threatens the very nasty move C5 I think
if anyone is better yobi it's got to be
white
yeah and definitely and also you've made
me very happy because you've liberated
the dark Square bishop and uh as long as
that poem was sorry as long as that
Bishop wasn't C4 that Bishop on B2 was
blocked in and
I'm not happy with a bad piece in the
Army in White Zombie so I like this idea
I mean is there anything that black can
do
after after B5 I mean
does the Knight have to retreat to
upon takes Pawn takes Pawn kind of again
feels like his favoring black sorry
White
yeah I can take here but you're probably
gonna take with a bishop aren't you to
keep the pressure on E5
mm-hmm
here come back again
it just looks okay I said good slightly
obvious but white black is solid here I
still think and Knight G6 is a very
important resource because it opens up a
diagonal and if you rush C5 this is what
I'm talking about you can tunnel vision
the pawn but you know here for example
B5 hangs and at the end why it's just
gonna be worse uh because of his weak
ones so the threat is strong in the
execution here you want to choose a very
opportune moment to win the pawn in E5
something like this I think is likely
but of course it's far from Force black
white does not have to take on E6 if he
doesn't want to
no and uh I agree with you don't rush
that capture in the middle instead we
see Rook E2 well very sophisticated move
rookie two with the idea of doubling on
the e-line and intensifying the pressure
on E5
yeah once again I I like it because it
puts the ball back in Black's court and
black has to just say come and get how
am I going to handle that
and on top of that black will still have
to calculate V5 in every single turn
even more so when white doubles Rook 71
the nb5 becomes a serious threat the one
downside I'll point out is that that
Rook on E2 in these positions can be
vulnerable to a night maneuver over from
H5 to F4 so Knight H5 here is a serious
candidate move and Wesley's got plenty
of time to consider his options well
yesterday Wesley so caught up with the
press to reveal his feelings about
playing teenagers of whom there are a
lot in this tournament Wesley one of the
Elder Statesmen let's listen in to the
American Grand Master
no I don't enjoy playing against
teenagers in fact I have a very bad
performance I think I didn't really look
but seems like I suffered so many
notifications teenagers in my career
because I remember in 2015 I lost to
Savion when he was like 14. then also
recently I lost the crystal Purdue the
youth championship and he's like 16.
so I don't really enjoy playing them
maybe I shouldn't have played here and
why I can't say but it's my favorite
tournament so but I I know Magnus says
you have to beat them when they're young
but the thing is they're insanely
focused and
they're very dedicated to chess but it's
a good thing I'm very pleased that there
are a lot of up and coming young players
who love the game of chess like I do
if they're they're very strong right now
as you can see from from another big
performance
well one of the sweetest classiest
easiest to root for Grand Masters on the
professional scene Wesley so he's always
in good spirits he wasn't too happy
about the way the tournament started for
him but his mood obviously improving
with that sparkling uh Victory yesterday
yovi
yeah and uh I like what he said about uh
Magnus saying you need to beat these
kids when they're young
and where's he like yeah but they're
still strong even when they're young and
you can just see that by Abby man you
Mishra right Grandma at the age of 12.
and uh now he's 13 and he's playing in
the challenges section
when can we beat them
yeah they're just incredibly strong you
know I do know that Prague uh I think he
kind of went to school in name he did
some exams last year I remember but yeah
I mean most of the time they're just
focused on just a completely dedicated
to the game and you can see it's
reflected they are so strong
yeah and and it's not just that they
achieve stuff at a younger age they
become Grandmaster uh younger and
younger it's also that they their Styles
become more Universal at a younger age
you see some of these 12 and 14 year old
Grandmasters and you know their
positional understanding is already at
an adult level which makes them
terrifying to play and let alone uh
players like ukesh and kymer who are you
know already veterans at you know age 16
or 18 their styles are even more
Universal they can play any position
their opening repertoire or that is vast
and you know this was always how the
older generation tried to gain the edge
over their younger opposition but
nowadays it's just gotten so hard they
can do some of what you can do and then
some and uh they're dominating the
worlds but Wesley he ain't going to go
gentle to that good night rookie two is
gukesh's last move and the American
Grand Master will continue pondering is
next course of action shall we take one
more look at the bird's eye view here
yeah definitely
and uh who is catching your eye and uh
immediately I kind of caught by arjuns
and I do satorov's kind of piece
configuration just look at that all
those pieces lined up on the F line
it's beautiful geometry uh that that's
one move that kind of comes to
consideration uh another kind of uh game
that I'm really looking forward to see
how it's developed is the game between
pragnananda and Van Forrest
whilst
yeah things are still very much where we
left off in the game Magnus Carlson
against Richard report
um
who who's uh taking your fancy
well definitely I'm I'm super excited
about the Prague game because event
Force actually sacrificed upon the queen
side to keep things under control and I
think after we emerge from our second
break we are going to take a dive
straight into prague's fascinating
giving every game this tournament has
been so rich I mean we really haven't
had a single anti-climactic game maybe
aronian Geary uh was our first so we've
got plenty of content and plenty of
fascinating positions to review before
we take our second break of the day we
wanted to remind you that chess kid is
hosting the second chesket bullet
Championship on February 25th a little
bit over a month from now the tournament
is open to players worldwide and it's
completely free to play in top players
receive chess get gold memberships and
gift cards to the chested store Fawn
Master my client will be covering all
the action at twitch.tv chess kid and
chess.com
TV if you or someone you know has what
it takes make sure to join the official
chess kid Club over at chesskid.com and
use x Glam CK bullet exclaim CK bullet
in chat for more do not miss the second
Jessica bullet championship and do not
miss our continuing coverage of round
seven here at the 85th edition of the
Tata steel chess tournament we will be
back with more exciting action on the
other side of this short break
when I say chess what's the first word
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game fantastic
okay it's just a sport absolutely very
competitive known worldwide uh battle of
wits to the highest degree I imagine
this is the best interview I've ever
given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
that chess a sport
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
[Applause]
chess chess yes like the game chess I
can beat you in chess if you beat me
I'll give you ten dollars ten ten if you
beat me I
I bet
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out
I don't know what I'm doing it's all
right it's all right I don't know what
I'm doing in life
okay
all right bro let's Checkmate oh
who's Mate who's made bro I will
unbelievable you got 30 seconds for me
quick interview come on you look like a
chess player you play chess don't play
chess okay when I say chess what's the
first thing that comes to your mind
winning
of these three things one of them is
real
chess dancing chess climbing chest
boxing chest climbing just climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climb chest
books chest boxing chest boxing you
nailed it okay am I right for real you
nailed it seriously yeah of of the two
of us one of us is a World Chess boxing
champion which one do you think it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay
no he's not he does get he tried to hit
another guy earlier so
he looks oh my God she didn't even
hesitate from now on will you stop
making me do things in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
January and Vicon Zay the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun happy seems
more fresh and I know he loves Todd of
Steel and you could just see the
inspiration in fabby's play once again
vikon Zay starts the new year as the
center of the chess Universe this year
as host of the 85th Tata steel chess
tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is playing for a win and he
has to start winning fast if he wants to
re-emerge at the top half of the Cross
table the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish is
taking down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps the order
back just playing a modern brilliancy
what a performance
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years and
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
the world champion Magnus Carlson is
struggling at the 85th edition of the
Tata steel chess tournament Magnus
considering his next move there as you
see the spectators in the background the
entire playing Hall the vast playing
Hall filled to the brim with interested
chess fans and chess fans who themselves
want to take a dip in the pool and are
playing in the open tournament what a
magical atmosphere as we reach the
halfway point of the Tata steel chess
tournament Daniel nerdinski and Ivanka
houska bringing you commentary of this
seventh round we hope you're having a
great weekend and enjoying some chess on
this Saturday morning or afternoon as we
look at the bird's eye view uh eovi all
of the games well first of all Roni and
Geary have already made a draw all of
the other games have exited the opening
and are hurtling toward some fascinating
middle games
yeah I mean we've been really Brewing up
for some nice battles and uh just uh
having a look at Magnus there in full
Focus mode and I just love the fact that
this being watched by so many people and
of different ages as well we see two
young girls uh they just sat there on
the table just hanging onto every bit of
moves and uh just look at them they're
enjoying their atmosphere
focused on Magnus Magnus is very very
popular all over the world and there we
saw a Fabby walking around in the
background and uh Here Comes Is that a
niche no
that is that a producer tour of no
deserve is sitting so unless he's
bi-locating
that couldn't be that that was a lean
rubers right there by the way big shout
out she is uh very strong talented
up-and-comer defeating Erwin lemie
holding a couple 26 hundreds to a draw
over in the Challenger section
yeah and uh I think I read somewhere I
mean that she's been trained by Lauren
fresenay and I know here she's working
with Robert Reese a famous Dutch
International master
and there we see pregnant always a good
cash
strolling up and down you know the
tension is palpable here
this is often the way that chess players
just calm themselves between moves
they're not actually
just uh just wandering up and down
thoughtlessly thinking about nothing now
there are just laser focused they're
thinking about plants they're thinking
about the positions and uh everyone is
just a picture of concentration they're
just walking out that nervous energy
with their hands often behind their back
or in their pockets they're just certain
poses that you that chess players
reliably adopt when they're sitting or
when they're walking that's why you can
you can identify a chess player from a a
crowded room many miles away well oh my
gosh speaking of crowded rooms I mean
look at the space of the spectators but
we have the bird's eye view up right now
we are going to choose a couple of games
to look at the world champion Magnus
Carlson has played Bishop E2 back to F1
and he did indeed refrain from the queen
trade so my proposal always that we look
at the era guys the abducator of game
because that game's seriously heating up
and while we do that perhaps Richard
report will have made a response to
Bishop F1 and uh perhaps we could follow
that up with another look at Magnus
Carlson's Rich middle game what do you
say to that I say absolutely and uh it's
a good time because I just saw another
fine move from Abdi sotorov where
suddenly everything is happening on the
board because there's a pawn break in
the middle he's just played D5 D4
oh hell okay let's break this position
down
yeah this is this is always one of my
favorite things about high level chess
is when the game you can feel the shift
between the stage of the game where the
players are still developing assembling
the tension is percolating and then at
one point one of the sides they step on
the gas pedal in this case it's black
doesn't necessarily mean that black is
better but black is the one who
initiates kind of the first battle D5 D4
by notorbeck now let me tell you what
what is not going to do unless I'm
missing something white is not going to
take that pawn and allow black snipe to
jump into the game Eric I see with a
quick response strike of his own on the
king side get off me he says to the
light squared Bishop
and uh okay and he's uh voluntarily
weakened his King side so that carries
great risk not right now because the
white king is safe as houses and now the
the question does occur does arise you
know is white going to capture the pawn
C takes D5 T4 and try to play against
this Pawn or is he kind of saying hang
on I've just pushed forward those pawns
on the king side and am I going to
continue
I think the the former option is more
likely I don't see a major downside to
playing CD it should be pointed out that
Arjun is by no means afraid of notorbeck
taking Bishop on F5 that enables White's
pawns to reach very imposing stature on
F5 and E5 then you could think about a
move like F6 to shatter Black's King
position so you're right White's
strategy not without risk especially if
the Center opens up but I would be
expecting something like cdcd and then
maybe a calm move like Rook D1 and D3
preparing to double Rooks Queen uh E4 is
also in the mix but for the time being
the queen must remain on E2 to supervise
uh this B2 Pawn
yeah oh such a sharp position
and uh yeah and if white is gonna
suddenly to switch to positional mode
and start attacking the default Pawn but
black has to have an answer of their own
because if you take a look at their
minor pieces
none of them
are working well I mean white sorry
black is in danger of being squeezed in
terms of space
I think that's the best word to describe
what aragaisi is about to do if you
think about the scenario where white
takes on D4 and doubles Rooks but black
is not at immediate risk of losing that
pawn you can play Bishop E7 to C5 the
pawn will have disappeared from C5 the
problem is that if you divert too many
of your pieces to the queen side
especially if they adapt a passive role
then white could switch over to the king
side and carry out your second idea to
play an H4 H5 at a timely moment and
force Black's hand on the king's side
you could get checkmated there in the
blink of an eye with White's pieces very
much equipped to move from one side of
the board to the other The Rook from D3
could swing over to G3 I'm really
talking about the distant future here
but that's what you have to do when
you've got a position that says
undefined and as sharp as this one you
have to make sure that your pieces are
ready uh to meet the challenge uh
whenever that challenge arises in
whatever form that challenge takes
mm-hmm and yeah I mean we're talking
about what black should do and how they
how they have to be ready
I'm gonna be honest here I cannot see a
way for blacks to do anything I mean if
and if the way is unclear that simply
means that black has to wait and see so
if white decides to go play Pawn takes
pawn pawn takes Pawn well it leads to
the dark Square Bishop gets liberated
and then you can deal with moves like
Rook D3 on a move by move basis and uh
when The Rook moves to D3 the first
thing that you should be thinking of is
do I have a safe place for the queen if
you do that's great if you don't then
find one sharpish hmm
yeah you know that that that is the set
of White's priorities first decide what
you're doing in the center then decide
whether you're playing Rook D3 then
figure out uh for both one in black
where your main piece belongs where do
you want your queen to sit wow I mean it
just does not get any richer than this
this is just a classic 2700 position
Yogi
this is the kind of book that you find
in those uh positional textbooks you
know asking you to come up with a move
take a decision for white and then you
have to sit there you've got half an
hour on the clock get going get solving
uh I mean this is a great great position
and it's one that really I think we will
learn a lot from
oh for sure and we will continue looking
at this game but I want to look at some
stats some really interesting stats
between these two players the most
pertinent of them is that both players
are making their Master debut at wake
and say of course Eric icy a lot of fans
might remember just smashed through the
Challenger section last year with a just
a wild score I think it was something
like 10 and a half out of 13 but not to
be denied of this is horov he was
runner-up in the 2020 Division and it's
pretty terrifying when someone is young
as abusitor have already achieved that
kind of success three years ago
terrifying
yeah oh I'm totally terrifying I just
remember he just raced through the whole
tournament no one had a chance against
him and he just kept on winning and
winning and winning and it really felt
like what are you doing playing in the
challenges you should be up there and
the Masters and uh of course he is now
and Abdus while he's just I mean if he
hadn't been a runner-up in the 2020
tattoo steals challenges I I still think
he would have gotten an invitation
because he has a really just ignited
onto the world stage he became World
rapid champion in 2021 and of course he
was one of the heroes in the Olympiad
leading Uzbekistan to their gold medal
and I mean it was just fantastic what
he's been doing and now he just shows
that he is up there with the world's
Elite and I think we're going to see his
rating catch up there so he will be very
soon in the top 10 and I I'm really
impressed by his his player how he's
willing just to take risks play actively
when need be he's bold he's Brave
calculates well and we saw how he
handled his game against Magnus Carlson
he was able to withstand all the
pressure that the world champion put on
him and he was like yeah I've got it
under control and I know that you took a
dodgy decision and I love what he's
doing
I do as well he just seems to get
exactly the kinds of positions and play
the kinds of games that the organizers
of the Tata steel respect they respect
Fighting Chess they respect ambition
they respect Youth and Notre back
espouses all of these qualities and many
many more okay so as Eric icy tries to
find the best way to resolve the central
tension I vote we dip our toes back into
the bird's eye view real quickly and
then see what the world champion is up
to here we go
oh and uh I feel a sense of deja vu
because this is exactly the position
that we had on our analysis board
in uh Carlson report isn't it yes it is
this you know we have predicted you
predicted you
find D1
and uh after alongside castling the ball
is back in
and court and he has to take a decision
I mean how is he gonna deal with the
threat of Knight C2
and potential openings on the queen side
and of course there is a threat of the
White Knight being kicked out from F4
with G5
I'm gonna I'm not going to hide my
exuberance at the fact that the Queens
are not off the board if you told me
that when Magnus played Queen E2 I would
have laughed you out of the room but
what it's what an interesting turn of
event defense as Carlson plays Queen E2
back to D1 and Bishop
um oh for some reason I thought the
bishop was on E2 and moved back to F1 it
never did I was uh that was a it was a
bad dream no Queen to D1
um if he had also played Bishop F1 I
would have uh started to get scared that
he's setting up the pieces because 92 to
G1 would have been next and then I'd see
three to B1
but what's Happening Here how is Carlson
going to resolve the tension in the
center and on the queen side if I
remember correctly Obi we were earlier
looking at this idea of playing A3
actually provoking Knight C2 and then
moving The Rook up to A2 and trying to
go after the Knight with B4 the problem
is that that's a very cumbersome plan it
takes a lot of time and it enables black
to strike at the D4 Pawn with a timely
c65 which you proposed which I thought
is a potentially game-changing idea so
if not A3 are there any somewhat Tamer
Alternatives that white could try
perhaps Knight F4 back to D3 to slice
off the mission what do you think of
that just stop bailing out you know
because I mean one of the defensive
rules that I kind of swear by is when
you're in trouble you've got to start
neutralizing the initiative and you've
got to start removing your opponent's
attacking pieces and the night on B4 is
in your side of the board get rid of it
put that Knight on D3 swap off a few
pieces and then you know once those
pieces have left I also like the fact
that the night moving backwards on D3
just uncovers the dark Square bishop and
now it controls the G5 Square so that
there is no G5 ideas in the air because
one of the things I'm really terrified
about in chess
is a pawn storm I hate them I can't
stand them that's why I love them so
much I mean when they come at you and
it's a wall of them you're just thinking
how how can I cope with this these
things and uh this way I do three
some attacking pieces eliminated
you can breathe a sigh of relief and I
do feel that that kind of movies and
magnus's style as well you know it also
falls into his kind of philosophy of
overprotecting everything every single
piece after Knight D3 is protected
my better silver dollar
yeah I'll bet a silver dollar we see
Knight D3 within a couple of minutes
it's just it's it's too much in magnus's
style for him not to play it I totally
agree and one thing I wanted to bring
the viewers attention to is that if we
pull up an announce board here real
quickly speaking of Pawn strums you
should always start by testing out what
happens if all of the pieces get off the
board if black takes the simplest
approach and just trades twice on D3 how
do you evaluate this position well it
seems to me that black is in serious
trouble here because you pointed out
Black's ability to pawn storm on the
king side is hamstrung by upon
prematurely being on H5 the Knight on F6
Robert Hess would want me to point out
is restricted completely restricted by
the pawn in F3 white on the other hand
has carte blanche on the queen side
you're just gonna close your eyes and
run that beep on up the board if black
tries to Counter Strike well this only
makes the pawn storm scarier once the
pawn reaches B5 there will be hell to
pay on the queen side so the combination
of the night being locked out the
possibility of a pawn storm gives white
the advantage and Carlson about to make
a move drum roll please let's see what
he does he is about move yeah and I do
think we are going to see that night
Retreat and he's getting he's getting
ready and yes yes
I mean how could he not make such a move
like that you know it fits him with his
philosophy and it's a great defensive
move and of course it amps up the
tension because just as you highlighted
if report tries to liquidate he'll be in
big trouble because he just is lacking
in space he's lacking bite in the
position and is Magnus the one who
suddenly gets the upper hand
and uh yeah and I I really like this
kind of position and there we see Magnus
Carlson deep in thought and so now the
the kind of all goes back to Richard
Richard has to take a decision how many
pieces are you gonna trade because one
of the things he cannot do is you cannot
just Retreat the Knight to A6 because
that would just be such a passive move
yeah I know it's horrible isn't it but
people kind of think like that you know
Knight is attacked Knight moves back so
people have either got to think of
exchanging maybe a set of nights or
you've got to consider moves such as D5
initiating your own break in the center
over protecting the Knight on B4 and uh
just getting ready for the Brewing
action
I don't yeah I I think that's the
direction Richard has to think in he's
got to think fast because I pointed out
earlier there's a very high probability
of time pressure now I think that
there's a probability black gets into
severe time pressure because White's
plan is now very clearly defined you've
got the option of bringing the bishop
out but essentially at some point you're
going to play B4 B5
I think the Evo bar is deceptive here
it's it's indicating a slight Advantage
for white I think practically speaking
black is in a good amount of trouble
here Richard has to find a way to get
stuff going on the king side or he's
gonna get run over you know by the tank
that's going to come after him down the
B file
yeah I I agree uh a storm is brewing and
it's not very clear how to stop it
either
difficult position because uh black is
getting kicked back
Magnus doing what Magnus does best you
know he starts from a very quiet
position makes some unorthodox backward
moves and then suddenly it's all working
like a dream
sign of a champion move move 13 this is
move 13 and this Yogi is the Magnus that
we are used to he starts by playing A
variation that he's comfortable with he
challenges Richard to get into a
slightly worse end game which says no no
I want to trade on my terms okay you
don't want a queen trade you ain't gonna
get it he brings the queen back to D1 as
you said typical Magnus retreating moves
and we're gonna have to see Richard's a
game for the rest of the game if he
wants to hold the fort here with black
um yeah and uh well he has to do
something now there's no denying it his
Knight is on Breeze
either D5 C5 uh I mean could you even
think about A5 I mean that's probably I
I would never even dream about playing
A5
um primarily because you don't push
pawns on the side that you're weakest
and certainly not the side where your
king is so
critical moments
A5 I suppose white will play A3 and like
you said that it merely adds kindling to
the fire because one swipe plays before
that would also challenge the A5 Pawn
okay I think Richard would want us to
leave him to his own devices he's down
to 45 minutes and we will update you on
the Romanian Grandmasters move and he
makes it but a very unenviable situation
D5 uh is his choice and that will most
likely be met with C5 but I feel like
the situation is beginning to
deteriorate back we go to the bird's eye
view Eric icy still thinking about his
move after uh abdusitor have shifted The
Rook to d8 but one game Yogi that I
Can't Take My Eyes away from is that
Vincent kymer battle against England
Because unless my eyes are deceiving me
it seems like Vincent has managed to get
the upper hand as the game transitioned
away from that complicated middle game
into a no less complicated end game
what do you say we pay a visit to that
game we definitely because that that
game has caught my eye for quite a while
now because I mean I kind of warned
about it I've quite a few
I was gonna say months ago it feels like
months but it wasn't months moves ago
and I was gonna say watch out for the
pawn on F4 coming E4 and E5 because you
know with this beautiful poor majority I
mean white is going to be so much better
and uh it's on the board I mean white
has just paid rookie too but E4 E5 is
brewing and I just remember games where
I was looking at certain lines on the
black side of a Queen's Gambit declined
and this was White's plan and it's been
seen I was going to say since the 19th
century you know I think capablanca have
won games like this you know you just
put your Pawn on E5 use your extra space
and you ask like what are you doing with
your porn majority there on your queen
side if you're doing nothing you're
basically are pulling down on the king
side
well White's just prying Black's fingers
away from the lead share as you're
saying after E5 the Knight has no
strongholds in the center The Rook is
kind of stuck in no man's land this end
game is just the bee's knees for white
now I don't want to overstate the case I
don't think ding is lost here because
even after white plays E5 okay black can
come back to E8 and for the time being
everything is reasonably protected
Vincent is gonna have to keep his foot
on the gas pedal probably swing his Rook
to the seventh rank but ding is really
just one more inaccuracy away from being
objectively lost I'd like to rewind
though a couple of moves and just show
everybody how Vincent was able to
outplay ding this quickly because the
middle game only lasted really seven
moves we last saw the position here
looks okay for ding but watch what
Vincent does not F4 but Bishop F4 a very
instructive move targeting Black's
strongest Beast ding responsive Queen D6
and queen A4 whoop get the queen to the
side attack the bishop make space for
The Rook ding is getting tossed around
like a flimsy boat in a storm take E5
and now Queen D4 offering a queen trade
now on White's terms and getting control
of the D file that Rook on E5
Bang
and rookie two getting the Rook onto a
better Square repairing E5 Exquisite
play yovi by the German youngster
especially after a painful two losses in
a row to come back and play like this
against the world championship
Challenger speaks to his resilience his
resolving this is what we've come to
take for granted in the younger
generation
yeah I I have to say and uh I think
Vincent will be in his comfort zone I've
seen him win countless games like this
and this is also very reminiscent of
Vincent's coach Peter leco I mean you
can just see it's going to be a
positional Masterpiece and I'm glad that
you're a little bit more optimistic
about ding's chances here because I
really don't like his position and I do
think that is teetering on the brink of
being lost uh I I just feel the danger
inherently here and
yeah what can I say Vincent has played
this perfectly so far I'm really really
impressed by the queen maneuver that you
just showed I mean he's got everything
he controls the open lines he's got this
beautiful porn advance
is there I mean am I being too negative
no I mean just curl up in a ball and
just survive
I I think that's the only alternate I
mean curl up and Joe ball with a move
like Knight E8 I would say if we bring
up an analysis board really quickly here
let's say he goes 98 white can
essentially pre-move E5 that's also very
tilting when your opponent it has such
easy play that he can literally close
his eyes and you know play the obvious
move Bishop takes Bishop White's gonna
take back with the King man White's
control over the only open file couples
with you know an amazing Knight on EA
that has so many active prospects yeah
that's what makes Black's position
miserable I I guess you play a move like
Rick C8 you just Earl up into a ball as
you said but yobby this just gets worse
and worse white gets The Rook to D7 the
Knight he can swing around to G5 and
just look how great The Rook was on E2 I
mean what a great idea prophylaxis
fantastic that was Black's only active
concept to meet 94 with Rook C2 and even
that was shut down convincingly by
Vincent kymer oh my gosh 40 minutes also
for ding which is not a lot of time when
you think about defending a position
like this for 20 moves until the time
control
crisis absolute crisis here for the
Chinese number one
yeah
sorry a time not G8 okay
so well the defense defensive Hedgehog
has appeared and I don't using this
obviously in the terms of porn structure
but here you know you just have to curl
up in a little ball and hope those uh
spikes do defend you
one thing I if I had to make a
prediction I think I think for some
reason the ding is Gonna Save this game
and that has nothing to do with you know
trying to dispense it I think is amazing
but I've just seen ding
play so calmly in these types of
situations I think even after I get to
The Rook 37 he's gonna find some way to
neutralize the activity of that Rook
something tells me that Ding is just
gonna hold the fort here but we will see
he is definitely in a very unenviable
spot
yeah I mean yeah of course let's not
underestimate the things defensive
Talent you know of course he is 2800 and
the world's second rated player so I
mean it is a challenge for him and we'll
see whether he's up to the task and
where else should we head to
well first let's go back to the bird's
eye view as we know Richard report has
struck in the center with D5 the world
champion is thinking about his next move
well the pro game is one that we've been
talking about for a while we can take a
dip in that pool I'll also point out
that Fabiano caruana has been forced to
weaken his Queen side further by playing
the move B7 to B6 or parhamax Hulu just
relentlessly pressuring on all sides of
the board as he prepares the Central
Pawn break that's lower left of your
screen he's going to try to get E4 in
and squeeze that in and keep pushing
black Pieces away what do you say uh
yeah and I just wanted to mention uh I
just yeah before we could go over to
that I just have to take a look at Arjun
he's done you know we were talking about
central control and I did kind of
reference this plan of just going wild
and throwing pawns all the way out the
king side Arjun says that's right up my
street and off he goes
um that game is shaping up to be a real
milestone
yeah you called it H4
continuing to accumulate the pressure
and you know I've been referencing the
time situation a lot on some of these
words it feels to me that a lot of the
players taking longer than usual here
and that bodes very well for the
commentators we are going to get some
time scramble slug fests right around an
hour from now about 10 moves from now
and we'll keep you posted on the time
situations in a lot of these games okay
let's go to the prognananda van Forest
affair and what do we have here why it's
up upon for sacking his beep on to avoid
uh the explosion of the queen side so
he's he's definitely worse Yobe that's
that's not up for debate
how much worse is he
um
he
difficult position actually because I
don't think he's as as bad as the
evaluation bar is making it out to be
yeah okay it's you know if two computers
were playing it no doubt it would be
really really bad for black but you know
the two humans here and
my understanding is that when a black
porn reaches E4 if black has a dark
Square Bishop then the position carries
a lot of venom and white must be
incredibly careful here
and I think that
danger can pose a lot of problems to
Prague and I'm not really bothered for
Jordan about his Pawn deficit because I
mean the extra Pawn is on B2 and the
White Queen is offside so for the time
being I'm kind of thinking it's it's a
balanced game where white objectively
has the better chances but black can
Pros Pros can a probe and create real
problems
are you going to say pose and and pro
yeah pose combination she's gonna say
probe and then the brain went and goes
let's make it a new word prose which
actually is is not a new word it's uh in
something else
by the way speaking of posing problems
Rook dw1 I agree with everything you
said I will say that one of the things
that hurts Black's King side chances is
the placement of the Dark Sword Bishop
like if you just could get it to this
diagonal it would be a completely
different story black had set up a
battery there would be a Greek gift
sacrifice in response to Bishop takes G4
as it stands right now when Forest
doesn't have anything going and there's
a ticking clock literally and
figuratively because white is already
prepared to play the move b2b4 and once
that move happens black is no choice but
to exchange on B4 and that a pawn I mean
the path is clear the runway there's no
airplanes on it you just go A5 A6 A7 and
that's only three moves
and uh that could just end the game
right then and there so Jordan he's got
to figure something out here
yeah that that move came like a cold
shower to me because I was being all
kind of in The Ether thinking about
beautiful attacking possibilities but
yeah you're right and Prague is right
before it's coming and with it is the
launch of the apron and that is going to
be difficult to spot to stop sorry and
uh okay
how to how to break out I mean
desperate times call for desperate
measures
or can what can
black do my first move is just to take
it slow and play Queen C7 but that
really doesn't do that much
yeah well you might have to be that H2
Plus for the only one
that you can attack this bishop E7 to
dhc7 maneuver just takes too long gosh
the more I look at this the more
miserable
it appears I'm even looking at creative
ideas like Knight D7 to B6 try to get
around to C4 but all of this are just
one move threats that can be very easily
parried if necessary with a move like B3
yeah
um maybe you have to use get creative
and kind of go rookie eight I mean you
might ask me why on Earth are you doing
such a thing but the whole idea is
perhaps to maneuver the Knight to f8 I
like your idea of Knight B6 let's keep
that in reserve for potentially
uh you know after Knight B6 can't be met
with Knight B3 with B3
I'm sorry say that again so so I was
just thinking if you leave that in
reserve for when I'm gonna cough
please get it out of the way
yeah it's a lot of talking we do a lot
of talking
and uh sometimes you just gotta you just
gotta clear the pipes but Knight B6 B3
and I feel like black is at a dead end
that's that was my so I was kind of
hoping to leave to leave that idea in
reserve for when B3 wouldn't be
appearing
so say for instance I mean could we
possibly set it up so that after B4
maybe there's some a takes before and
then Knight B6 could that be something
oh so you're saying a move like Queen C7
now I see what you're saying B4
yeah and then just leave that image up
and maybe don't put the queen on C7 I
thought Rook comes to E8
and it is a bit wacky but I thought that
maybe
now there's Pawn takes night
oh no I'll take spot Rook takes Pawn
that ain't gonna work I I you see black
is just too passive for any of this any
of these Shenanigans to work okay what I
think black should do is actually go
Queen C7 with a different idea in mind
after B4 which frog might actually
choose to delay there's no hurry if you
play brief before prematurely maybe
you've left just acquiescence to the
trade and goes Rook B in and says okay
I'm down the a pawn but at least I have
the B file
maybe try to get the queen to B2 but I'm
going to be brutally honest here it
feels to me that black is borderline
lost because of this b2b4 idea
yeah but the problem is
like if even if you do get the B9 like
you say the queen is just gonna step
back and then A5 A6 A7
and
yeah you can't stop that tune happening
and Black's attack is not even started
so I I another I oh
of course I mean I mean maybe this maybe
black just has to accept that that pawn
is gonna shoot up the board you just
ignore it just blockade it at the last
minute and all the meantime kind of try
to shift some pieces over to the king
side so the reason I wanted rookie eight
it was because Knight f8 Knight G6
Knight h
it's so long but who knows
yeah I mean I don't see another option
you kind of have to go into what I call
Swiss pilot mode if you're black is
watching this video a couple months ago
of uh Swiss airplane making an emergency
landing uh because their engines will
out and right in the midst of the chaos
after they declare the MayDay the pilot
who's this sort of very typical you know
Swiss calm uh older man he he like
suddenly takes a bar of chocolate out of
his pocket and he unrolls it and he's
like and now it's time for some
chocolate and he's just like eating this
chocolate as he's doing an emergency
landing that's the kind of Zen mode that
Jordan has to enter we called it Queen
C7 is on the board but is he going to be
able to contain the Furious progress of
the Apon man I think unless Prague does
something really wrong I think he should
be able to finish this game off Bishop
E2 to F1 by the way as we go back to the
live board is uh entirely possible as
well just leave the bishop on G4 in the
dust and play H3 at an opera tune moment
to prevent Knight G4 anyway long story
short crisis time for Jordan benforest
who has been struggling you'll be this
tournament and uncharacteristically
struggling in the opening phase which is
usually his strongest suit
yeah I'm and traditionally I have to say
in tata he does very well you know of
course he won the tournament in 2021 and
then let's not forget last year he also
he didn't defend his title but he
finished around about sixth or seventh
which is a very respectable score but
things are just not working his way in
this tournament and like you say you
know he's suffered quite a few defeats
straight out of the opening he just
seems to be getting caught in
preparation
yeah I mean the the the tides changed so
easily from tournament to tournament
sometimes you get lucky with your
preparation your opponents just kind of
enter into the lines you feel most
comfortable with and there are other
times where every game you seem to face
precisely the opening variations that
you find most annoying and most
uncomfortable and you know I think this
tournament belongs to the latter
category for the Dutch Grand Master well
we will leave him to his devices here as
he struggles in this Pawn down position
and let's swing back to the bird's eye
view Magnus in the meantime he's played
C5 as we expected so I think we're doing
a good job of sort of predicting the
course of that game and that course is
not favorable to Richard report
no it certainly isn't and uh Richard
really if he wants to maintain the
balance now he has to do something
and the problem is it's not very clear
what he has to do
so maybe
should we revisit that position or shall
we go to another game
I'm looking around what are you thinking
yes so I was thinking the game between
Fabi and maxulu
yeah there have been some changes in
that position
yep and it kind of feels like a very
somatic position it feels like the kind
of position that many people would find
themselves in
for sure the last move has been Bishop
E2 to F1 you mentioned thematic yeah
this is a typical Pawn structure
uh that emerges out of all these Queens
gamma decline or goes in positions now
to me it seemed evident that white has
to be better the email bar doesn't seem
to agree the reason I said that is
because black has all these weaknesses
on the queen side but if you look at it
from the other perspective well those
weaknesses are actually very safely
defended Rook defense B6 three pieces
defense C6 and perhaps Fabby could
convert the weaknesses into a strength
with a timely C6 C5 so are you as
surprised as I am you know that the eval
bar is not giving a bigger advantage to
White
um
I'm not that surprised because I've
played a lot of these type of positions
from the black side and it's always told
me I'm okay even though at the time when
I was playing the game I was absolutely
terrified and I didn't feel very
comfortable the evaluation bar was like
yeah it was not a problem why did why do
you freak out so much I mean he's
threatening me for a big deal just just
step back with your bishop move it to
age seven and just sit there and you're
like oh okay I didn't know that
yeah A4 is not the end of the word it's
not a cataclysm when it happens okay you
just occupy the center so you're saying
maybe move the bishop back preemptively
you know revolutionary prophylaxis
prepare yourself for the future
yeah I mean this is the kind of thing
that the computer just suggests you know
do nothing
and just sit back do nothing wait for
the action to emerge I probably would
put it on G6 just to kind of have a a
hiding place for the king and like you
say the main thing not to do
um but of course you had to take this in
a case cut by case basis is just not
meet E4 by capturing on e4 you have to
let that tension brew as long as
possible so once that happens then
you're like okay the action will now
take place in the center and now you can
do something else so just wait and I
think a lot of humans find it very very
difficult to sit there and wait
yeah you're absolutely that is probably
the hardest skill which computer has
really distinguished computers from
humans there's the move Queen D6 to D7
In The Same Spirit as Bishop G6 you
bring the queen back preemptively so E5
doesn't come with Tempo but more
importantly you turn it back around and
you go C5 this is exactly how white
loses control of the game he's bitten
off more than he can chew in the center
the Knight is saying you have to play B3
and already black could drive this
little wedge into White's position and
potentially follow up with B5 and pawn
looks imposing but what is it doing it's
never really going up to E6
and uh habiano caruana is just so good
in these undefined middle games you know
these rich structures he just seems to
have a great feel for where to position
his pieces and so I am changing my mind
about this position now that I've
understood why E4 isn't inherently
dangerous I can begin to see that Fabi
has greatly improved his position I
would say compared to what he had when
his Knight was on C6 and he has managed
by the way to bring the Knight back and
uh improve his structure by putting the
pawn on C6 COV
yeah and uh I I agree you know put the
pawn on C6 and yeah I I like what he's
doing you know he's simply preparing for
C5 at the right time and uh now you
mentioned C5 and putting the queen on D7
is actually the possibility of
retreating the bishop not to G6 but D7
is also in the air so I think still a
lot to play and uh yeah
Fabby doing nicely
solid well he's been he's been sporting
a very classy new haircut I mean he's
totally Unstoppable and he was
Unstoppable yesterday after defeating a
struggling let's listen in as Fabi talks
about how he feels going undefeated
through six rounds
yeah overall pretty good I I think I
could have maybe made a bit more in the
last few rounds against Richie
um some chances from the opening uh okay
against Wesley the game was pretty much
uneventful from a point of view of that
it was just a prep into a drudge
position
but after today I'm quite happy well the
last two games I lost were in the
Olympia to objectash and I was
responsible in large part uh from these
games for the United States not doing
very well and not meddling
um and in this tournament I haven't lost
against them so I'm done with them they
can't beat me anymore
at least in this tournament maybe in the
future but I'm quite happy with that
yeah overall pretty good I I think I
could have maybe made a bit more or less
against Richie and
um
sharing his thoughts after
the the winning is concussion oh that
was bad
um I'm not in I'm not an impression mode
today but Fabiano caruana is just very
impressive he's so stable and we've
talked a lot the OV about his struggles
in the last year or so ever since the
Madrid candidates but he just seems to
be more fresh he seems to be more
motivated and I think it's safe to say
he's really out of the funk that he he
found himself in over the last couple
months
yeah you know he's had a tough few years
you know first of all he's separated
from his uh second uh rustam cousin
majanov that happened during the
pandemic and then it kind of felt like
you know he was adapting to the change
he lost a ton of rating points and in
this tournament it feels good for him
you know he's now on plus two he played
a great game yesterday and victory
always brings a smile to your face I
mean however you get it whether it's
deserved undeserved ugly pretty doesn't
matter you enjoy your moments and uh I I
have to say I wasn't sure whether he was
being sarcastic when he talks about his
uneventful draw
against the Wesley so
I've got one of those faces where you
think wait hold on one second I are you
being serious are you kind of
[Music]
I think
Fabi has the dead pan of humor going I
definitely must have been sarcastic
unless all of it was preparation it was
that Scotch game where you had the open
H file and a furious counter-attack by
black so man if he wasn't being
sarcastic then I'm curious what fabi's
definition of an eventful game actually
is if that game didn't fit the bill
I don't know I mean that was one of the
wildest games I've seen it was not a
smooth path to the draw but uh okay
it's just Fabby being Fabby it's still
very difficult for me to tell whether
he's joking or being serious and uh
there we see him concentrating hard he's
pondering over what to play how is he
gonna meet this uh Pawn advance to E4
we are predicting that he's going to
move his Bishop away from F5 he seems to
be uh close to making a move he's got 16
moves until the time control 17 moves
that is and 34 minutes to make them and
so he's not in the best situation time
wise but I think he realizes that if he
finds a good way to meet E4 then his
structure and his uh position is going
to remain watertight and easy to play
Queen back to D7 so he plays the second
uh move first and after E4 Bishop G6 we
will transpose into the line that we are
considering good stuff by Fabi and we
are going to leave him to sip his tea
and Ponder this complex position we are
going to go uh ladies and gentlemen on
to another break as we look one more
time at the bird's eye view here with
the beautiful uh playing haul a shot of
all the spectators uh in that playing
Hall
man oh man what a tournament this is two
hours into the round and change and
before we go on our third break we
wanted to remind you that after a
two-year Hiatus the pro chess league is
back the 2023 season begins with a
qualifier week starting February 1st
coming right up with 16 teams advancing
into the main season pass BCL
participants include Magnus ding nepo
Fabi Hikaru mvl and Anish so we could
not be more excited for the League's
return and with over 100k on the line
it's looking like the 2023 season will
be one for the history books use x Glam
PCL in chat to learn all about it okay
we hope you're enjoying our Saturday
coverage of around seven of the 2023
title steel chess tournament we will be
back with more exciting action in just a
couple of minutes
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
thank you
what an iconic picture there fiddling
with the night is the world champion
Magnus Carlson at round seven of the
2023 Tata steel Masters Magnus is in the
midst of a slug Fest against Richard
report he is struggling he is on minus
one he is trying to come back and stake
a claim at least end in the top half of
the tournament cross stable but Richard
report stands in his way and a night
sacrifice yovi a night sacrifice amongst
the Clear Blue Sky it looked like Mark
Carlson marlson who is going to just run
Richard over on the queen side and boy
how the tables have turned let's take a
look at what happened two moves ago
after the move C5 look at what Richard
does he takes on D3 now we talked about
the scenario where black trades and
white runs the beep on up the board with
a Checkmate to follow no no no says
Richard report Knight f60 E4 check bang
goes the dynamite and after fe4 de4 all
of a sudden White's King very much
caught on the crossfire yovi this is I'm
still adjusting my eyes to the sacrifice
crazy stuff by report yeah I do think
that the sacrifice was necessary because
we did see that he was in danger of
being steamrollered over there on the
queen size and I love this move I do
think if you're gonna beat the world
champion you have to initiate
complications you have to go wild and uh
yeah and the position is so crazy now
and uh have we do we have any moves
after Pawn takes born Bishop probably
has to retreat somewhere close to the
king that's what I would put it just
because it feels like you need every
single piece protecting the king
huddling around trying to stop the
onslaught that is coming toward it and
uh Bishop E2 and the queen to F6 that
was played very quickly right because
there were a whole lot of candidate
moves you know there was Queen H4 check
it was uh obviously Queen F6 and then as
you've highlighted Bishop C5 brewing in
the air
okay
oh absolutely and then this is going to
equalize the time situation which is a
very important byproduct of the
sacrifice both sides down below 40
minutes we're only on move 18. Queen F6
is just a that is a sick move because it
threatens discoveries it threatens Rook
D4 threatens Bishop C5 and the question
for Magnus
he cannot defend against all three
threats at the same time so what is his
top priority I think this it's not what
people might think people might think oh
he has to move his King but actually
there is no immediate way to exploit the
discovery to the fullest extent the
bishop doesn't have too many squares my
inclination would be to support the D4
upon because if that pawn Falls in kind
of the wrong fashion and black takes on
D4 and on C5 white skin could just get
massacred on F2 so my sort of instinct
would be to play the move Bishop C1 to
E3 in this position
to which black almost certainly would
respond Bishop takes C5 and the idea it
came up with during the break was
actually to take back on C5 and to say
okay listen after Rook takes you on
Magnus has played Bishop E3 Rook takes
D1 Rook takes D1 white has a lot of
material for the queen a rook and two
pieces for a queen and two pawns to be
exact but this is what Richard report
would want it's an unbalanced position
his initiative continues to rage on and
the eval bar seems to believe that after
Bishop G4 check only black can be better
because white is a hard time keeping all
of his pawns protected keeping his King
sheltered and both players are out off
the board I love that
yeah I know I I have to say I love your
idea of giving up the queen it was also
my instinct just to
just to kind of neutralize all the
fireworks that are happening I mean but
here it is just move by move you've got
to take every single decision here
you've got to consider every single
possibility so ponte's Bishop is one
um what other moves are there I mean
could you simply
I don't know I I'm obsessed with King
safety I was thinking move the Rook to
perhaps F1
and try to try to live like that and uh
hide the king away on G1
I love them
yeah Bishop takes bishop or maybe is
there still no good discover check
anywhere you look
crazy I mean
takes no I have to take back because the
queen is also hanging Queen C1 Quincy
one this maybe this is the way that
Magnus should play because on the next
move you go King G1 now what's let's
take stock of the material black already
has three pawns for the piece so at this
point the sacrifice isn't as much of a
sacrifice but in these middle game
positions the piece usually does
outweigh the pawns so if white could get
King G1 and then perhaps Queen E3 in I
feel like only Magnus could be better
this might be the key to the kingdom
here as the world champion takes his
seat to continue thinking about this
critical position of course Richard
instantly blitzing out Bishop takes Pawn
yeah and the positions the well it just
plays itself for Richard he doesn't have
to worry about anything but uh you're
right if the white king finds safety and
say for instance the white Rook on H1
is not in the corner then the piece is
gonna be so much more effective than the
pawns
um I was kind of taught the rule that if
you have these peace imbalances like a
piece against three pawns three pawns
are actually not sufficient you need
something else so for instance that
something else could be an unsafe King
that you can attack another on something
else could be the pawns are far Advanced
up the board uh another thing something
else could be tremendous peace activity
coordination
um but here
if
just as long as the white king is safe
then that extra piece will count for a
lot
very well said and
it seems to me that Magnus is such a
specialist in these situations where a
lot of players would lose their minds
and start panicking especially when a
fearsome attacker like Richard report
sits across from you but Magnus takes
solace in his incredible defensive
ability honed through the years and he
also takes Solace into his positive
record against Richard report as we
bring up the statistics card one more
time Carlson leads their head-to-head
three wins one draw one loss now what
strikes me about that Yogi is that it
just isn't a lot of games I mean both
Carlson and Report have been a top uh
the the Mount Olympus of chess for a
very long time and yet somehow they just
haven't met each other that many times
five times for two super GMS is almost
nothing you think about Carlson Anand
you know Carlson caruana you're usually
talking about dozens of games at a
minimum and I always find it very
exciting when two players don't know
each other's Styles uh quite as well it
usually leads to more exciting action
yeah I agree with you somehow it feels
like the two have been moving in
different Cycles you know obviously
Richard has been in the lead for many
many years but somehow they've never
quite made it to the same tournaments
until now I can I can remember them
playing in Norway chess and that was a
victory for Magnus
um ah but what an exciting battle is
ahead and the more I look at it the more
I really like my Rook F1 move
the chicken way with your king is
perhaps maybe the safest
I think Rook F1 is the best move in fact
I think it's vastly Superior to uh to D
takes C5 which would play right into
reports hands it would enable him to
capture White's Queen and continue the
initiative
if the king gets to G1 Black's
initiative almost instantly evaporates
one more clarification I will make we
don't have to analyze this I'll just
State this after Rook F1 black also has
the possibility of playing Rook takes D4
but that move is a lot less scary than
it appears because white does it have to
take and give away the bishop well I can
still drop the queen over to C1 where it
protects the bishop and you know
everything goes according to plan you go
King Joel on the next move and I
continue to be worried about Richard
reports prospects here if Magnus Carlson
can find Rook F1 and something tells you
that he will I mean he is
world champion after all yeah he's the
master of Defending these tough
positions and I I just noticed they have
this ability to protect their pieces
there I mean I've said it time and time
again they're all about safety at this
uh super GM level they're all about the
harmony of the pieces coordinating and
the only other thing that I can kind of
be tempted by I mean I did like your
Pawn takes Bishop
um is it possible to do it and get away
with capturing with the other Recon H1
because I have seen examples of Magnus
sacrificing I say it's sacrificing his
Queen at in order to get that peace in
balance
well My worry is is the same after both
Rook a and Rook HD2 and so let's let's
revisit that line because this is a very
very important line to evaluate properly
you know DC if it works out gives white
a ton of stuff for the queen but here is
my concern after Rook D1 you want to
take with the atrok right yeah
yeah he's gone for Rook F1 great call
you called it Bishop G4 check would be
ultimately the deal breaker I think this
is the reason Carlson refrains from this
you want to go King G1 you don't want to
go King E1 and the problem is that at
the end of the sign you lose another
Pawn on B2 your queen side basically
evaporates and three pawns is a little
bit too much to bear so Carlson
definitely considered this option but as
we go back to the live Ward Rook F1 is
on the board of the ball tossed
furiously right back into Richard's
report's Court
what a crazy game actually what a crazy
start and who would have thought
actually from the opening moves
I thought well it's going to be an end
game it's going to be a grind and
instead the players have treated us to
This Magnificent
now this is this is lovely stuff and the
best very likely is still ahead time
continues to dwindle but Richard report
he needs to be perfect he really needs
to be perfect I think if he wants to
pull out at least a draw in this game
all right well Richard report still is
not taking a seat Agnes Carlson has
resumed uh the Furious fidgeting and
fiddling around with the pawn just a
classic chess player thing I do that all
the time I don't know why it's such a
Temptation for players do you do that do
you find yourself you know grabbing
whatever captured piece uh is available
and spinning it around you're not a
you're not a fidgeter uh no I am a
fidgeter but I am not a peace twiddler I
I like to Pace up and down up and down
the tournament Hall in fact I pay so
much that it often looks suspicious but
no it's just me just working out that
energy and just thinking about the game
and calming myself down
um but I have been tempted to take it on
because look everyone is doing it and I
I remember in 2021 I played in the grand
Swiss and I kid you not nearly everyone
in the open section was fiddling away
with these pawns so
there must be something in it right
it's just a way to divert and channel
the nervous energy there's so much
nervous energy in these middle games you
don't know if a single move turns the
evaluation around so you do that with
your leg to I actually that's a huge pet
peeve of mind when the the usually the
tables that chess tournaments are pretty
unstable and when you're shaking your
leg up and down it kind of shakes the
board but I never say anything because I
you know don't like confrontations with
opponents you do enough confronting at
the board but in any case Rook F1 is on
the board Let's Travel back to our
bird's eye view if you're just joining
us this is round seven of the Tata steel
chess tournament this is the halfway
point of the masters section the world
champion is struggling on a minus one
score another brick of do satorov leads
the tournament and one game has already
finished a rather uneventful draw in the
game between ronian and Anish Gary who
was tied for second before this round
well the OV I'll pass it back to you
is there any game that you think we
should go to next
top left
if there is marching up the board I
wanna know I want to be part of the
action and it's not just uh the age Pawn
that is rolling there's a deep horn
sitting there on D3 I what is happening
what is happening indeed well I will
start with a very controversial
statement the black Bishop on G6 is
hanging
[Music]
don't don't do that Have To Tread
carefully here
so
are we within reason to say that Bishop
takes F5 is virtually forced now I say
virtually because technically after
white plays HG black responds with FG
and the pieces that white so carefully
arranged on the f file are all going to
be hanging but that just seems way too
outlandish to me Bishop takes D3 in that
resulting position comes with Tempo it
attacks the queen so I think what
noterbeck is really thinking about here
is what he wants to do after taking on
F5 and I think I have an answer for you
Yogi I think there's the possibility of
swinging the Knight over to D4 and
initiating a favorable trade of knights
and you can't take on D3 because of the
discovery on E2 with a beautiful tactic
Bang
and The Rook hangs at the end of the
line black emerges up in exchange
oh beautiful thing that is such nice
footwork there so um
94 I mean 94 is the move that you want
to play is wrong to my intake
but here
um well with great space comes great
responsibility and
well wise position it is creaking you've
got to drop your Bishop back to I was
gonna say G3 G protect the king
to the white king
[Laughter]
yeah oh my gosh so this is why you have
to move back to YouTube but the downside
and this is a big downside you have
enabled the pawn to squeak forward to D2
and you know what comes after D2 D1
White's pawns just don't look as
impressive when there isn't a whole you
know Entourage of pieces standing behind
them right that's when the bonds look
like they're doing all the work now you
see that it's the pieces really doing
the heavy lifting why do you think black
is going to do here because this
position is very likely should noterbeck
jump into D4 with his Knight and I think
he will
yeah I mean there's so many tempting
things I I love your idea of playing D2
uh I really do adore that move I mean I
would also be tempted to play D2 and
after The Rook swings to E2 or through
E3 if you go e Rook E3 I kind of wanted
to go Queen H6
yeah you know
I like to get greedy but
I'm I might at a lawsuit and then and
then back that up with Bishop G5
and if I go here you can still take on
H5 because the Rook hangs
and then you can take it and then go
okay you can just take on F5
I was wondering about Bishop G5 at some
stages
I mean it does it just feels like
there's some kind of pins
well Bishop G5 I will play F4
but I think this is already a deal
breaker for white like even if black
only has this you're a pawn down your
king side is in shambles your Bishop's
horrible and black just has the clear
path of going H5 H4 and you know resting
control of the D file so this line is
highly problematic for what at which
point could Arjun deviate well if we
rewind a little bit
I mean this position Yogi I wouldn't say
forced but extremely likely because are
you really going to go Rook F1 that
looks even worse
yeah yes no no no don't do that
um
um okay maybe we can rewind back to
Knight D4 I mean what's the capture
forced Okay so
text here Knight D4 take care
it's forced
it's forced right okay
can't do anything about that well Queen
D3 is even worse as we established and
maybe that end game is the Lesser evil
maybe that's the upshot of of what we're
you know getting at here but
I don't think Arjun would do that even
if it was the Lesser evil I think he
would seek his Fortunes in the sharper
middle game maybe here you want to find
a better score for the bishop but I I
mean it's one or the other F6 black just
plays GF and the g file opens you can't
afford that
I don't know what white is supposed to
do here so you are forced to go Bishop
G6 G3 sorry
um
D2 yeah this is forced so we reached
this position basically by force so here
I think white has to hunker down
maybe that's Queen takes one seven nice
yeah
and after Queen taste porn you just
trade off
what do we make of this end game may be
holdable for white
Nike
and wherever wherever we look at it it's
like um
this porn on D2 is mighty fine
um I agree it's uh I I also have this
rule in uh in games when it comes to
pawns it's the quality not the quantity
it is the quality
yeah the better they are
indeed and this is crazy but Arjun is
once again going to be squarely on the
defensive I think unless we're grossly
misevaluating this position should
motorbeck jump into D4 with his Knight
and I think at this point what might be
going through his mind is is this too
good to be true is did Arjun really just
allow me to take over the initiative
like that but given his current form
Yogi I mean notrebec is going to play an
ig4 he just is not going to let this
opportunity pass him by
and our generic icy will once again find
it necessary to pull through with the
defensive effort and already in severe
time pressure Deja Vu for the Indian
Grandmaster
he does seem to be following this uh
pattern where he gets a terrible
position and then he plays so well he
plays incredibly just to defend it and
hold the half points
and
well
it's been working so far but it sure is
nerve-wracking
yeah you're not going to pull it out
forever especially not against Notre
Beck and I just wanted to open up a
brief larger conversation you'll be
about Notre back you know we sing the
Praises of these young players again and
again and I feel like there's been a sea
change in the last couple of months
about our discussion of future world
champions you know that's chess fans
love that question you know who do you
think has the biggest potential to
unseat Magnus Carlson who's going to
headline the next generation of Chess
stars and I feel like alireza farouza
was the one name that was repeated again
and again uh let's say six months ago
but I really feel as notorbeck takes on
F5 uh that Abdul satorov is absolutely
world champion material I mean the guy
is 18 years old and he's got no
weaknesses in his game it's crazy
I'm really really sorry to interrupt you
but I do think we should Dash over to
the Magnus Carlson Richard Rapport game
because originally sacrifice another
piece
we go straight there first to the bird's
eye view really quickly he is two pieces
down and now to the Magnus game
oh my gosh
oh my gosh like how did what is this
how did he find how did he manage to
sacrifice the second piece and by the
way Notre back he did play Knight E4 so
we will keep you posted as that game
follows exactly the exact line that we
just examined but Bishop E3 Bishop C
fiber F1 check back
threatened mate
oh The Bishop's hanging you just take he
just took it it's just check your check
and his idea is after Bishop I mean you
can you've got two moves You've Got King
F2 and you've got Bishop G1 that's it
wait a sec at all
yeah Bishop G1 right
after Queen H4 is Perpetual so this yes
it and then Bishop H2 and uh I think
Checkmate that's going to send my heart
racing so King goes to F2 and now
and the game is over
I'm I don't know
I'm very very confused it's okay so
let's step back here for a second Maybe
he wants to push his h-pond down the
board maybe he wants H4 but this also
doesn't work his wife Jinx the bishop to
H3 and traps the queen and White's two
pieces up no that's not that
what else could it be
G6 maybe to dislodge The Rook from the f
file first
thank you okay yeah that's nice because
after Rook takes F7 hey you're opening
up lines and Rook hf8
that's going to be
unpleasant although the computer is kind
of the evaluation bar is kind of saying
it's not working which then inspires me
to find either queen or Bishop C4
connect the bishop and The Rock and the
obvious human move here is to take and
go Rook f8 but let's not forget that
white is two pieces up not one piece but
two pieces and he remains two pieces up
after your other move Queen to B3 and
hear blacks attack Fizzles out
so if we rewind black is not supposed to
take on F7 but oh my gosh
this is definitely objectively lost for
Richard report
ah I don't see a movie
he just missed something
hmm
H2 I guess in this position is a better
attempt
but
soon well then maybe I can try E3 check
it's Carlson has to be careful but it's
it's losing
can you can you come run with the King
to F3
oh man
takes tits Rook Cafe now nope not rookie
eight Rook f8 but again you've got Queen
B3
exactly and give back some material
because now the counter check is gonna
be a deadly
obviously we've gone very far down this
line but essentially if black plays G6
then all of these moves are largely
forced so let's rewind for a second I
know people in the chat might feel a
little bit overwhelmed here Bishop G1 is
on the board so let's get us back to the
live board what we are expecting what we
were just calculating is the move G6 and
just so we're all on the same page the
reason Bishop H2 isn't effective is
because the king lifts up to F2
connecting the queen and the bishop
black is down two minor pieces
Richard report who's not at the board
again Yogi he seems totally unconcerned
or maybe he's too disgusted to look at
the board
this is not how you beat Magnus he's
going to find all of these moves right
he just does not stumble in these types
of positions ever
when the win is so close at hand
and I have to say in most of those moves
were kind of forced for white you know
when the bishop comes down to Age Two
there's no other way you have to step up
with the King when you attack The Rook
you have to do something with your Rook
human you have to move it along the F
line there's no other thing and should
the black porn move forward to H4 well
you have to stop it getting to H3 so
every single one of those moves
the reply is super natural and that's a
problem
it's a huge problem and when you're
evaluating the Practical value of a
sacrifice you have to factor that into
the equation are my opponents moves
forced and the worst situation the most
tilting situation is when your opponent
has no choice but to find the correct
moves that's what you want to try to
avoid and I think the only way to create
a more open-ended situation here is to
play the move G6 try to get white to
take on F7 and open a second front down
the f file but man the evaluation's
about plus three I'm surprised it's not
more than that so if Richard plays like
an engine for five or six moves maybe he
can whip up some counter play but 30
minutes on the clock for the world
champion I think that's enough time to
navigate his way out of the situation
and consolidate his material advantage
and score what would be an absolutely
critical full point
yeah and it would be absolutely critical
and it does feel like this second
sacrifice
was asking too much of the position and
it seems to have kind of fallen into
magnus's lap you know it just happened
and it probably means that Richard was
perhaps thinking he hadn't found the
best way to continue that a marvelous
sacrifice or by putting the Knight on e4
earlier
I do feel that somehow something went
wrong and Richard was kicking himself
and this second sacrifice is a
psychological result of that
it just seems to me that this game
epitomizes why reports struggles against
Carlson I mean Magnus he put so much
pressure on you that he almost forces
you into these drastic measures and
report is such a Creative Flair he's so
fun to watch He's everybody's favorite
super GM because he will always give you
an entertaining tournament I think the
candidates last candidates are a great
example of that he was struggling all
tournament long and yet even his losses
were more entertaining than some other
players wins so all credit to Richard
report but the world champion is too
precise he's too clinical for this style
of play uh to succeed uh more often than
once in a blue moon
yeah
yeah but uh impressive game from Magnus
I like the way he defended this and uh
should I don't I mean Richard has 24
minutes so he could take a while to come
up with his next move in the meantime
should we move over to the bird's eye
view
let's do it I I feel like we're in the
situation you get into in a hotel where
you decide between the elevator and the
stairs you call the elevator you're like
do I wait for it the moment you open the
stairwell the elevator arrives I feel
that way with Richard report he's about
to play G6 the moment we leave his game
but we'll keep you posted look at Eric
in the top left they are following the
exact line that we analyze and queen H6
here was your suggestion I think there's
a high probability that that move
appears on the board as well
okay yeah things are not looking that
great for Arjun there because uh his
King looks shaky and of course Black's
Pawn on D2 it looks Mighty strong to me
um we're kind of talking about losing
and someone who's been skirting On The
Edge Edge of defeat for quite a while is
that Jordan van Forest has he managed to
ride out that storm or is he still
groveling away
it looks like he's groveling away but I
definitely think that is a worthy game
for us to check out because Prague where
they win in this game would move to a
amazing and epic plus two score and make
a serious bid to win the tournament
which is which is wild okay let's uh see
what has happened in the last couple of
moves we saw the position after black
17th move Queen to C7 Prague forces the
bishop to commit with H3 Jordan sees
nothing better than to trade there's
that before move as expected Prague
accompanies it with a rook trade which
obviously favors the side of material he
does not blunder his Knight big surprise
there and now maneuvering the other
night over to before to dislodge the
queen and pave the way unroll the red
carpet so to speak for the Apon now I
don't think the position is entirely
one-sided Yobe and I think Jordan has
just uh stumbled upon an important
defensive idea which is to bring the
Knight over to C7 and once the queen
moves away you can establish a little
side blockade on A6 or the Knight could
jump out to B5 in some cases if White's
Pawn advances 2a5 what do you think
about this defensive approach
I like it in fact it's very reminiscent
of what pregnant did to Abdul sitarov in
yesterday's game you know his sacrifice
support and just located what's Advanced
pawn and I think that's the way to do it
you know you've got to follow the rule
Knights make fantastic placadas I mean
the queen she's needed somewhere on the
king side to kind of initiate chaos let
the Knight blockade there's Sarah Rogue
Pawn on A4
Knight C7 has been played and I don't
think Prague will be able to resist nor
should he resist the temptation to play
Knight before now he does resist that he
plays them of A5 and I think I see why
he wants that A4 Square for his Queen
and he wants to combine the progress of
the a pawn with the direct assault on a
huge weakness on C6 the slav pawn is now
the greatest Target in the position
ah Prague is good isn't he there's no
denying it
um now you have to you have to handle
this queen A4 as you said and uh that's
not easy
the instinct is actually to attack the
queen and play Knight to B5 and then
just try to perhaps blockade not on
A6 but on A7
hmm so but uh not like it
no
what do you mean Black's position is
fantastic lots of winning chances very
active these are kingside counter play
so yeah
I I I don't really have too many moves
to suggest here other than okay hang on
hang on hang on hang on a second I was
too pessimistic I can actually put the
queen on to C4
okay so Queen C4 let's bring up our
analysis board
I'm a little bit active and I see the
evaluation bar hates this
huh and what if I go according to plan
with night before
I'm gonna hit C6
yeah
laughing your face here ghosts yeah yeah
and laughing is the correct response
because often I'd be five just move your
queen and I have to kind of go
Rexy eight and that is not a great move
well yeah Knight A7 is no
97 there's Knight C6
no no no no no this this is bad this is
falling apart no no no the queen cannot
go to C4 you can't go for any active
measures you just have to sit tight
um
no no no no no Dreadful Dreadful
Dreadful
um can't do this go back to her original
position
so no Queen C4 Queen C4 is out I think
you're on to something though for let me
just say I think Knight B5 hastens
defeat because after Queen A4
where you really want this Knight to be
is not on B5 it's not doing anything
here I think you want it on A6 so maybe
the best approach here is to drop the
queen back let's say to C8 if white
plays A6 prematurely black could try to
surround the pawn with rookie and maybe
even Knight B8 so if Prague goes Knight
before maybe Jordan can try to hold the
fort with the move Knight A6 again the
evil bar creeping up and perhaps it's
because white just accumulates the
pressure with Queen A4
and unfortunately Rook B5 looks great
but fails to Knight takes the I mean
whatever black does here something
collapses the OV it's either the C6 Pawn
it's the queen it's the pawn it's The
Rook I mean the position is just too
flimsy the pieces are too passive even
though the engine is giving something
like plus 1.8 I feel like in Practical
terms black is just borderline hopeless
borderline hopeless
yeah I kind of agree with you as well
and I was gonna say yeah you might stop
one night getting to the B4 square but
uh there's an another Knight sitting on
C1 that can make its night make its way
there so
ah
it's difficult to suggest a move for
Jordan I mean the one great thing is he
does have a lot of time on his clock
that's that's something
on the audience
in the old days I think they would just
resign here with black you know I I was
looking uh yesterday at uh games from
the tournament in Venice in 1950
um I was reading Alexander kotav who
perhaps some people in the chat will
know as the author of how to think like
a grand master one of the most famous uh
chess books of all time he was a Soviet
Grandmaster one of the top players of
the Soviet Union never became world
champion but he was also the sort of
official journalist uh so when he would
go to tournaments together with Smith's
love and batmanic uh he would always
write about their experiences so he has
a book on the Venice uh super tournament
1950 where a lot of the top players of
the day played first of all uh the way
that the players got to those
tournaments is incredible like I
complain about travel all the time I
complain about a two-hour flight DeLay
So in 1950 Smith's love and kodov left
Moscow airport at 12 a.m they had to fly
10 hours to Prague because back then the
range of the airplanes was limited so
they had to stop for fuel three times in
Prague they had to catch another flight
to Rome and he has a funny phrase he
says we were exhausted and we were
thinking about going and just exploring
for frog and getting a hotel but the
next flight was seven days away so they
would have missed the entire tournament
and it took them 12 hours to reach one
European country from another but the
reason I bring this up is that a lot of
the games in the tournament when one
player would reach just like a position
like this with no Prospect you would
just see a lot of premature resignations
and I feel like that's one way in which
chess has changed it's become a lot more
of a sport where you don't give up just
because you're down 20 points you play
Until The Bitter End that's your
responsibility you don't play for
enjoyment in those cases you play to
save one game out of ten
yeah I I agree with you uh there were a
lot of premature resignations but I
think a lot of it's to do with the
Germans
um because often you'd reach move 40 and
there would be maybe one side was
winning but there was still a lot of
play left but because of the a German
situation where the game would just stop
the players would stop for dinner they
would gather their friends around maybe
their seconds and their teammates and
they would have a good old uh go at
solving the positions that you would
often see this kind of like oh I resign
I can't be bothered to play on because I
know you've analyzed the best possible
consideration now you know with the time
and controls kind of sharpening up
they're being quicker time controls
suddenly it becomes much more attractive
to fight it out until The Bitter End
because you know there's the possibility
to go wrong
there most certainly is and let's be
very clear on one account this game is
not over Jordan uh is a resilient player
he's going to try his best and Prague
still has a lot of work to do if he
wants another point on their crotch
table okay let's swing back to the
bird's eye view Magnus Carlson in the
meantime has captured on F7 Richard did
play the only viable move G6 but that
game I think is furiously moving toward
a rather unhappy conclusion for the
Hungarian Romanian Grandmaster
and uh talking about resignation do you
think that Richard will resign in the
next few moves
I think I think he's going to try Rook
f8 Bishop C4 and you know there was an
engine line there that minute well quote
unquote keeps the evaluation to
something like plus three I think
whether or not he resigns of course
depends on whether he's able to win back
one of magnus's pieces if he can win one
of those pieces back even if the attack
Fizzles out he's going to try to keep
playing so we'll find out in the next
couple of moves but obviously the
position is lost and I think his chances
are close to zero
okay
okay because I was I was a bit worried
that these engine lines were perhaps you
know Magnus just giving back material in
order to
just
completely demolish the attack and if
the Queens get traded off then it's
ridiculous
so well we will see and uh a game that
we haven't visited in a long time maybe
we can check out the bird's eye view I
was kind of curious to see how ding was
doing against Vincent climber because
the last time we left it it didn't look
good and ding was groveling and I can
just see from the bird's eye view that
there is a beautiful Pawn chain on the
board
but it seems to me that Ding is Alive
and Kicking and I don't think he's that
much worse
yeah I mean that pawn chain is beautiful
but so is the Knight on F5 so let's go
to that game we still have uh the same
pieces on the board two Rooks and a
knight for both sides now first of all
ding has managed to avoid Armageddon
there uh with the Rook appearing on the
seventh rank he pushed it back to D2
instead Vincent focusing on the queen
side there is now a Pawn on A4 which is
obviously more of a weakness than a
strength in our last couple of moves
were
rookie 4 Rook G6 threatening H4 to break
apart the pawn chain Vincent saw nothing
better than to move back to B5 and ding
says I'm more than happy with three move
repetition back he goes to C6
and Knight C3 Rook G6 you'll be would
lead to repetition I think there's no
way Vincent acquiesces to a draw but if
not Knight C3 how does he make progress
maybe he wants to slow roll it with a
move like King F2 but that's a sign that
I think the worst is behind ding
yeah it is a sign I'm also just thinking
about the overall tournament situation
um Vincent of course has suffered a few
devastating losses he's just he's
playing this game on the back of a loss
to Wesley so
and remember that he also lost in game
five to levona Ronin in a heartbreaking
style maybe he's just going you know
what
let's just accept the draw
let's repeat the position and focus our
energies onto the next game
that's entirely possible when your
confidence is hurt and you're playing
someone of ding's caliber it's just
easier to get frustrated you're a little
bit less resilient
and uh it depends on how much time
Vincent spends he's got 22 minutes for
nine moves that's not time pressure but
it's also not you know insignificant so
I think he's got to make a decision in
the next couple of minutes I would vote
King F2 though I feel like he still
isn't risking that's for king after Rook
C5 you can always drop back to C3 on the
next move as I say that King F2 appears
on the board there we go yeah and uh
we've been very good and so far at
predicting how things are gonna play out
King F2 on the board
makes me feel good do you ever get the
sense of satisfaction when the players
make the move that you suggested all the
time being chess Bingo you know I'm like
yay I won I didn't that's the top of the
move no it it does there is a satisfying
feeling and I think you know our job
part of our job as commentators is to
try to tell people how the game is going
to go uh before the move is reached so
we have you know The Insider knowledge
we have advanced notice of which
direction the game is going to go well
we have advanced notice of a different
minor tournament that is going to happen
uh from April 7th to May 1st it's called
the World Championship
uh and it will be it will take place in
the city of Astana Kazakhstan from April
7th to May 1st a new world champion will
be crowned as Jan nipponishi and dingley
ren will battle to seize the throne left
vacant by Magnus carlsen's withdrawal
this could not be a more hype event and
it is coming your way just around two
months and change Yogi how excited are
you to watch ding against nepo
I'm very excited I actually can't wait
to see how things are going to play out
I just love the fact that during these
World Championship matches it becomes
all about the Mind Games it becomes all
about the engines the seconds who's
doing what how are they training are
they also kind of working hard on their
Fitness how are they going to cope with
the psychological pressure I have to say
I love that storyline and that to me is
almost just as important as the chess
because the chess is going to be
exceptionally high level and we're
probably going to see it lots and lots
of draw and so when someone cracks it's
going to be really important to kind of
like just critique how did it happen how
can things be improved should how can
they recover from this and it's it's
brilliant and I I love it and that's why
even if it's ding against napoleoni and
obviously I would love it to be Magnus
defending his title again but uh it
isn't and that kind of also brings with
it a new freshness because we don't
quite know how ding is going to cope
with all this pressure
I mean if we're honest all chess stands
collectively are are definitely groaning
that Magnus Carlson is not participating
right that's not a good thing but uh we
have to a I think make the most of the
situation and B give maximum respect to
the players you know it's not Ding and
nepo's fault the Magnus isn't playing
and it's still a world championship
right the rules are still the rules the
winner of the match is still the world
champion and I still think that that
will be a Monumental achievement but you
brought up an earlier point right as we
uh start to make our way back to the
bird's eye view just one more thought I
had on ding is that the time before the
world championship match Yogi is just
unenviable you have to hide your
openings and it's really a matter of
life or death you just cannot reveal any
of your nice opening prep or really any
opening prep at all you want to keep
everything a secret and that is no easy
matter that basically means having an
entirely different repertoire in the
months leading up to a world
championship match and even though these
players are capable of playing many
different openings you see them going to
drastic lengths to abscond their
preparation including ding playing 184
which would have gotten you left out of
the room if you said that would happen a
couple months ago
I know we have seen ding make a lot of
surprising opening choices and yeah I
and also it's interesting for him as
well how is he gonna cope with the
psychological pressure because again all
the eyes of the world are on him how is
he going to cope with this particular
tournament and one interesting fact that
was brought to my attention is that he's
here on his own he doesn't have
seconds with him he's got no no company
and I find that quite unusual because
maybe again that also leads to opening
preparation for the world championship
match he cannot have a second with him
because he has to keep that information
hidden
yeah I mean the the pressure in these
tournaments is incredible and to handle
all of that alone
uh is is incredibly admirable and ding
does it with style and class he is one
of the most well-liked players both
among his uh the other super Grand
Masters and of course among chess fans
at large Bishop H2 there by Richard
report as we uh had predicted I think
and eval bar just continues to shoot up
King F2 there and Magnus I think is only
a couple of moves away from securing uh
the full point Queen C4 you predicted
another one although I'm not sure that's
a good thing I'm not sure that's a good
thing for Jordan because Knight before
what's him on the cusp of losing
I know I know I was gonna point that out
to you it seems to me that we've
predicted the continuation of era Galaxy
against Abdus we've been uh very good
with Jordan fan forest and Prague
um not in a good way and uh We've also
done very well because Magnus Carlson
and Richard are following our analysis
oh goodness me yeah we have it look at
the ability
Queen H6 Queen D7 we got that as well I
know I mean we really are hitting the
jackpot today
very nice very nice and the games are so
exciting I feel like it's it's easy to
be invested and engaged uh when when
these games are are such a treat it's
funny that the Wesley game still feels
like it's early in the middle game but
that's deceptive because it's further
advanced than it looks and the time
situation is very alarming gukesh is
down to four minutes so we're gonna get
a Time scramble there I honestly don't
know which game we should go to because
so many games have reached a climax at
the same time that it would make sense
to go to really any of them so I'm gonna
put you on the spot you've helped me out
where are we gonna go next
um maybe to the
bring
the time to scramble quickly
you know what we're gonna do because I'm
so indecisive and I don't want to make
the wrong decision we're going to take
this opportunity to go on a short break
we're gonna wait for a little bit more
clarity particularly in the Magnus game
when we come back that game might be on
the cusp of being over so as we once
again look at that beautiful playing
haul here at the 85th edition of the
Tata steel chess tournament do not go
anywhere because the games from round
seven are as exciting as ever the world
champion might be knocking on the door
of a victory and we will bring you more
Tata steel coverage when we return in
just a couple of minutes
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to round seven of the Tata
steel chess tournament
2023 85 years of incredible action in
the village of vikon Zay and we will
start by reviewing the standings one
more time if you are just joining us it
has been a wildly impressive performance
by the Uzbek Talent notorbec abusatorah
who leads in clear first with four and a
half out of six on the heels of a win
over the world champion the world
champion sits at two and a half out of
six minus one a shocking alternative
events here Yogi as Magnus Carlson is
trying to make his way out of the bottom
half of the tournament cross table
I know when was the last time you saw
him in 10th place out of 14
um this is the very first time in my
life that I've seen such a thing happen
and of course at the top naughty back
abdusitor of 18 years old such a
phenomenal talent and uh What uh
absolute blister of a tournament and
blister blur I missed all the players
are just like blistering away they are
playing Amazing chess and uh let's have
a look at the time control
yeah well the time control is 100
minutes for 40 moves it's one of the
longest if not the longest time control
of any annual super tournament and the
important thing to note right now is
that there is a 50 minute time Edition
after uh move 40 is made some of the
games are inching close to that time
Edition and then on move 60 you've got
an additional 15 minutes and of course
there is a 30 second increment from the
very first move 30 seconds are added to
your clock after each move is made and
in this round I think more so uh than
the two previous rounds that I've
commentated uh there there are just more
time scrambles I think actually most of
the games have entered what I would
really call A Time scramble phase
Richard report is struggling against
Magnus he sacrificed two pieces
swashbuckling play by the Hungarian
Grand Master but I don't think it's
going to turn out successfully he is he
has found a way Yogi as we discussed
during the break to win back one of
Magnus this is pieces so it ain't over
just yet but Carlson could happily give
that piece up and permanently end
Black's initiative
Wayne B3 not the most accurate move
though
is not the most accurate move but it's
sufficient and this was actually the
move that Drew our eye first and uh we
thought it was great
um because the whole idea is that if
black were to ask the Kings and
questions by pushing that pawn up one
square E3 the king would just go sure no
problems King F3 and suddenly it is the
counter attack that white has that is
gonna be deadly the queen is going to
come to E6 and there is no way the black
king or the black Rook will be able to
survive that one
and so if E3 is not possible then report
has to go Bishop takes G1 he has just
played that I actually think I take back
what I just said Carlson has calculated
a long and forced variation at the end
of which he will basically force a queen
trade I think where a couple moves away
from resignation we don't have to make
any moves in the analysis board because
they're going to make those for US
Reports moves are absolutely forced and
queen H4 check here travels back to F6
and is going to pick up that Bishop on
F7 the problem is that why it also has
an extra piece called a knight that sits
on C3 and that is going to capture the
pawn on e4 in due course after which
black will have a miserable Pawn for the
piece
yeah that is no way sufficient for that
kind of deficit and I agree with you
Queen H4 or it's going to be resign time
it's up to Richard to decide he's a
combative player you might as well give
that check to the white king and see
where it goes see if there's still some
way that Magnus can't go wrong it is
kind of Mission Impossible though
here's my prediction Queen H4 Magnus
will play G3 the point of G3 is to
create a Luft Square for the king queen
F6 check King G2 now there does seem to
be a scary looking Chuck on F3 if black
plays Rook F7 he hastens his defeat
because the Knight is inevitably moving
to D6 you can even take on F7 first so
black has to give that check but the
king calmly drops back to H2 Queen F2 is
blocked by Rook G2 Queen takes F7 leads
to a queen trade and Rook takes F7 leads
to an immediate loss after Queen E6 and
queen takes E4 black uh runs out of
checks and runs out of meaningful moves
if I had to break a prediction I think
the game is going to end after Carlson
plays the move Queen E6 check right but
I'm going out on a limb here
yeah it is a natural conclusion to the
game and uh looking at Richard's body
language oh he's reaching for the queen
Queen H4 played and
G3
and G3 is such a Magnus move just
eliminate all complications Force the
game and to clarify the position you
don't have to go King E3 here and look
for Adventures where they're not
necessary
yeah that kind of King I have a name for
I call them Spartan King which came a
king that's that's leading its forces
from the front is a king called uh from
Sparta my Spartan King
I see yeah
um uh there could be kind of like idiots
rather though because you there's no way
you want your king wandering out leading
the charge in the middle game
um sometimes it works but that's very
much the exception to the rule a king
goes out to E3 no way uh Magnus just
re-checking his lines he's just making
sure that after G3 there's nothing he
could have missed and fully expecting
the king sorry the king oh he is the
king the time being Magnus Carlson to
block that check
well I'm fully expecting the king to
treat his King pretty well and Magnus is
not going to keep Richie waiting for too
long he's going to put him out of his
misery quickly here and Magnus you know
he knows the significance of this game
he's got 24 minutes on his clock and I'm
always taken with the fact that even the
best players in the world literally the
best player in the world they double
they triple check their line so the
young members of the audience watching
these games and trying to take
inspiration I think it's just important
to notice that you're never above double
checking stuff and just making sure that
your calculation is correct with that
said I think G3 is coming to a theater
near you any second now
yeah absolutely I mean how many games
have you saved by just not making that
move impetuously you know how many
points have been saved by simply taking
the time out rechecking everything
making sure it's all good
and then the hand and the Brain can
catch up they can align together and
they can make the move
um I have to say I have been on the
receiving end of the hand reaching out
and making a move before the brain
caught up and I was like I was literally
looking at my hand like why did you make
that terrible move it's almost like I
had no responsibility you know I had no
autonomy over this body part I mean it
was
that's so correct yeah you just you just
bring your brain has this natural system
of preventing you uh you used a good
word there from doing something
impetuous but
um there are times when that membrane is
breached and there's just nothing you
can do you can't resist the temptation
especially if you play a lot of bullet
not gonna name any names but I am I am
surprised that Magnus has taken out
three minutes to play a move which
literally just will lead to resignation
but he knows he's not in the greatest
form and you want to do stuff to
compensate and you know that you're
struggling you know that you're making
uncharacteristic blunders Magnus is not
about to let this game out of the bag
no I mean there's no way that he could
be considering stepping up with the king
or moving the king to E2 I just I I just
why do you need to go into for those
Dramatics keep it simple
the you know
in Simplicity there is perfection
here
he's just thinking
I mean
magnus's body language right now is very
hard to read
it doesn't look like he's like Yep this
is a win for me this is all good it just
looks like he's incredibly focused in
fact I
know he's Rich whoa no he is running
with a king
oh
wow oh well well
that was a turn up for the books
um
but okay
let's have a look at the position I'm in
is it still very much in the bag for
Magnus
I am frankly pretty shocked at this
because and I okay let me make one thing
very clear he's still winning he hasn't
lost the decisive Advantage but the
reason I'm floored is that after Queen
G4 check which is on the board
King to D2 I presume is his idea he's
seeking shelter on the other side of the
board now first of all after King D2
black will play Queen F4 check
don't go Casey too and walk into well
actually maybe you could but King to D1
is much simpler blackface Rook F7 and
this is an inferior version obviously of
the same position which would which
would have occurred with the King
sitting pretty on H2 surrounded by you
know uh a pina colada and lying on the
beach with that pawn on G3 giving it
complete shelter now you know the king
is there's no pina colada to be found on
D1 and if you give that check on E6
which Magnus will I would be you know a
little bit concerned after let's say
well I guess King C7 white can trade
Queens here so maybe black should play
I don't know where black should go King
d8 King B8 but I think people can
understand the point King on D1 just
feels a lot less comfortable than it
would on H2 it's still winning I still
have no doubt the Magnus will secure the
full point
but this was an uncharacteristically
sloppy move by the world champion
yeah I mean I have to say it wasn't the
most precise technique but maybe he's
just seen one move ahead maybe he's
banking everything like in a in our
analysis position or moves like Queen
takes porn and he's saying okay calm
down it's enough and I'm getting ready
to meet moves like Queen F2 which
okay yeah you yeah Queen F2 Queen after
rookie one Rook to E1 and that's it it's
gonna be game over and Checkmate but
you're right Queen takes Queen Knight
takes Queen
Rook comes to D7 still in the game
and there we go there's a direct
consequence of putting the King on D1
not only is it weaker it's also taking
away the rightful Square from The Rook
if the King was on H2 here normally you
want your king closer to the center but
here it's just important to keep your
pawns protected after Rook D1 the game
would be over as it stands white can
force The Rook terrano King E2 and Rook
D1 but these types of end games where
black has the potential for passers on
both sides they're actually a lot harder
to win than they might say Knights are
not very good at containing Pawn
majorities in general especially not on
both sides of the board okay back we go
to the live board because we're going to
get a lot of moves fast here
let's see what the world champion
decides to do where is he going to run
with his King
I think he has to go King D2 I I just do
not see an alternative King D2 and King
D1
yeah oh I was wondering whether he could
repeat moves but no he cannot candy too
looks makes a lot of sense to me I mean
probably he's calculating all these kind
of moves such as E3 seeing if that has a
disruptive effect on the position but uh
it's fine
King
um
and uh Magnus thinking
it's focused
it's a tough choice right King King E1
you have Queen G3 King E2 I mean
it's just 72 candy one makes perfect
sense
it's just all of this could have been
avoided if he had gone King H2 like he
wouldn't have had to decide where to put
his King and he wouldn't have had to
dodge the potential Fork against his
Rook so I really I I don't like to jump
to conclusions I think chess fans and
sometimes commentators have a tendency
to uh use things to weigh things too
drastically oh this is evidence that
Magnus is in terrible form and he is
washed up and this is just more of the
same okay this is the somewhat sloppy
move that doesn't really give away the
win it's more that it's uncharacteristic
for Magnus because we are so used to to
him operating with surgical Precision
but okay as the world champion Ponders
where to put his King Yobe we've got
crazy action on a lot of the other
boards so I know people want to see
Magnus and we promise to keep you
abreast of the developments but we
cannot miss the action on some of the
other boards as we go back to our bird's
eye view crazy stuff happening in
Origins board he is on the verge of
losing his game as we uh fought against
Abdul satorav looks like Wesley so is
taking over the advantage against cash
struggling again where to from here
carwana's better now oh my gosh
yeah it feels like this is going to be a
very bloody round with a lot of decisive
games and the one that catches my eye is
uh basically uh Arjun eragaisy and
nordebec abdusatorov I mean we kind of
followed the games for quite a while and
they actually seem to follow our
analysis how things panned out
oh my gosh what a position and as we
transition to that game a huge shout out
to the over 30 000 of you on the edge of
your seats across YouTube and twitch we
really appreciate the energy in the chat
and uh just showing up on a weekend you
could be having brunch with your friends
maybe you are but you're sneaking some
glances at your phone how can you miss
this Breakneck action okay it is I'm
just a torabs move they went down the
exact line that we had outlined and
currently The Rook is hanging note
Rebecca has to decide where he puts it
and to me it'll be the most natural
Square unless there's some sort of a
sacrifice here which I don't see Rook G4
to D4 you have to keep this Pawn
incredibly well protected you cannot
afford to lose this Pawn for nothing if
you're noted back and he's just played
it yeah yeah what a roll keep it simple
Rick D4 a nice move and uh all you need
to do now is start improving your other
Rook that's not working on a f8 get that
into the game somehow and then
start picking off all those weak pawns
I'm thinking of that pawn on F5 it
doesn't really have a home
doesn't have a safe spot
and I also have to say part of me is
also attempted to reroute the bishop
to move it along to B6 if possible but I
realize that's not possible for the time
being because of Rook takes Pawn
well yes and no I mean even if you give
up D2 and you recapture F5 black lacks
advantages uh indisputable there it's
just I think Notre back will probably
want to squeeze out he can do that
whenever he wants to essentially but
nine minutes on the clock in this
position can you imagine that I mean
yesterday Eric icy saved kind of a
similar position in spirit against Geary
with a similarly alarming time situation
the problem here is that objectively
he's a lot worse here than he was
against the niche the position is a lot
less two-sided
yeah no definitely here you know take a
look at what his pieces none of them are
active and also the defining factor is
that porn on D2 look how it cuts White's
forces into and just forces white into
passivity and on top of that huge
problem there is the big issue of King
safety I mean if this taraf is feeling
in a really feisty move he could even
start trading off the Defenders around
White's killing maybe with a bishop F4
Bishop H4 at the right time and start
asking questions like how are you going
to hide yourself and these such
unpleasant things for aragaisy to deal
with
well as we're talking he's dropped down
now to eight minutes he's gonna have to
start blitzing out moves it is
inconceivable to me that he saves this
game Notre back doesn't have too much
time in his own right but his position
is so much easier to play and the the
cost of a single mistake is far uh
decreased if you're not about because
you've got to supply a steady supply of
moves that you know can't really ruin
the position I'm talking Rook FDA you
pointed out moving the bishop back if
White's Queen leaves G2 which should
very well might the queen can slide in
to H3 from whence it came a couple of
moves earlier uh this is
this is devastating I I just don't see
Arjun holding pulling this one out
now his position is just creaking and uh
shall we take a look at the bird's eye
view
yeah yeah
we have to go there and I'm just the
kind of game that I kind of want to keep
a really close eye on is the of course
the Magnus game because he's of course
two pieces up now just one piece up
against Richard rapport and
how is it looking so this one is on the
bottom right
he's
figured out a way to trade Queens he's
just swung his Queen from B3 to H3 and
they're incredibly sad thing for Richard
report is that even though Carlson has
played a couple sloppy moves he's still
completely winning and Carlson is going
to convert this end game up a piece I
think the main difference is the report
is not going to resign he's going to
keep playing
but I just don't think he's got any
realistic chances what's worse than
being in an end game against Carlson
being an endgame against Carlson down a
piece
yeah I'm not sure I think that Richard
will stop we'll kind of keep on playing
I think he might just go this is enough
this oh entirely countries get traded
off and the white king Finds Its way in
the middle of the board on E3 I think it
will be enough handshake and there we
can catch a glimpse
the back of Richard's head and he does
not look happy
yeah he knows he knows that this game is
virtually decided more good stuff by the
way from notrebec as he has just moved
his Bishop from G5 to H4 into refusing
the queen trade and exposing the glaring
weaknesses on White's King side it seems
to me that Arjun is going down maybe
even faster than Richard report we're
going to have clearly a couple games
ending basically at the same time
caruana against Max Sudlow is another
game that has reached a certain state of
clarity Zulu is up a pawn but Fabi has a
furious initiative uh going in the
center I feel like that game is likely
to end in some sort of a piece where
white can use the B4 Pawn as a
bargaining chip to get rid of Black's
initiative
man we could get like four results in
the span of you know the next 10 minutes
I think so too because uh also good cash
is struggling against Wesley so he's
he's a pawn down and uh his position
just doesn't look good I mean so look at
his Bishop on his starting square and
see one doesn't make a good impression
and none of his pieces have any active
roles whatsoever
no they do not bad news no they do not
bad news indeed shall we take a quick
look at the gukesh game maybe just a
minute or two to understand the extent
to which he is struggling is it lost or
does he have some chances
okay let's go there
we'll bring you more Magnus as report
Ponders his next move okay
I think that this game
is close to being over if Wesley just
takes this Knight on E3 he's got a fork
on C4 coming in
oh
oh no oh
it says
a minute for nine moves
oh and he can capture that Knight three
ways and it doesn't really matter
because every single one of them Falls
for some kind of Reason uh so okay gosh
[Music]
this is over
no that is not good news
any sense of the word Rick takes oh or
this or or this I mean look at look at
White's Pawn structure look at White's
Bishop it's like kukesh has made less
moves than Wesley has or so it seems how
did this get so out of control gukesh is
unable to contain uh Wesley's King side
initiative and of course if white plays
let's say Rook takes E3 and the Knight
C4 picks off an exchange and I can't
even sack the queen for a rook in a
piece because the Rook on E8 is
protected by this hero of a queen on B5
and Wesley look how patient he is just
making sure double checking he's got
plenty of time
this one's gonna end pretty quickly as
well
it is if he spots that killer blow but I
mean it wasn't necessarily a natural
move to capture on E3 because the bishop
on C5 is just such a beautiful piece and
the Knight on E3 well it's doing nothing
let's Pace it
but once you spot it
killer blow
E3 fp3 is forced Knight takes H3 check
at that point black is up two pawns but
more importantly White's position is
utterly in shambles go cash will
probably keep playing until move 40 out
of inertia when you've got a minute on
the clock you're usually too excited
um to just stop the clock and resign but
I think once this game reaches time
control uh kukesh is gonna have to
accept the inevitable what a tough
tournament for the Indian youngster I
mean could not be a bigger contrast from
his form in the Olympiad he's not just
struggling Point wise if you just look
at his games you'll be they're just
one-sided he's not giving himself any
chances against these guys
yes something is not quite working for
him he's not quite enjoying if I can say
in the same way that he played in the
Olympiad and uh yesterday's interview
with uh caruana he actually kind of
commented that he was surprised that
kukesh actually resigned when he did
because he was fully expecting the game
to kind of continue but it seems to
seemed like gokash had had enough you
know he's been having a terrible
tournament things haven't been working
his way and he was like enough
yeah no that's exactly what happened
there okay I think this game is
virtually decided we will leave Wesley
to finish off the technical task Eric's
position continues to go down just
computer play from up to Satora first he
plays Bishop H4 then he accentuates the
pressure in the center you could see
their Rook f8 to d8 making sure that D2
is fully secured Carlson in the meantime
Rook F3 is met with Rook G3 this is
quickly moving toward a conclusion
uh as well yovi let's let's go to the
Carlson game because I think it might
end just in the next couple of minutes
yeah I'm suspecting that Richard will
give a spike check the king will move up
the board and
12 seconds game will finish
he's got 12 seconds gonna make a move
he's got four moves to make and he's
resigned okay wow yeah
the handshake is there and uh
yeah let's see if the players discuss
they will Carlson always likes the
pointing at the board you know moving
the fingers around Furious and what a
valiant effort by report but this kind
of stuff it just does not work against
Magnus Carlson and reports struggles
against the world champion continue
yeah I think he's kind of indicating
that maybe queen of six check was
incorrect that he needed to do something
else but
they're pointing to the king in the
center
yeah I mean definitely if I had to guess
they are trying to figure out whether
report could have made that peace
sacrifice work I loved the sacrifice I
think that was the best practical chance
but just getting too excited there and
giving up the second piece really
hastened the defeat
yeah I I agree and that's good okay
sorry I'm just I'm sorry for some of
these games
me too and I'm just like but I'm kind of
confused by the kind of where they're
pointing they're kind of pointing to the
queen side when I thought that they
would be discussing the peace sacrifice
and hence moving all the
gesticulating towards the king side
yeah it seems that they're kind of
focused on maybe this night before idea
that Richard had
you just never know I mean they could be
discussing 50 things at the same time
speaking of things happening at the same
time we've got a beautiful move by
notorbeck top left of your screen Rook
D4 has moved to E4 to see blundering a
rook no The Rook on D1 is under the
X-ray of the queen on H5 I think that we
should go back to that game because it
is reaching the ultimate climax white is
down to five minutes we are going to get
a lot of moves faster and we might get a
result before move 40. so I think this
is gonna be the next game to end it's
gukesh also might resign but we will
tell you if he does I was gonna say
Wesley did spot the winning move and uh
gukash is now on the edge of defeat
things are Dreadful state for him
speaking of dreadful Rook to E4 what is
the idea of this move well The Rook is
moving into E1 not necessarily
immediately but the strain on arjun's
position has become unbearable he can't
even move his Queen because he's going
to lose both E5 and then F5 his pawns
are falling like flies I don't see a
single move for him he's tied lengthwise
and sideways and man I'm just a tour of
just tearing him limb from limb here
with his Rooks
yeah and I was wondering can uh Arjun
simply make a pass move I was thinking
what is the plan should he just
I don't know make a random
I don't know like A3 no like a no-nons
move
um I guess Queen takes pawners in the
air I was also thinking about ideas try
to get uh Bishop takes Bishop to work
but that's just too fancy for my own
good
I think you're right I think he has to
play A3 and I'm just a story of as many
ways to improve his position I like the
look of Rook d8 to D5 not fearing the
check on C8 because the King has of
course a very nice Luft Square on H7 3
minutes and 50 seconds now for Arjun man
if he pulls this game out then I mean
What miracles I will start to believe in
I will go buy a lottery ticket I'll put
it that way
I was gonna say You're Gonna Believe In
Father Christmas
and then I was like no you're not going
to go quite that far
um okay
so
I like it 45.
was he played
three minutes on the clock
there is no immediate don't move in the
position for black why there's no moves
I don't know I didn't know what to
suggest
um you can't really touch the bishop you
can't move the Rook from the third row
make a pawn move
my process of elimination now Rook D5 is
what I would call a second order threat
it you're basically threatening to
threaten but black is all the time in
the world black and if he wants he could
play King h8 to H7 first if you really
want to rub it into White's face white
Candyman move the Rook from C3 because
the pawn on F3 will hang essentially
with Checkmate can't move the queen
because the V5 can't move the other Rook
because of you can't move the bishop
because of rookie one literally look at
every piece and you understand that you
have no moves left F6 he has made a pawn
move trying desperately to muddy the
waters this ain't gonna work I think
you'll be the black could simply just
take on F6 and then double on file and
that might end it
I was gonna say the same thing that
certainly Springs to mind take the pawn
and also once uh White captures back on
F6 I just wanted to point out that the
king is rather vulnerable on F1 because
now the queen can just Dash across the
board to B5 and give a check and pawn
takes Pawn quickly played by abdusitor
of there's a beautiful line here that
actually might happen can I show it
really quickly I know that those are
coming in fast but
unless I'm missing something he takes F6
I was calculating Rook D to E8 now white
takes the pawn and I was trying to
figure out if this move leads to
chuckman and it doesn't this might
actually happen takes takes the king
seems to be able to escape to H3 but
after Queen G5 King H3 the coup de gras
is Rook to H1 a deflection black white
just has a series of spite checks but
the king hides away on H7 and even if
you don't take the Rook on H1 and queen
G3 is still a beautiful Checkmate I
think Notre back is calculating exactly
that line and he has already taken on F6
this is exciting and Arjun has not
recaptured
Wesley has won by the way
let's go oh
yeah or shall we go yeah we'll look at
that later our uh kukesh resigned after
Knight takes history Yogi as we
predicted what a win two wins in a row
now for Wesley so
yeah I know it's like the floodgates
have opened and uh it's actually
incredible that this round there's been
two results two decisive results in the
space of a few minutes and now we're
probably gonna see our third and uh it's
difficult again to come up with a move
for Eric icy Pawn takes Pawn just
opening too many lines too many
diagonals against the white king
the big biggest problem as you said is
that he takes F6 there is now going to
be Queen H5 to B5 a lateral move
essentially pushing the king away and
you're going to drop the bishop on F2 so
the simplest move for Notre back is now
just to move the Rook away from E4
because once the queen moves to B5 The
Rook will actually be hanging Rook F4
might lead to resignation and he's got
seven and a half minutes to find this
relatively straightforward move
yes but it's good good technique by
nordeback you notice how he pauses in
these critical moments and he makes some
great choices and puts the pressure on
Arjun Arjun has to come up with a move
and he has
two and ah just over two and a half
minutes left on the clock
indeed he does and there's other
exciting games but I'd like to wait for
Clarity on the board here as notrebec
once again fidgeting with a piece that
he's captured a pawn upon that he's got
he's captured a whole lot of peace and
he's about to capture many many more
six and a half minutes
okay
tension is building
very much so Rook F4 ends the game
just want to see if he plays it looking
around at some of the other boards no
not none of the other games
are all that close to being decided yet
so I think this game is definitely
the most tense closely followed by
Fabiano caruana's slugfest against
Mexico six minutes now for Notre back
the reason a miracle could happen is if
notreck allows his clock to dwindle down
to under a minute that's the kind of
uncertainty you want to avoid
I'm anticipating a move in the next
minute
yeah I agree with you something's gonna
happen now and you know if you don't see
anything directly there's nothing wrong
in being practical and just playing a
very natural move I mean white has no
threat on the board I mean white is
completely tied down
as Dania says move the Rook to F4 take
the pawn
there he goes
he's gonna move the rook and by take the
pawn I was actually advocating either
Pawn taste porn or Rook takes Pawn
and the reason I think Rick F4 is
slightly more accurate Ponte spawn white
has the move Bishop F2 to E3 and okay if
Arjun picks up the D2 Pawn he's still
completely lost but at the very least
his hands are somewhat untied and he can
at least try to shelter his King Rook F4
also prevents Bishop E3 because then
black can take on F3 with a fork he was
about to make a move
but now he continues to take his time
and he's just he knows and he's played
it he's playing it he's so good he's
Unstoppable
I mean what a talent Rook F4 and
how can Arjun respond to this move
what can he do
King E2 is the only thing I see
seems to lose on the spot
and uh Arjun just under two minutes and
15 seconds he has to find a move that
does not lose instantly and that is
going to be incredibly difficult
y too if you're suggesting kinky to
mimper really
if the position is crying out
for King E2 to be played you know that
it's going all wrong and Arden thinking
me too
Queen takes C5 and queen B5 is just mate
no that doesn't that even hastens the
defeat no he's gonna resign here I think
there's no moves left there's no moves
left and black did just take on E5 on
the next move
yeah
um I can't suggest a single move I
thought maybe he can go E6 why
why not
and uh one minute I'm just looking at
the top computer move I mean no way is
he gonna play this top computer move is
Queen H1
I I'm speechless Bishop takes A7 is his
move okay okay and here I would just
take on E5
yes
it makes a lot of sense and the players
are on move 38
. so
still two moves before move 40 and I
agree with you Dania take that pawn with
the Queen lay it simple play it safe put
it in the bank
and I mean anything wins at this point
you can play Fe you can play Queen takes
C5 and the reason Queen E5 is the faster
win is because it threatens Queenie one
check which is ultimately the entire
reason that white got into this trouble
in the first place it was because he let
the d-pawn stay alive in advance D2
Notre back is literally playing one top
engine move after another after another
how do you stop a man like that who's on
a mission like this who's defeated
Magnus Carlson who defeats Arjun
aragaisy dealing him his first blow of
the tournament with the black pieces out
of an opening that Arjun seemed to be
very well prepared in
yeah I I mean I have no words
he's just incredible and he just seems
to be having the tournament of his life
and once again naughty back making it
look easy his play has been effortless
throughout the tournament I don't think
he's been in trouble one time okay the
bishop comes down to E3
okay first move that I'm thinking of
give the king a check see the way that
he plays it that's it instantly
King goes to G1 where else are you gonna
go
Rock g a check and queen B5 to E2 is the
cherry on top of the king is going to
get squashed over there in the corner
and Notre back again is going to take a
look a couple seconds to double check
this Yogi but this is what a sparkling
finale to a sparkling game
yeah
I agree with you he's uh leaned back in
his chat he knows
he has this in the bag he's just working
out those final calculations he's
calming himself
that the queen is definitely gonna zoom
into E2 there's no stopping her and with
that I agree with you Dania it's going
to be instant resignation
there he goes nope we need to first as
if it matters he's gonna play that first
and our generic icy is going to stop the
clocks in this position
or he's gonna play Queen F1 and after
Rook G8 the Queens are gonna get traded
and then he's gonna take on F3
the final deflection
mm-hmm
and Eric I see just under one and a half
minutes his position is just hopeless
yeah as if that held that's it makes it
worse right the fact that you have 50
minutes to Stew on how lost your
position is makes it even more likely
that he's going to resign
yeah and uh Arjun looking at his first
defeat of the tournament and he does
drop his Queen back to F1
playing the move relatively quickly
yeah Rook G8 is going to follow
notorbeck will need about 20 seconds of
his additional 50 minutes to discover
that move
and then Queen takes F1 check and
anything wins in that resulting position
and you can actually set up a nice
Checkmate right
yeah I mean I could show this on the
analysis board nutterberg is going to
take his time
but after Rook G8 King H1 when F1 Rook
apparently the best move here it's
actually Bishop h40 E1 but sufficient is
Rook takes F3 this is what's going to
happen I I don't really know why Arjun
is making him prove this uh and that's
it either you allow promotion with mate
or you have to give up The Rook with
check and black hasn't had enough he
also comes back around and wins the
bishop as well Rook G8 is on the board
we
are going to get resignation here King
H1 he continues to play but Rook takes
F3 is going to silence the crowd
and uh
just waiting for those closing moments
[Laughter]
there's no way
yeah I was going to say there's no way
that norterbeck can go wrong here I mean
this one is just beautiful I mean I was
just looking at any fancy kind of ways
that
are guys who can go wrong and he just
can't there's just no need for any
Dramatics
says take the queen
this is so miserable for Arch and I I
would resign here on my opponent's turn
just because there's just no question
he's going to take the queen and he's
basking in the moment let's come back to
our bird side we're gonna stay on this
camera review because
I I really don't uh anticipate this game
lasting more than another 10 seconds
there he goes Queen takes F1 but we want
to keep you abreast of the other games
we have some updates in those games and
there we go he's oh oh he still hasn't
stopped the clock
Rook takes F3 Notre back let's go
and I reckon he might play Bishop D1
.
you feel the hammer coming down slowly
it's coming down and coming down and
it's just like waiting for the moment
when it's going to come down
yeah
Ruth takes F3 is what I would play but
uh yeah I know Rick takes the three on
the board
and that's it now is the moment the hand
is out and naughty Beck wins again
oh my goodness literally OMG the man is
five and a half points out of seven he
wins another game he's now won two games
with the black pieces that in and of
itself is already an incredibly rare
achievement at a tournament of this
caliber as we see the players there
amicably discussing the game but Notre
back has to be elated
showing zero signs of fatigue if
anything his play is actually like
getting better as the tournament is
progressing
absolutely I mean he started the second
half just in a complete role you know
first he steamrolled at Magnus Carlson
and then draw yesterday okay and today
back to business and he with the black
pieces he just seems completely
Unstoppable
and Arjun and Nordic making
some moves pointing to some squares
where they could have played and I like
this it's like the players are just on
the same way from length just moving
their fingers pointing maybe you could
have done this
exactly okay still twiddling
I think the words but okay are probably
uh used pretty liberally and he's right
these uh post-game conversations but a
huge congratulations to Notre back with
Anish giri drawing Fabiano caruana as
we're about to find out
probably not going to win his game
Notre back is going to extend his lead
to a full point that is huge and if you
can continue with even 80 percent of the
intensity and spirit with which he's
played he has every chance to score
perhaps the greatest tournament victory
of his career although let's not forget
he did win the world rapid so it's just
amazing stuff by Notre back what a time
to be alive okay so as we look at the
bird's eye view we've got three games
ongoing you called it it's a bloody day
we've only had one draw thus far and it
seems like at least two of the games
that are remaining are also likely to
end decisively I think Fabiano caruana's
game yovi is the one game that's
likeliest to end in a draw I think it's
the likeliest game to end uh first out
of the last three shall we take a deeper
dive into fabi's position
yeah absolutely we haven't visited that
one in a while so
it seems to have gone a metamorphosis
yeah geez per currently Parham is up a
pawn a lot of liquidation happened on
the queen side Black's compensation is
really visible to the naked eye
obviously you've got the Rook on B2
you've got the weak Pawn in the center
and I think if Fabi wants a draw if he
wants to force matters the easiest way
to do it here and this might actually be
the most prudent approach because
keeping the Queens on the board with
this past Pawn angling for B6 can be
dangerous
Fabi should take on D4
and then simply centralize the 995 and
yes White's Pawn on B5 is very well
protected and I cannot see Parham having
any winning chances given the disparity
in peace activity for instance you can
go Knight F3 and I wouldn't even trade
the knights I would just go
just maybe go Knight D7 although the
evil bar starts to creep up and maybe it
has to do with White's ability to
dislodge blackstroke from B2 what do you
think of you should Fabi go for the
trade no he's declined it
and he's declined it oh okay because I
was kind of
Queen V3 it kind of makes sense to kind
of keep the Queens on the board
especially because out of the two kings
it is White's King that is
a little bit more shaky
there's just so much to keep track of
for both colors both Rooks are being
made contact with by the opposing Queen
and if again now if Parham wants to
force a draw he can drop his Queen back
to D3 at that point I think Fabi will
accept the trade because in the
resulting position Bishop D7 picks up
the pawn on B5 and once the pawn is
liquidated you basically have a dead
drop do you see a way for Parham to keep
some winning chances alive maybe Rook A1
maybe try to get active but that could
also backfire after Knight to F4
yeah I kind of feel that he needs to
start mobilizing his pieces and start
the big unraveling and I I do like Rook
A1 other moves that kind of came to mind
when I
F3 but then this allows Knight F4
um
Queen D6
but this allows Queen E3 oh hmm
you know I think Parham should just call
it a day with Queen D3 if you start
playing with fire when your pieces are
this passive you know all you're going
to get is is a potential loss the EVAP
bar is showing an edge for him
but before we go on break I just want to
show this line there's a crazy computer
idea which starts with what looks like a
blunder E5 walking right into the
deflection Knight takes E5 and now not
Queen takes E5
which leads to a liquidation and a
Surefire draw in fact black is the one
pushing with the more active Queen but
the incredibly calm move Rook D1 to A1
reinforcing renewing the threat of Queen
takes E5 and the point of E5 is to open
up a direct line of fire to The Black
Gang all of a sudden that King starting
to feel a little bit uncomfortable yovi
but I'm going to make a bold prediction
and say that I don't know if there's a
way for a human to find this idea
we will see right because uh param is in
the tank he is thinking hard and he is a
tactical player he's very aggressive
if anyone can find it he might be one of
those
that's why players like Parham get
invites to these tournaments I largely
think there's a sort of philosophical
question here Parham has already come to
terms with the fact that he wants to
hold the draw we might see Queen D3 fast
if he's still holding out some Ambitions
he might even take 30 minutes in a
position like this you have the luxury
of doing that because all three
remaining games ladies and gentlemen
have made move 40 that means 50 minutes
have been added to each of their clocks
things have slowed down we can take a
deep breath we've got three decisive
games already it's been an incredible
round seven here at the 2023 Tata steel
chess tournament and as we have a
beautiful view there our high Max Zulu
and Fabiano caruana deep in the tank we
are going to go on our post time control
break do not go anywhere because there
will be more Breakneck action from the
three remaining games that the title
steel tournament when we come back very
soon
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish giri and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you
maybe tactics are your weakness a
woodpecker method has helped students
gain hundreds of Elo points most
importantly all of our courses are
powered by chessable's exclusive move
trainer technology which uses the
science of space repetition to make sure
it all sticks
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun happy seems
more fresh and I know he loves Tata
steel and you could just see the
inspiration in fabby's play
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is playing for a win and he
has to start winning fast if he wants to
re-emerge with the top half of the Cross
table the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish is
taking down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps outer back
just playing a modern brilliancy what a
performance
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
forty thousand of you watching across
the platforms this fascinating seventh
round of the Tata steel chess tournament
in the beautiful picturesque town of
vike on Z it is the 85th year with this
prestigious tournament is held and the
playing Hall is still packed to the brim
both with players in the open section
and of course the spectators crowding
around the screens and the players this
is an amazing atmosphere in the games
from this round have been bloody amazing
bloody and amazing as we've already had
three decisive games you'll be draws are
not to be found today
no it certainly has not been that way I
mean we've seen deadly attacks we've
seen the world champion repel a
ferocious Onslaught by Richard Rapport I
mean it's been so many fireworks on the
board it's been incredible to see and
you know what I'm kind of hoping that
the remaining three games have also
produced that little bit of spark too
they are very likely to do just that but
you're absolutely right the story well
the two stories of the round thus far
Notre producer tour of wins another game
with the black pieces he is Unstoppable
he is bloody amazing and of course
Magnus Carlson with a huge win with the
white pieces basically saying listen I'm
in the bottom half of the tournament
cross table first of all that's not
going to last long second of all there's
a lot of Chess still left to be played
Magnus wins all six remaining games he
is going to win this tournament and the
world champion
for anybody else I would say that that
is a total impossibility for Magnus
Carlson we have learned through the
years of his chess career that nothing
is impossible but we have three games
left we are gonna delve into them very
shortly but we wanted to address a point
that occurred earlier today and we now
have some clarity earlier today we were
confused when our first game of the day
when Lavon and Anish Gary were able to
make a drop before move 30 by agreement
it was not a repetition they seemed to
agree a draw and we were wondering if
the rules didn't expressly forbid that
apparently we were not the only ones who
were confused after a short draw in
round four Vapiano caruana revealed that
the players are in fact just as confused
let's listen in
no you know I thought before the
tournament that it was like 30
um that it was uh that you should make a
draw after move 30 if you're going to
make a draw but then in the first round
like I was talking to Anish and Anish
was like no no you can always make a
draw here
and I thought okay Anish was no he's
been here like uh nearly 20. yeah he's a
tournament investor he has to know so
when Richard offered I was like
a bit unsure and I was like yeah let's
ask the Arbiter
and then the Arbiter said uh no you you
probably should play on a few more moves
I don't know if it's a recommendation or
something like normally I in most
tournaments it's just a given that you
don't draw until there's no more pieces
left where there's a repetition uh so
the rules here are a bit more
um let's say traditional like we don't
have for the Sofia rules or whatever you
want to call them
revealing that he too was unsure of what
exactly the draw rules are now from the
tournament handbook I can read the
actual statement which reads we kindly
ask all players to show their best
fighting Spirit the sponsor and
organizing committee respected a lot
when draws within 30 moves or within
three hours of play will not be seen
during the event the players who do not
respect this ethical rule May risk not
being invited for future Tata steel
tournaments that is an ominous ominous
ending uh eovi so it's not expressly
forbidden to offer drugs you can offer a
draw and move too but if you know what's
good for you that's basically what the
organizers are saying you're going to
refrain from such Behavior your thoughts
yeah there's a Unwritten code of conduct
here
um I think that organizers are
well-wined within their rights to kind
of stamp down this kind of code because
let's face it these are the world's best
players
they are here they've been paid a lot of
money to put on a show to entertain us
with their chess I think it really gives
a bad name to chess when the elite
players are kind of like green drawers
in 13 13 moves because that's not
entertaining no one cares about that
kind of Chess instead we care about you
know these fights to The Bitter End and
I do feel that even when you do have a
very clear-cut position where it is a
draw you should play it out you should
show everyone how it's done and also it
also kind of eliminates the opportunity
of making mistakes I mean it just it's a
bit ridiculous if you think about it in
chess that suddenly the players can go
would you like a draw you know
just kill the game as it stands and just
forget about and everything ah no other
sport
does that so I am kind of in agreement
with the organizers I think high level
chess is a little bit different they
have to kind of play to a different tune
than other players because
and the reason I say this is because I
don't want to be dismissive or short
drawers I've been guilty of taking a
short draw and I know yeah we can weaker
players you know rely on the fact that
this is chess is their living they have
to make it they have to earn something
and sometimes taking that quick draw
will mean that they get a prize but
it's the lead players the lead players
should be setting a moral example and if
the organizers want Fighting Chess give
them Fighting Chess
yeah I think those are great points and
I have also been guilty many times even
in the last tournament that I played
last weekend of uh taking a couple short
draws but in my defense I was not
playing Tata steel and shot of Steel has
a reputation to uphold right the reason
people keep coming back for 85 years now
is because you know for a fact that when
you watched how to steal you get a
certain brand of Chess you've got a
certain type of player who plays in the
tournament a very eclectic assortment
with the top players The Talented
Juniors everybody all in one room and
you get Fighting Chess entertaining
chess all the way through to the end of
this Marathon tournament so I like also
the fact that it's not a hard and fast
rule so you give the players the ability
uh to kind of do what they want but
within reasonable limits and I also like
that the organizers allowed Anish giri
and levona Ronin to agree a draw in this
game because although I agree in
principle that you should play out even
positions there are some exceptions to
the rule in today's position was so dry
so equal that I don't think think any
chess fans really mind the fact that
they agree to draw in that position but
we hope that that remains the exception
rather than the rule and in generally OV
I remember when the Sophia rules were
revolutionary it was like well our
player is going to stand behind this is
this gonna is this just a quixotic you
know uh outlandish rule change and it's
been amazing to see that almost all top
tournaments have in one form or another
adopted no draw rules it's good to see
the Chess World adapting to what the
fans want and uh not necessarily always
what the players want I don't think the
players truly protest
yeah you know I I kind of think the
Sofia rules have really translated very
well in the high level chess and these
Elite tournaments where you're seeing
Superstars you know people are relying
on publicity and New Sensations to make
this event work to make it as attractive
as possible and and you let's not forget
that this is also a festival that these
players are playing alongside amateur
players there's also alongside the
challenges and so you you know as an
amateur you do want to be playing
alongside the world's best that gives
you a very special feeling and just
imagine you sit down play your play your
game for five hours and within two hours
everyone from the top section has uh
Gone they've agreed draws and they've
just finished I mean it doesn't leave a
good impression so I I do think for
elite tournaments
no actually I would say no draw offers
that's the end yeah
I'll just finish by by echoing that
point
um I guess saying echoing anything is is
a dangerous thing to do given that I've
had a little bit of an echo uh at
various points today but uh just the
idea that you can sort of artificially
end the game whenever you want I agree
that philosophically there's just
something very weird about it but I will
say that the inherent concept of a draw
is not a bad thing the idea that neither
side wins the game is not itself a
deterrent or a reason uh or or a
downside at all and I think the people
who say we should eliminate draws all
together that every single game should
be decisive are missing the point
completely the draws can be some of the
most interesting games that we have seen
we saw even in this tournament when a
game is played well by both players the
rightful result is often a draw it's
just the idea of the artificial draw the
draw that is agreed and produced
artificially by the players rather than
the draw that stems naturally from the
course of the game that's the kind of
draw that we should be targeting in
avoiding and the organizers have done a
fantastic job of that let's switch back
to what I would argue is our most
exciting of the three remaining
gamesulu has found the movie five he has
me to thank because I said he couldn't
do it yeah you face commentator you've
put it in the atmosphere and he had he
heard the Universe telling him just
sacrifice back the pawn open up the
potential of the bishop actually I was
listening to a very interesting uh Point
by uh incidentally Fabiana caruana and
his second Christian and they were
talking about how in Blitz and Rapid
chess it's so common just to give up
material in order to get some peace
activity and uh I mean the case in point
for them was actually Magnus Carlson's
A5 move when he faced off against Anish
giri and that was very interesting that
it's a reflection of Chess speeding up
that has enabled players to find these
kind of very dramatic moves they don't
care so much about material it's just
about initiating chaos
and I love what param's done as you've
indicated that was such a cool line
what makes it particularly impressive is
that he is risking you know he's giving
up his material advantage he could have
scored a nice warm drawn you know
basically gone to eat dinner with Queen
D3 would have been a good result but he
finds the energy to keep the game going
so before we update you on our two
remaining games I'd like to predict or
try to predict how this game is likely
to go now as we were discussing earlier
if we bring up an analysis report Knight
65 is clearly the principled move and
here as we pointed out the dangerous
response is Rook to A1 now the night
hangs what happens if the Knight moves
back to G6 the problem is that after
Bishop D3 yovi suddenly black is
extremely tied down the heavy pieces are
just kind of sitting there doing nothing
and white is already threatening to run
the h-bun up the board and if black
continues to weaken himself before you
know it that's it you're already
checkmated that's how quickly Black's
King could go from impervious to
checkmated no that wasn't incredible
line actually
just like that that was a bit too quick
yeah zero to a hundred
it was uh but uh it can mean it just
goes to show the danger in the position
and uh I mean it's actually not such a
ridiculous line because when you if you
go where to go back to the position with
the Knight on G6 and the bishop on D3
you can kind of see a scenario where if
you make a non just a nothing kind of
move I don't really know what but I'm
just thinking that Bishop takes Knight
is actually in the air
ship takes night well first of all if
you try to pick the bishop then
definitely Bishop takes Knight yeah I
can't find I can't find an empty move
that's why isn't zooksvong like almost
okay it may be like okay just to
highlight my point Bishop C8 No One's
Gonna Play Bishop C8 oh Bishop yeah okay
then then you can kind of go yeah Bishop
C8 and then Bishop takes Knight and you
obviously don't want to take with the
King but if you take with the pawn then
you have Rook eight a seven and same
idea back
that's a great observation especially
because the queen makes contact with the
Rook so Queen G8 is out of the question
I didn't even yeah in kg6 there's Knight
C3 Knight F4 with uh big big problems
for black you're absolutely right Bishop
takes G6 is a threat
maybe black should try to go Queen to B4
but the sad thing for foxy is that first
of all even the queen trade gives white
some chances would that pass her on B5
in fact takes takes
maybe swing the Knight around uh to C2
and try to get it to D4 maybe go Rook B1
trade Rooks and Bank your winning
chances on this far Advanced passer on
B5 this is no fun for Mr caruana and
he's already down to 30 minutes before
you know it in the blink of an eye he
could drop down to the second round of
time pressure
it is uh definitely a very Troublesome
move to be facing e for E5 I love it and
the line that you showed just then you
know just with the minor pieces on the
board it just looked devastating for
black maybe there was some kind of very
far-fetched defense there but
why it's playing very very natural and
Fabi in serious danger and something I
kind of wanted to stress was that param
has kind of said repeatedly he loves
chess so much he's not interested in the
result he wants a fight
and uh a fight is what he's getting
it's such a
old school romantic approach to the game
you know that's how Wilhelm Steiner
should play in players in the 19th
century and they would lose the game and
they would be so happy that they
participated in a work of art it was
less about who was the Victor and who
was the vanquished it was more that it
was a collab collaborative effort and
the loser plays just as integral of a
role in its creation as the winner of
course players nowadays are much more
invested in the results and let's be
clear Parham likes to win games but I
love love that old school approach and
we get Fighting Chess every single
tournament from the Iranian wizard
will have to play very accurately if he
wants to wheel his way out of this
incredibly dangerous situation let's go
back to the bird's eye view we have two
other games both of them with Queens off
the board
and not much has changed in the prod
game in like the last two hours it's
like you know the same position for like
forever
it's like Ferris Bueller's Day Off right
same position keeps happening again and
again
um yeah wait wait wait
is it Ferris Bueller staff or Groundhog
Day groundhog no I think they both do
I don't know Ferris Bueller's Day Off
I'm trying to because it's one of my
favorite movies I'm trying to remember
oh no okay then I was just kidding it
was Groundhog Day let's uh bang for the
safe one
I haven't actually seen another one yeah
Groundhog Day is the is the one that if
you want to stress anything that repeats
itself you go Groundhog Day Groundhog
Day yes Johnny Phil
yeah
um Groundhog Day I'm not very good with
films actually I don't watch too many
um
okay okay okay okay
yeah so that I mean that one looks it's
just a question of whether fortresses
exist isn't it when it comes to practice
game against Jordan
you know Jordan is just
doing the Gandalf approach you know I I
love that scene from uh Lord of the
Rings where Gandalf is fighting the bell
rock and he says thou shall not pass
that's exactly what Jordan is doing
living on the back row trying to
establish the blockade against uh
pregnant as pieces
and uh no yeah
I I actually think that uh there's too
many avenues for pregnant to attack
I mean just look at uh Jordan's P
they're just like oh congregating there
on the queen side
and the King side is also entirely up
for grabs as well so nope don't like
that game and uh
okay well we see actually in the Fabiano
position that Knight takes Pawn has been
played so now we're gonna see where the
Parham is actually going to find the
critical Rook A1 to put Fabi under a lot
of pressure
Rook A1 is not a certainty but I cannot
imagine where I'm getting this far
swimming 99 of the way to Shore and then
turning back and going to the island
that would be Queen takes C5 so we will
keep a close eye on that game between
the two others that we have left I agree
the prod game is largely going to be
decided by the question of whether a
inroads can be made probably on the king
side and I think the answer might be yes
if you move susbishop away and then
swings his Rook over to G1 to your
question about whether fortresses exist
till Magnus Carlson might still be in
the playing Hall and we know what he
thinks about that question Jordan is in
for a long miserable defensive grind I'd
like to go a little bit deeper into our
other game between Vincent kaima and
ding Lee Ren Vincent has been squeezing
an end game Advantage for a very long
time the positions continue to transform
and unfortunately for Vincent it feels
like it's continued to transform largely
in ding's favor although he's still up a
pawn is Vincent kymer his Rook is on an
Ideal defensive Square it's less active
than black stroke but it's of course
controlling the second Rank and I think
he's just made a lovely move King G2 to
H3 you're taught to go to the center in
the end game these players they violate
rules more often than they follow him
and Vincent taking the side route trying
to get to H4 and ultimately infiltrate
G5 still yobi I think one thing is very
clear dingler n is far from being out of
the woods uh he's in danger right
um he has to Simply blockade the white
king and he just has to find again we're
going to talk about forces a way to hold
the pawn structure intact and to also
restrain the white rook and the one
thing that I would always suggest when
you're playing a rook ending and you're
on the defending side is that you must
keep your work active there don't go
passive with your work
if you have to make a choice between
active King and active Rook
most nine times out of ten please choose
to go active with your Rook
active with the rock active with the
King often more important than material
the most important point I agree with
you completely now in the name of Peace
activity Black's most natural move is to
play King F5 we could pull up an
analysis board if you don't do that then
you run the risk of getting your thing
pushed away with King H4 to G5 and then
F5 check I think Vincent has cooked up a
genius attacking idea after King F5 he
might be preparing to play the move b2b4
what is the point of B4 well you are
doing what's called a deep freeze you're
using one Pawn to restrict two or more
of your opponent's pawns and on the next
move you're threatening to swing The
Rook over to C2 and force blackstroke
into permanent passivity now you might
say well doesn't this help black create
a past one well the problem here is that
after BC BC even a simple approach like
Rook C2 is pretty likely to bear fruit
you also should consider to get behind
the pass Pawn with a rook to A2 ding has
to calculate all of this
perhaps Rook A2 is a little bit too
passive due to King E4 but yoey I think
something like this is what he's
planning and I'll finish by saying that
the purpose of dragging Black's King out
to F5 is that later down the line if
white can get a rook to the seventh rank
that will come with far greater effect
because the king will no longer be able
to support the spawn black will have to
move the king back and White's King will
immediately pounce on the opportunity so
he's setting himself up for what may
seem like a distant future but we know
how quickly things can change in these
Rook end games yeah I agree with you 100
I actually think that moving the king up
is probably very risky on account of
your last points if a white Rook does
find itself on the seventh row I mean
it's going to be dilemma all round and
yeah it's
it's a tough end game for doing to hold
I mean if you've even if you were to
kind of play in the most direct style
which is simply to
put the Rook on C2 attacking the pawn
and even if you were to kind of see like
movies like C5 and then white would
destabilize this Pawn by playing B4
it's not an easy position to handle I'm
just thinking after Pawn takes pawn pawn
takes porn
and here things could quickly go wrong
for instance after Rook to D4 you've got
your idea of plant planting a rug on C7
and how do you how do you defend those
pawns on F7 and G7 without
you know losing everything or losing the
B6 Pawn
you can't hear you're lost because if
you drop back as you're saying you'll
lose the B Pawn if you lose the F Pawn
then white is a four on two and four on
two basically means two past spawns and
even if black gets one pass Pawn on the
other side it can be easily restrained
uh by putting the Rook on B7 I think
that's a wonderful idea to start with
Rook C2 and then invert the move order
with before I would just urge uh the the
viewers to not put too much stock into
the eval bar because actually playing
these Rook end games like a computer
unless your Magnus Carlsen is virtually
impossible so it's really all about
creating practical problems and causing
your opponent's clock to dwindle down
ding rirun's clock is down to 38 minutes
I have seen this happen so often where
you make move 40 you take a deep breath
that's it I'm out of I'm out of the
woods and then by move 43 you're in time
pressure again
story of my life that's why I don't like
these classical time controls and uh
well I do like them I mean I find them
very exciting I actually quite enjoy
them but
so many times you know move 41 I kind of
settle into the tank and then I forget
and then I'm in time travel for the rest
of the game and wow
yeah
interesting fascinating end game on our
hands from Vincent kaimer and ding Loren
and it's actually really nice to see
that uh it's Vincent who was going to be
putting the pressure on ding because in
the previous two games we've seen it be
Vincent who's had to survive these end
games are born down tried to establish a
fortress and things have just not gone
his way in those final moments
you're absolutely right and uh the
problem when you have a couple of games
like that is that your confidence
starts to get hurt you know you you get
into kind of here we go again mode where
okay Vincent has been on the defending
side but he might be thinking right now
well I've screwed up a couple of these
critical moments am I going to make
another mistake that might cause them to
take a little bit longer than usual so
the effects of that can be subtle but
they can be very pernicious and
I'm pretty cautiously optimistic I think
Vincent's got a serious shot here ding
has already lost one game to a
bloodthirsty youngster is he going to
lose shockingly enough a second one
yeah
and uh is it possible to go back to the
bird's eye view because I see things shy
shaping up in a Parham against Fabiano
very interesting let's absolutely go to
the bird's eye view we have three games
left if you're just joining us this is
round seven of the Tata steel chess
tournament three out of four finished
games have been decisive most
impressively notorbeck's win with the
black pieces what is happening oh maxulu
did not find Rook A1 uh oh and again I
jinxed him
and again I jinxed him
honey the more I look at this this is
understandable actually because you know
if the Queens get traded off then this
bishop ending is just completely winning
and
you know that's something that will
provide
um with a lot of inspiration but he it
feels like he's better despite what the
evaluation bar is saying this is a slap
back in the middle sat there I just love
how the evaluation bar is always like no
0.0 it's a draw meanwhile if you were
playing this on a board in real life as
black you'd be absolutely petrified you
would be calculating recalculating
thinking that you were living on the
edge and uh param deep in thought
he's got some attempting Canada moves
here you pointed out moment the Queens
are off the board at the pawn promote so
Queen E2 is to me the most logical move
the problem is that black is never in a
million years going to yield to White's
desires black is going to drop the queen
back to B4 this seems like a fork but
it's easily parried with Bishop E4 so
unfortunately white essentially has to
tread water with a move like Queen E3
and black doesn't have to do anything
just go whatever G6 H5 and shuffle your
king between G7 and H7
white doesn't even hypothetically have
any way to make progress and the reason
why is just because there's no safe spot
to put this King let's say black goes G6
all it takes is a sloppy move like
Bishop B2 and uh well let's just say
this is not going to lead to a desirable
result for white I don't see a way
around the COV if you could somehow get
your Bishop to F3 maybe you've got some
even then black just takes on F3 and
White's Queen can never really leave
it's rather passive post so I think
Fabby is just a couple of moves away
from holding the game here finally B7
looks very tempting but after Queen E3
check King H1 Queen back to E1
white obviously cannot promote and if
white leaves the pawn then black takes
it
arhan would have to repeat moves with
King Juan and I think this is probably
how the game is likely to end
yeah uh it's a little bit unfortunate
right because I can I can see a
construction which would give White
a safe home for the king so the
construction that I would be looking at
says just setting up is first of all I
would uh give my king an opening on the
dark squares I'll be playing H3 I know I
can appreciate it's very slow and that
there are two players playing the game
one attacking one defending but somehow
if I can manage to get the queen to C7
mm-hmm give my king that hiding hole on
H2 and then the bishop could kind of
snake its way around and try to
challenge its counterpart
even in some scenarios give it up put it
on C4 or something and just say hey
where are you going
let me get b7in
yeah it's like part of these types of
ideas where you you close off the only
diagonal through which black and axis
White's King there's checks on E5 and F4
and G3 and if you put your queen on the
ideal Square then the king is going to
be temporarily safe my worry though is
even if you accomplish all of that uh
you're gonna have to move the bishop
eventually and I can Target the G2 Pawn
as a result so Fabi if you had five
minutes in this position in a Blitz game
I'd say that there are very serious
practical chances to induce a blunder
but given that he's got 25 minutes and
then another 15 minutes coming uh in in
17 moves
I think Sudley didn't quite manage Rook
A1 still so admirably took his time he
found E5 and he came oh so close to
producing serious winning chances
yeah
definitely uh and also we have to kind
of talk about how param was invited to
the tournament because when the original
participants were announced it was Yan
chistophthuda who was meant to be
playing the tournament and magsudlu has
actually stepped in at the very last
minute to play in such an elite
tournament so whilst the others all have
had months and months to prepare he's
kind of just been thrown in at the deep
end and a lot of these players he's
playing for the first time in a
classical game so I I like that it adds
a kind of freshness to the mix and we've
seen that he's played great chess so far
yeah that's my favorite thing about
these tournaments is that yeah you can
pay attention to who's winning the
tournament but the point of watching
tournaments like these isn't just oh
you're gonna look at the cross stable
after the game it's also just to
appreciate the process and it's to
appreciate the players who might not
have the biggest chance to win the
tournament or finish in the top three
but just hearing the name Tada Steele
this is what it connotes you know game
after game with entertaining action
where even the draws are almost just as
interesting as the decisive game okay
shall we take a look once again at the
bird's eye view I would guess that this
game is likeliest to finish first out of
um out of the three remaining
prague's position still hasn't changed
Yogi it's like moving so slowly
it will liven up uh towards the end I
predict there's going to be lots of uh
kind of very slow moves uh White's just
making slow gains in the position and
then suddenly
like walk just crack and that's the end
of that game
I mean I I just feel that White's
position is just so overwhelming you
know he has complete domination over the
queen side and then the king side as
well I mean black can't hold everything
I don't see it happening for Jordan
event for us and the the crushing thing
about these types of uh defensive tasks
is that there's it's not like there's a
limit to how many moves white can play
White can try a little bit on the queen
side and then a little bit on the king
side and Rook to G1 and Knight to B4 and
eventually something is going to crack I
just and let's not forget we're five
hours into the round and the worst is
still ahead of him
yeah the critical moment is Yet to Come
and the worst thing is is that you can
see it coming
because the science the porn structure
is so clear I mean and Black's plan
sorry White's plan is just so obvious I
mean and all you can do is just wait for
the inevitable
yeah there's just not much that black
can do when you can't defend actively
when you don't have a single chance to
win the game psychologically that
produces such a strong effect on you now
I've pulled up the game it's very hard
to analyze these positions concretely
because the value of each particular
move is greatly diminished it's all
about the general direction in which the
game goes so let's see if we can
approximately predict what White's best
winning chance is here let's start with
a neutral move let's say black plays
Bishop back to d8 trying to Target
White's only weakness how would you
respond to that do you think Bishop E1
is the most expeditious way to play
um actually capturing on H4 isn't a
threat for the time being because you
can just move the Rook over to H1 so it
does give white some time to do a move
and the first thing I would be looking
at is does black have any significant
entry points on the B line I mean does
the white Rook have to be on A1 if it
doesn't have to be on A1 I'm just gonna
move my Rook to G1 and get going
very much so
um the reason it would stay on A1 I
would imagine is to support Knight CB4
so let's try the concrete move Knight C
to B4
okay now if you move your maybe you have
to move your knight to be it because if
you take it and I take back
right you go King D7 let let me push
that pawn up to A6 and I feel like we're
eventually going to get a situation like
this the question is can white use
pressure on the other side of the board
to overextend Black's defensive forces
or did I do something that you wouldn't
advise
with your six
um it wasn't A6 actually because I I
kind of want to keep as many pieces on
the board it was the night trade that I
wasn't so sure about because like one of
my big things in chess is that every
move has a consequence and the bishop
going back to E8 does have the
consequence that the white Knights can
now jump into E5 which I didn't spot
until now
and so you would consider that move
immediately yeah that's the first move I
would consider after once I kind of
shook off this Obsession that I had with
the rook and
okay so the King has to step forward but
now now it does feel that black is kind
of creaking a little bit because the
Rook can swing over to
to G1 and then can go to G6
and starts out I guess I'll meet that
I'll meet that with Bishop F6 can I also
can I float a different idea what about
the move for Rook to A4 trying to I know
I'm obsessed with this Knight before
idea but I think in this version it
might be better because night before
I'll take it and go A6 Bishop A5 and
I'll try to toss your king away from its
defense of the C6 Pawn
yeah looks good
let's go for it so that I mean
thing is though there's not that much
black can do so they take that pawn or
H4 and then once you go Knight to
I think you just have to
absolutely oh God no no
okay well Bishop d8 on the board okay
yes we are really on fire today
we've been on a roll in all of the games
now predicting moves in a position like
this is incredibly hard so let's see how
far down the line we can go you kind of
opened my eyes to the fact that white
does not have to go Bishop P1 now he
might choose to do it just out of an
abundance of caution because in some
lines later down the line you have to
reckon with Bishop takes H4 as we just
saw but night before is the first movie
considered uh 95 is
the other move going in the other
direction and trying back down to the C6
Pawn by the way 20 minutes for
prognananta he has to put a move on
because you never know when positions
like this can get sharp and you want to
leave yourself with at least five
minutes to handle the ensuing
complications
I I agree do you have to be practical
and uh the complications are going to
occur there's no doubt about it
oh I mean no one envies Jordan actually
you know his he's been grimy defending
this position upon down since almost the
beginning and now he has a position
where it's just a question of whether he
can hold and it's difficult to keep your
motivation up when you've been
struggling throughout the whole game and
uh there we see Jordan has left the
board and Prague is deep in thought
he knows
he knows that you know this is his
moment this is a great opportunity for
him and
one of the things about Prague is that
he's so fantastic at attacking he's
fantastic at calculating he's a good
all-rounder and he's just 17 years old
it's unbelievable it's quite scary isn't
it 17 years old I remember all those
years ago when uh Bobby Fischer became
the youngest grandmas in the world and
he was 16 and Judith Pogo went on a race
to beat this and she did and again we
were talking of Ages 16 and now everyone
is becoming Grandmaster at 12 years old
it's Pro
it's just scary but good at the same
time
it just gets crazier and crazier I mean
you think one player becomes a GM of 12
it's never going to happen again now GM
at 14 at 15 is you know you barely bat
an eye which is just absolutely nuts and
Prague of course has worked extensively
with RB Ramesh perhaps the most famous
uh Indian coach one of the most famous
coaches by now of all time and you know
Ramesh has written a lot about what they
do and Prague is just I mean he's a
calculating machine and that doesn't
happen overnight that's not only the
product of immense Talent which of
course he has in abundance is also the
product of just diligent work over the
course of many many years of you know
sweaty calculating sessions but in this
position it's not really about
calculation it is about understanding
about pursuing the right conceptual plan
and with 18 minutes on the clock Prague
still has a lot of work to do and uh
we're gonna swing back to the bird's eye
view here for just a hot second and
we're gonna go on another break because
the games are about to enter their one
two three sixth hour games are about to
enter their sixth hour how tired must
the players be you can see there the
playing Hall starting to empty out as
most of the games in the open section
have finished but that area near the
players that is not emptying out at all
if anything it's becoming even more
packed ladies and gentlemen you're
watching round seven of the Tata steel
chess tournament 2023 we will be back
with the sixth hour of these fascinating
games on the other side of this short
break
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to Tata steel round seven
what Breakneck action today as the games
have officially entered their sixth hour
it is 7 P.M Dutch time on the nose but
the players they're not thinking about
dinner as some of them are enjoying some
great pizza others are still sitting
hunched over the board there is dingley
Wren he is struggling to hold a very
difficult Rook end game against the
young German Phenom the Protege of Peter
leco Grand Master Vincent kymer Ivanka
Huska and Daniel laradici bringing you
coverage of this Marathon round seven as
the tournament has reached its halfway
point Vincent kymer there is deep in
thought and Ivanka every single game in
this round perhaps say veronian Geary
has been fascinating
as we look at the results
yeah and there we can see it has been a
bloody round so far we have had three
decisive results so Wesley so taking
down gukash with the black pieces and
Magnus Carlson regaining his footing by
defeating Richard Rapport and one other
very important victory for tournament
leader nordeback Abdus
taking down Arjun eragaisi
it almost feels to me that that game
occurred in like a different Universe
you know these three end games are
completely in a category of their own do
we remember that Magnus Carlsen defeated
Richard report another crazy game with
reports sacrificing two pieces but Agnes
Carlson was just a brick wall today
laying down the wood on a struggling
Richard report
okay well we've got three games left we
have prognananda coming very close to a
win and that would really shake up the
standings if Prague can win his game he
enters into a tie Yobe if you can
believe this for second place one entire
Point behind the exceptional amazing
Notre back Abdul sotorov
yeah and uh that would make a great
impression on the look on the
leaderboard because there we would have
18 year old 17 year old and then
anishkiri Wesley side Fabiana caruana
the old God just bringing up the rear I
mean it's just incredible to see that it
is two teenagers who could be leading
this tournament if you'd asked me before
Tata began whether this was possible
whether this was likely I would say no
not likely but uh we have seen the
teenagers just play like they are on
fire they're incredible and naughty back
wow wow wow he's just been dominating
every single game he's played so far
but I just gotta keep referencing
Madness Carlson I know I've been talking
about this a lot but I just have a
feeling I've compensated these
tournaments for many many years I have a
feeling that Magnus Carlson is going to
ride the wave of this win and make a
serious bid at the very least to enter
the top three because we've got a lot
more chess remaining to be played we
have a lot more chess to play In This
Very round let's switch back around to
dingly Ren's miserable Rook end game he
is upon down against Vincent kymer he
has been defending this position for
right about 25 moves first he was under
pressure then Vincent transformed his
Advantage into a pawn up rook end game
and this is where they currently set F7
F6 yovi is the last move by dingley Wren
trying to cut into White's Pawn chain
and simplify the position
yes I think it's a good philosophy
actually to follow when your Dow
material when in a rook and pawn end
game trade off those pawns and I really
do like this move
okay and there's not that many things
that Vincent can do he probably has to
trade off pawns but at the right time he
has to activate his rook and he has to
cause pressure on the black position uh
if you're not gonna trade on F6 the only
other move that I can see is actually to
swing The Rook one square to B3 and
attack the B6 Pawn oh I didn't even see
that and he's just played it
this is just insane I mean we swear we
don't have inside knowledge of the moves
that they were going to play literally
insane timing Rook B3 is on the board
and we're gonna get a series of forced
moves as dingley Wren takes a seat and
writes down the move he's going to take
on E5 and he's just done that Vincent is
going to take on B6 with check and then
recapture the pawn 95 when he's gonna be
you'll be two pawns up but the problem
is that his King is
just punishingly passive here and all of
a sudden dingly Ren has gotten wildly
active
yeah
it's a big problem I mean is there
something
oh oh oh
no I gotta pull up an analysis board
I'm gonna go here don't do that to me
okay you still have Rook F6 check
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then one of the biggest tragic
comedies on the planet happens and
you're like
makes all the end game manuals as to
what not to do
oh my gosh so what is who I gonna do
about it because Rook D2 sets up the
mating net now you can meet you want to
Rook F6 check I suppose yeah
I'll take this little
nugget over there
another interesting kind of scenario
occurs because after work takes porn you
can actually step forward favorite B5
check grab the H5 and it's a race
oh my gosh why am I be losing here
yeah I probably have managed to Wrangle
that because um you do have ideas of
just a blocking
the Rooks coordination I was kind of
hoping that two pawns would be fast but
they're not very good are they
well to your point I think that exactly
happens if you try to get behind upon
the typical wisdom is that you wait for
black to promote
and then you know user connected
passwords the problem is this classic
Rook B3 check and Rook C3 trick and
black simply wins now Vincent is
definitely not going to get a situation
where he risks losing the game although
yovi I'm sure you can second me on this
I've seen so many of these games where
you think you can't lose you're playing
for two results and then you just get
too ambitious you allow a certain
imbalance and whenever there's a past
Pawn in a rook end game there are
winning chances doesn't matter how many
extra pawns the opposing side has let's
rewind back to
getting F5 I think Rook B3 as tempting
as it was was a serious mistake I think
Vincent might have either missed or
underestimated the idea of Rook to deto
yeah I agree with you
um I think it was very tempting but
ultimately in the end game Teamwork
Makes the Dream work and you just have
to remember that at all costs and yeah
on the subject of Recon Pawn endings I
have seen so many and I've also
commented on so many Rick and porn
endings where one side has been a pawn
up but they've
artificially played the position or
they've contorted themselves in such a
way that it's actually the defender who
manages to turn it all around and win
and we just saw a great example of that
it's not like white did anything foolish
uh in the line that we just examined
it's just that it's so easy to
underestimate the counter play Vince and
missed Rook D2 he's got 12 minutes
suddenly for 10 moves I think ding is as
close as he has been in the last 30
moves to let's say at the very least
holding half a point and speaking of
ding we had a very insightful interview
with him uh not we he was interviewed
right before the tournament I wasn't
there but let's listen in to ding's
insights coming into Tata Steel
yeah I feel I feel good I feel excited
to get back here
I remember the first time I was there I
was helping one Hall I just sometimes I
got some snakes or drinks here in the
park in the playing Hall so it's it's
very special feeling
when I'm playing a very strong
tournament
I always want to try my best and do not
hide anything yes it's totally changed
the not only my games but also the games
itself I I say you know the engines can
completely evaluate the positions very
correctly evaluated positions it means
if we want to beat the opponent with the
same level we need to work hard and to
try to stay the very small advantages
not cool collected Championship
Challenger dingley Wren is just a Class
Act and right now Vincent kymer Yobe we
talked about it the Here We Go Again
mode I think that's exactly what's going
through his mind again can I just catch
a break in the final stage of any game
yeah and sadly for Vincent this is what
makes super Grand Masters
Grand Masters who are number two in the
world very difficult to beat because
they keep on finding resources and you
have to bring your A game to every
single moment of the game I mean there's
just nothing for it and uh Rook D2 as
you've highlighted was a it's a
fantastic resource for black
it's all about coordinating your forces
about creating chances and having said
that I think Vincent still knows that he
is within the Realms of saving the game
even if he takes a little bit of risk to
get there
yeah I mean we analyzed the line or
white is on the cusp of losing where
white actually loses but that is a
little bit of hyperbole let's be real I
don't think Vincent is going to allow it
to get nearly uh that far now the one
last thing I'll say and then perhaps we
could uh take a look at prague's game
we've got a lot of exciting developments
in that game as well white could start
with the move Rook to B5 but the issue
is that black could execute the same
second rank mating that idea with the
Rook from C2 so Rook B5 Rook C1 I don't
really think changes the nature of the
position but whatever he does Vincent is
going to have to make a decision quickly
he's now down to nine minutes and 40
seconds and we will keep you abreast of
the developments in this game but I'm
going to bet a silver dollar that we're
gonna have a peaceful result in kymer
ding but let's go back to our bird's eye
view we still have three games left
we still do and uh take a look at the
bird's eye position of pregnant against
Jordan van Forest I'm just admiring that
porn structure isn't that a sight to
behold
and uh just to have a look at that night
sitting there on F7
now presumably
things happened in the way that we
expected them to
and as you pointed out during the break
Prague literally melding two ideas in
one and actually a very creative
tactical way here's what happened after
Bishop d8 he went 95 and 90 before I
thought was a transmission error when
the first move was first played took me
a couple moments but I realized that
it's actually a stroke of Genius because
in the event of Knight takes before the
move A6 may seem to give lack a chance
to give the Knight away for the pawn of
course if you move the Rook A7 wins but
Prague sees one step further Rook A6 and
you cannot defend the C6 Pawn that's why
you put the Knight on E5 and here black
collapses immediately Jordan had no
choice but to drop back to d8 a
depressing move in comes the night
around it goes to D6 tying Jordan down
even further and all of the ideas that
we had mentioned Yogi I love how he's
applying them one after the other and
the third idea is to swing The Rook from
A1 where it has successfully done its
job over to greener pastures on the
other side of the board
ah that Rook is headed to G6 and there's
no stopping it and
I
I I'm just lost for words because I
cannot see what Jordan can play to
remain in this game
yeah he's tied down I think a good
illustrative line his Bishop takes H4 in
which case I think white just goes
Knight D6
and you could play Knight takes F5
you could even play Knight takes D5 and
Knight B5 I wouldn't Venture that far
your old idea Rook H1 I mean literally
anything here leads to the immediate
collapse of Black's King side and with
it uh of course the game Bishop F6
there's a beautiful idea here Rook to G6
and then black bushes you have a knight
takes G7 just massacring the whole King
side and I feel like the game is very
likely to end in exactly this kind of
way now apparently if we go back to the
current board the only move and Yogi
this is not an easy move to see Knight
B8 back to D7 in order to control the E5
square and to prepare to meet Rook G6
with Knight D to f8
man
yeah it's uh it's not pretty but I guess
it's
sufficient but I mean here we're talking
about just surviving as in
just extending the game by a few moves
you're like the only chance here for
Jordan might be to try to extract as
much time off of price clock as possible
get him into time pressure before move
60.
otherwise you're just staring down the
barrel of the most miserable end game
I've ever seen you just gotta sympathize
with with Jordan we've all been there
those games when you seem to defend
interminably and you don't catch a
single break and you know that your
opponent is going to keep you in his
clutches for the foreseeable future how
do you motivate yourself in these
situations
well it's one of the hardest things to
do Yogi and it's what makes people like
Magnus so impressive because he handles
these situations
amazingly from both the attacking side
but equally so from the defending side
yeah it's not an easy task and uh
maybe I think I think now that you've
shown me the move I think it is findable
it is findable to have this kind of
situation where all the pieces protect
each other and you just sit there hold
tight hope for the best like you said
at some point Jordan will make a mistake
and he will crack and there we can see
Jordan's face while he concentrates and
he tries to come up with a move and in
the meantime can we take a look at the
bird's eye to see how things are
developing in the other two games
because it feels like we're edging
towards a result
very soon I'm predicting in the next few
minutes somehow that some of the games
would just fizzle out and one of them
that I'd like to kind of revisit is the
game between Fabi and param
yeah I'm actually surprised that that
game is still going and if I had to
predict I'd say that that is going to be
the next game to finish on the same page
in the sense that we are getting a lot
more clarity in all three of the
remaining games things haven't really
changed in the param game he goes for
your idea he talks the king away on H2
but unfortunately there's just too many
things to keep track of for white and
it's just not feasible or Parham to ever
get this queen onto a square where it
can properly support the pawn
what has happened in the last couple of
moves they're starting to repeat Queen
B1 Queen D1 Queen B1 and I feel like
Parham might have to accept the
inevitable this is probably a good time
to do it no he just keeps it going with
H4 oh I'm looking for him what a fighter
what a fighter keeping the game alive I
I have to say I really do like uh fabi's
technique of anchoring his Bishop
putting out E4 just by going F5 you know
it's a fantastically placed there it
also kind of prevents any tactical ideas
happening along that long diagonal and
okay H4 it's a kind of a bluffing type
of move hustle move trying to strike
some fear in Fabi but we know Fabi is
just very calm very collected he's not
going to be phased at all
he just doesn't fall for provocations
like this and I would just go Queen
before I mean I'm just saying you you
want to push your Pawn to H5 and create
another weakness you want to over press
by all means be my guest because it's
important to note that even after white
gets the pawn to H5 it will be
vanishingly unlikely that white ever
manages to get the queen to G6 again
that involves moving the queen away from
this diagonal that means leaving on
unprotected so I really think this is
parham's last ditch attempt to provoke a
move like H5 which incidentally I think
doesn't change the evaluation at all but
if I'm fobby you know all things held
equal you normally want to avoid pushing
unnecessary pawns and avoid changing the
position which will then force you to
spend more time and adapt to the new
reality I'm going Queen before I'm
looking up at my opponent and saying
let's go to dinner
yeah and uh it is very tempting just to
kind of
put the pieces back in their box and
agree
to a dinner date but uh on the other
hand but on the other hand I mean you
can kind of see it are trying to think
of ways that white can get his dream so
his dream is to push his Pawn to age
five get a queen to G6 and if the bishop
is on C4 even better then we have a
check mating net
saddled up but I mean can Parham even
get close to
obtaining something like this
no I mean as close as he comes to see he
can ensure H5
and Fabi he seems to be about to make a
move I would venture to I would Hazard
the guest of this queen before and it is
Queen B4
so he can play H5 congratulations would
you like a medal you know black and just
go
anything Queen back to B1 Queen D6 back
to B4
if I'm Parham you know I don't want to
do something foolish do something crazy
I have an idea I have an idea okay it's
if okay so I go H5 I have to do that all
right and now you've got to be a bit
slightly careful because now I'm going
to go Bishop C4
okay yeah so for the sake oh he's scared
you see where I'm going guys I see I'm
starting you're starting to send some
Shivers up my spine you want to go
Bishop F7 2g6 with the bishop to get to
G6 not with the queen yeah oh that is a
lovely idea
ah
okay I know what I'm gonna do though I'm
gonna go Queen B4 anyway
okay in your face I'm gonna send you to
F7
I'm gonna show you that I literally
don't care Queen D6 check
okay
um okay so I Turn To Shine
Okay g I got I can move my king up
I can
yes yes yes
but then my king does a run around yeah
and at this point this is the kind of
thing that I'm talking about I mean I
think black can maybe go F4
threatening a fork
here you have to start I mean this is
already becomes like a three years old
game all of a sudden although probably
Bishop g6s
is a safe way to to ensure a draw
but uh
yeah yeah there
yeah they're like is best advised to
I still don't see how Bishop G6 really
sets up
threats that are overly significant it's
just a mate on the back rank you know
what's the big problem so let's say I
actually just go like here
okay check I'll go back
and now the queen has to slide somewhere
probably to yeah that's right put it on
80.
good
oh you can't get it to C8 because C2 is
covered and D2 is covered somehow
Black's pieces are weaving building a
wall a defensive wall That's preventing
white from infiltrating
oh very nice
crazy
ah but this yeah this is possible
knowing Parham he will squeeze every
last drop out of each position he won't
admit the draw until literally every
chance has been squeezed
yeah and uh well he has the right to do
that I mean in fact we encourage that
kind of philosophy we encourage that
spirit and it's
really makes us happy to see it because
I mean let's face it most of us would
get into this type of position and if
they if it was like for instance a
strong very high rated player playing
with the white pieces black was lower
rated there was no way that the higher
rated player would just kind of say draw
they would try try try until
that they tried absolutely everything
and nothing had worked
that's exactly right and this isn't for
show I think is the important thing to
emphasize it's not like he's sitting
there and thinking about what are the
organizers going to appreciate it that I
play Parham is truly thinking about each
and every way to tighten the screws and
make Abby's job as hard as possible
unfortunately
there's no magic in chess there is but
not in a position where you only have a
queen and a bishop and a pawn that you
are unfortunately obligated to protect
at all times so this is really a
question of when the game will end in a
draw not weather the game will end in a
draw and we have more clarity in some of
the other games let's rush back to our
bird's eye view because
it seems to me
that in both of the games we are
following the kind of path that we laid
out uh you can see dingley Wren has
indeed uh maneuvered his Rook to the
second Rank and set up this deadly idea
of G5 and G4 that is going to force
Vincent's hand it's going to force
Vincent to give up at the very least at
Pawn of his own I think ding is knocking
on the door of a draw in fact
I'm gonna Echo what I said earlier yovi
where I'm starting if I had that against
ding I would start to get really
concerned uh if I'm Vincent because you
don't want to give black that past sea
pawn and you certainly don't want to get
checkmated
now you certainly don't I think it's now
time to back pedal furiously and just
accept the draw because like you said
the threat of Checkmate is looming
strong and you just don't want to handle
that I mean look at the white king it
should not be there on H3 it was a good
idea in many moons ago but now terrible
piece just so it shows how chess is a
pickle
I try to put less of an emphasis on body
language ever since that well-known
interview with Fabi where he actually
offered constructive criticism uh to me
and you know other commentators that
there often tends to be an over emphasis
on body language and chess commentary
where you claim that you know exactly
what the players think and I started to
understand that I did tend to do that a
lot uh in this particular instance
though after five and a half hours I
think body language is a lot more direct
you have much less of an ability to
temper uh your emotions everything is
written on your face and it just seems
to me Vincent is just fed up with
playing excellent games and then an hour
four or hour five things just seem to go
Haywire
yeah and uh I have to say I agree with
you there in fact I I just saw him look
to the side and it appears like there's
a small Shake of the head like he's like
oh man give me a break you know I've
been upon down and I've lost them and
now I'm a pawn up
why can't my opponent make a mistake why
is there still fight on the board and
yeah
and then now he's after talking to
himself he's back in a full Focus mode
it's quite funny with chess it's like
often you give yourself like a rut what
I do anyway
um I give myself a running commentary
and sometimes I give myself a pep talk I
remember one time I had a terrible
opening it I mean I could barely move a
piece and I was playing Black against
2600 and I thought
you know life is good look outside
you're in Sunny Norway look at the
mountains enjoy the fact that you're
alive and so I just sat there and I
started smiling and then I went back
into full Focus move mode and I
discovered that there was one move to
survive in the position and uh in fact
it set a trap and he fell right into it
so I was very happy
that's incredible and it's just a
wholesome way to look at it I think I do
something similar especially at the US
Championship which is in the St Louis
chess club the players have the right to
come out into the balcony the weather is
often good
um when it doesn't storm and pour so
what if I especially if I have a
difficult position I'll do something
kind of similar I think in spirit where
I'll walk out I'll see the you know the
pedestrians Milling about on the
sidewalk and the cars driving into the
parking lot I'll just remind myself like
there are people still living their
lives who don't really care how I'm
gonna do against Alexander onishook in
this game there are people still working
in the restaurants and walking to and
from Starbucks and working on their
homework assignments uh and you know
paying off their bills it just gives you
I think a nice sense of perspective
because sometimes when you get really
stressed it's very easy to just start
catastrophizing to borrow your word from
yesterday and imagine things as kind of
a life or death scenario that can really
really put you on the fast track to a
disastrous blunder speaking of
disastrous
disastrous yeah
someone is threatening a Checkmate in
two but of course Vincent has spotted it
and played the only saving move which
was to advance his Pawn to G4 and now
the King goes to safety on G3 still it
gave us that uh
he gave us a little bit of a scare but
I I think Vincent's game is going to end
very shortly we'll bring you that when
it does but I think the more meat on the
bone is still in prague's game somehow
you're invent Forest hasn't lost yet in
fact he's holding things together for
the time being so let's switch to that
game and let's try to determine if he's
got any realistic chances to exploit
products time pressure and keep things
going in the right direction what do you
make of this looks like he's completely
in utterly paralyzed
uh looks like Jordan can't move but to
be fair I mean this is an improvement if
we on the position that we saw maybe 10
moves ago where it just looked terrible
I mean it just looked like like species
were not doing anything at least here
they're all together they form a pretty
pattern and it's not entirely clear how
White's Rook is actually going to start
attacking some Pawns
um unless he's kind of
trying to move down the board with a
rook to G1 or somewhere and then attack
the F Pawn from in front that could be
an idea but it kind of feels like a step
backward
away from the goal
there's one tactical idea that I would
draw people's attention to well two
concepts first of all black is virtually
in zugzvan it's incredibly hard to find
a move but let's say the black you know
finds a way to tread water this might be
the only way to do it there's a couple
of interesting ideas one of them is to
drop the Knight back to D3 and then move
it toward F4 maneuver the Knight around
trade off flex really blacks only
piece that stands between him and you
know apocalypse and after Knight takes
up for EF Bishop f8 I don't think Wayne
needs to do anything complicated I think
what I just comes around and starts
eating up the king side pawns and then
dragging The Rook forward to h8 Black is
not going to survive this for very long
so I think the only chance and this
chance is only gonna have only gonna be
on this move because after Knight T3
it's no longer possible I think Jordan
has to seek active counter play well
active counter play in quotes insofar as
you can do that with the move uh F5 F4
and in the event of A6 you take it and
now you continue treading water with
Bishop f8 it's losing of course but you
know
it's not the easiest thing in the world
and he's played a four and we continue
our hot streak
we've done well haven't we in the end
game we've got nearly every single plan
every single idea and uh I'm feeling
quite toughed with myself me too well
it's hour five and a half six and a half
so you know Gotta Give ourselves some
credit Gotta Give Jordan some credit for
finding up for after five and a half
hours of Defending
yeah and uh what's also neat about it is
that it sets up a tactical trick that of
course pragananda will not fall into you
cannot capture that pawn because of the
fork Knight takes F4
and that would be all over that would be
such a cruel turnaround
um
but uh yeah you've got to keep your Pawn
structure intact so I I suspect that
we're going to see something else maybe
maybe your idea can still come into play
again of Knight D3
yes although there the difference is
that after Fe King takes E3 I guess I
can since we have the analysis board up
take Stakes black has the additional
resource Rook to B7
and another tragic turn of events would
be Knight F4 Rook D3 track uh Rook B3
followed by Rook takes D3 check and you
know the same tactic with Knight F4
strikes again so here white would most
likely have to go back to B4 no damage
done but Jordan looks up at his opponent
after going Greek C7 and asking hey Rod
what you got let me tell you what you
got he got eight minutes on the clock
for eight moves and this game isn't
gonna win itself black is not going to
collapse voluntarily white is going to
have to find one more tactic he's gonna
have to make one more push in order to
break the last line of Black's defenses
and I don't see anything off the top of
my head you'll be amazingly I'll be
honest with you I think Jordan has some
serious practical chances all of a
sudden
yeah
um I see a few ideas actually
um so I kind of I like this kind of
situation I like your move A6 why not
tie The Rook down and oh he's done it
and he has say for instance after Pawn
takes porn
King takes six one and you yeah you
start waiting I think white should be
advised to wait as well
and I maybe wait by playing
Bishop F2
and you might be asking like why
but okay now I'm going to go Bishop G3
why Bishop F4
oh my gosh the staircase are you going
to G5 I am going to go to G5 but then
maybe you go to Bishop f8 and
um
I know I've tracked my own Rook oh yeah
you can do you can do all sorts of
shenanigans like A7 and Knight 66 that
idea by the way was missed by Prague a
little bit earlier that would have won
the game I think on the spot you could
still do it as a desperate measure but
yeah this gets very messy so maybe in
this position
now now you can't do that either here
because Knight takes C6 Rook takes and
then A7 Rook stops the pawn from behind
hang on a second how about you put the
bishop on F2
okay let's rewind it back down Bishop F2
and now you just run with the King to D2
huh
and like f C3 get it all the way up to
A5
dancing dancing dancing well the moment
you get it up to A5 I'm gonna go here
will you dare
no no
this this coward over here says no no no
no no this wise person this wise person
over here will not go King B6
uh no but I I
will probably get my king to A4 I think
I might not step up to A5 just yet by
the way we'll try to yeah so sorry
interrupts you I just wanted to put it
in that camp kymer and ding have drawn
as predicted
okay
yes that is official please continue
and okay so we still have the games uh
Parham maxoodloo and Fabi Karana still
playing and of course this one had to
break this one down it must be possible
it must be we don't believe in
fortresses in these parts
what is
the secret ingredient how do you make
that last push well first of all I think
it's not that easy for Jordan to find
the move Bishop f8 we talk about how
difficult it is just to sit around and
do nothing especially when you have the
feeling that your opponent is this close
to winning
but Jordan is helped by the fact that
there's just no other moves he can't
move his Knight can't move his King yet
literally Bishop fade is forced
yeah yeah there's not nothing for it
right you just gotta indeed play it
and uh well if Jordan draws this then it
really will be goalkeepers Glory as you
mentioned yesterday you know he's
expected to lose this game now for
many many many moves and uh he's still
alive he's still fighting and
yeah still some technique to be done
still some work ahead for pragmananda
it might be expedient for Prague to wait
until move 60 to try to just Shuffle the
pieces back and forth avoiding
repetition of course
to get those extra 15 minutes because
750 in a situation where you're trying
to break through a fortress like this is
not a lot of time and it's so easy just
to make one untoward Pawn Advance play
A7 at the wrong time and suddenly you
know the table's turn so we will let
Jordan figure out whether he wants to
sit around in Bishop f8
hint he does spoiler alert and he will
and we go back to our bird's eye view
where we have only two games left the
Jordan game that we just looked at in
the Fabi game which should end the OV
any second fappy is just going for
active defense advancing his spawn to F4
and trying to force the result of the
game and this is what I was talking
about parham's King is a little bit
uncomfortable there on H3 should we run
to that game yeah definitely because I'm
getting that feeling of deja vu again
no no no no no we have to go back to the
Jordan game oh just plundered horribly
oh my gosh
sorry to
you know go back and forth here but
Jordan has just played a shocking movie
he's played Rook C7 to C8 simply
allowing the pawn to advance to A7
and after Rook A8 there is the simple
tactic Knight takes C6 maybe Jordan was
banking on the Move Knight to f8 but
everything went there's even Knight B8
check
yeah oh no
um am I missing anything no you're not
missing anything A7
has to be played
and the shock maybe maybe his whole idea
is actually
just sit there with the Rook on C8 and
now move Bishop f8 could that still hold
but I can still play the move Knight
takes C6
this maybe is what he missed
fatigue fatigue is the worst enemy of
anybody in a situation like this okay we
ride back to the live game Prague with
the no hesitation
that was a pure fatigue moment right
there yovi he would not have played this
move not even close after two hours of
fighting
yeah and of course we have to remember
that Jordan has been under tremendous
psychological pressure it's so difficult
to be on the verge defeat remember he's
been calculating every single one of
prague's moves he's been on the
defensive the whole game and it's
unsurprising that in the sixth hour he's
just cracked
this is like the definition of cracked
right Bishop f8 it was the only move and
that would be a very interesting
position to analyze I am positive that
Prague had a way to break through but
Bishop f8 might have offered Jordan the
best chances that he's had to draw this
game really in the last
30 moves because he has been struggling
ever since he was forced to give away
the beep on in the opening you can see
him grabbing his head there
what am I thinking
says he ordered into himself and he
might resign
now like right now I think there's no
point in continuing Knight takes C6 is
Unstoppable
it is Unstoppable sadly and
I
heartbreaking
heartbreaking scenes
better
oh
that's gonna move
I mean even Knight takes C6 ends the
game immediately that's a beautiful move
wait yes
you're very sharp Daniel
I didn't see Knight F4 check it's just
that I forced myself to keep calculating
and Prague didn't do it it doesn't
matter but not be a check would have
ended it here
it does yeah
yeah he took that's also good enough
ah
I think he should have played Knight
takes C6 I really feel like Prague is
making it a little bit more difficult
for himself yet again
yeah but he does have a rook takes
G7
he does then I'll play Rook a eight
that's okay somehow okay
because I have what do you do then okay
so don't I have E6 ideas
so if you capture record yeah
so my idea is and this is where it gets
all a bit fancy yeah E6 and then decoy
your
and like Rook H7
yeah but I think I don't actually have
to rush with uh playing E6 it's it's in
the universe
and there's I guess the idea of taking
on E7 and going Knight takes c66 with a
fork the problem is it's hard to get my
knight off at the right moment but
actually Yogi I think if you play E6
here
this might be a better version because
after Knight takes C6 there is Knight
takes C6
and this I think is game over because
Rook takes white promotes Knight B8 is a
threat and if King takes C6 takes here
and the simple Rook A6 and Bishop G3
just sets up a situation in which
obviously black is totally paralyzed and
C6 is coming and the fact that Prague is
taking his time here the fact that he's
not grabbing the pawn on G7 just yet
tells me that he's going to see E6 he
has to deliver and E6 will end the game
on the spot
was a very convincing line that you
showed us
um
the thing is that there are quite a few
tempting continuations and when you're
spoiled for choice that is when things
tend to go wrong
E6 Rick takes porn
both win
but one is easier than the other
only reason Prague wouldn't play E6 is
again fatigue because this is a move
the kind of move that I think he eats
for breakfast the kind of move he might
even find in an online Blitz game
and with five minutes on the clock he
absolutely should wrap this game up
right now don't keep letting your
opponent back in the game don't mess
with the gods of Chess go E6 and go eat
some dinner
um
how much time
four and a half minutes on the clock
15 minutes added in four moves but I
don't think we're gonna make it that far
it's good he's got plenty of time and
he's doing the right thing it's a
critical moment
and uh take your time and there you can
see they they've been given an extra 50
minutes
for until move 60 so Prague has
how many moves
one two three four four more moves
all my moves okay
including this one
I would be shocked if he doesn't play E6
and he doesn't play it
this one's good enough as well Knight B8
is a threat
huh
and now he's going to get E6
now he's gonna go E6 then I'll go King
C8 though
and suddenly again it's not so simple
this is shocking to me I think the win
is just to go in ib8
yes
so orbish Bay five first
he's chosen the most complicated path
but this should be good enough
yeah
okay
so Rook A7 Knight B8 then you take the
Knight and then you come back around and
you eliminate the sort of linchpin Pawn
once C6 is gone
the whole position collapses and white
should be able to promote either the C
Pawn or the e-pawn in the resulting
position there's an IBA check
yeah this is a
dislike how a Prague has like full board
Vision we were kind of like focused on
E6 and he's like look at this I can just
fit my knight on A6 and my Bishop on a
five a direction I had totally forgotten
these two pieces could go Knight B8 and
once the stronghold on C6 Falls that is
it Max Position will no longer be able
to save be saved
and this is a super impressive idea by
Prague Bishop A5 Knight B8 it's just
that you know he missed the the
relatively straightforward idea and
found the high level Grand Master idea
but this is definitely good enough and
we're entering that stage after Prague
takes on D that will be move 60 it'll
give him another 15 minutes where at
this point Jordan might simply refuse to
continue the struggle which at this
point has become futile
yeah
the result is not in question there it
goes Prague he's not going to hesitate
e is going to take d8
and he does
by the way our other game also very
likely to end any second now I've been
saying that for quite a while but I
think Parham has reached the end of his
winning attempts
okay
shall we go back to our bird's eye view
real fast yes let's do that because
things are definitely nearing their
conclusion right now and uh there we can
see actually the playing Hall how empty
it looks it was full of the crowds
enjoying chess and now just the Arbiters
remain
it was hustle and and bustling with
people all of the open section games
have of course long since ended I think
the time control in the open is quite a
bit uh more manageable for the less
experienced players
who definitely want to make it to the
restaurants in time for dinner
and Prague having himself some dinner on
C6 you can see in fabby's game again the
bishop on B1 the King has somehow made
its way to G4 Yogi and if Arham knows
what's good for him I think it's time to
take that pawn and F4
and after Queen takes B6 to call it a
knight
yes
that would be one way of looking at it
yeah exactly but uh um there's another
way of looking at it saying hang on a
second there's one piece that could be
mobilized and that's the bishop on F1
could be improved there's still some
life left I was thinking put the bishop
on C4
okay
you never know one day you might find
itself
lined up with a queen
yeah those light squares on the king
side
you never know in five minutes for both
players now for six moves
Bishop C4 G6
I'd be terrified of losing to someone
like Fabby here with white Akon F4 I
think the time has come
I think
I think enough is enough
uh but I like you know this the thing is
and we're just commentating these are
not our pieces we don't have to be
nervous about the outcome so you know if
param was to continue I say Bishop E2
Bishop C4
come on I'm just I'm nervous on his
behalf because once you get into the
zone of thinking you can never lose and
you can just make these attempts forever
before you know it with four and a half
minutes it's unpredictable right you you
meet with a move like G6 suddenly you
don't have the time to figure out the
only response so my guess is that Parham
is going to take another minute or two
he can even draw the game with two
seconds but if he goes under two minutes
then he's definitely taking on F4
I agree with you
yep 27 is quite a nice move
but I know in param I think the bishop
will probably go to E2 you know better
safe than sorry
hahaha
it's shipped to E2
it's not an easy move to make now three
minutes and 50 seconds
for the Iranian Grand Master this is
getting a little bit tense again
oh my God Parham is just like huffing
and puffing and grabbing because I mean
you're drawing Fabiano caruana it's not
the worst result in the world
yeah
but uh somehow these Grand Masters you
know they really want to win and they
want to exert every single ounce of
energy that they have and
you know I like the fact that he's
huffing and puffing when he's playing
Fabby I like the fact that Fabby has had
to defend with everything that he's got
in order to secure the draw and what are
we gonna see he's re reaching out for
Queen B2 oh queen bee too we're all
trying
okay yeah I didn't see this one
okay now this is consequences this is
consequences because the queen can come
to D1 you can come to D7 to give check
he's sacking his Bishop
I think Queen E6 check
I think Parham is actually planning to
take that pawn let's bring up well I
don't know if Abby's gonna play quickly
I don't want to bogged down I think
Queen E6 check might be the clinical way
to draw this
the idea being King takes F4 you skewer
the bishop
and then at the end white pushes B7 B8
is a dark Square so the pawn itself
cannot be stopped but what black can do
is just deliver a series of endless
checks to the white king ultimately
forcing white to repeat the moves
yeah
three minutes and 50 seconds now for
Fabby
oh and we have resignation by one Forest
yeah
and uh expected result but what a brave
fight that the Dutchman put up after
just achieving a bad position out of the
opening it looked like at some point he
might be able to hold firm but right now
found a way
indeed he did he always seems to find a
way he is now on plus two with no losses
a tour de force put together by
pragnananda through the first half of
the tournament but of course he's got
the second half to play he still has to
face Magnus Carlson and he's got plenty
of trials and tribulations ahead as he
tries to finish in the top three that
would be just a remarkable performance
by the Indian youngster Fabiano caruana
has put up a remarkable defensive
performance but he needs to finish it
off with a few more accurate moves three
minutes now on the clock
and four moves to make this is a little
bit nerve-wracking Yobe well our hom be
able to pull off the unimaginable and
somehow squeeze out a win
foreign
B2 I'll be honest with you yes it's very
tempting but I'm afraid that the white
King has been left to fend for itself
and there's so many checks on the board
I mean you kind of mentioned one way how
to secure a draw by Perpetual check I'm
also looking at moves like the queen
going down to D1
yeah it's very very tense
it should be two is what he's planning
don't take on F4 and give up the bishop
with check that's the best way to lose
now two minutes for Fabiano car one it's
time to move Fabian I can bet a silver
dollar he's probably trying to ensure
that in that line I mentioned where he
takes the bishop and white plays B7 that
is nerve-wracking in the sense that you
could imagine a scenario there where
White's King somehow meanders its way
out of the checks and Abby just has to
ensure that that scenario remains behind
the scenes
yeah and actually I was thinking of a
way for param to lose it so say you go
Queen E6 can the king hide on the corner
to eight four
just begging to be a checkmated right
exactly
yeah because Bishop F5 there threatens a
very whoa hey that was not an
intentional Arrow Queen E7 mate would be
one of those diagonal mates where the
bishop controls one diagonal the queen
controls the other
one minute
and there you go
and you have to take the pawn
is in for the penny he's in for the
pound
King H4 would get mated in three by the
way I just saw Queenie one and queen G3
mate yeah our hom please take the pawn
don't shoot the same guys for King F3 as
well King F3 by Queenie Queenie three
and queen G3 so there's no point in
thinking about this you've got to take
that pawn
yeah he's he's in too deep and is there
a any chance that he missed the move
Queen F5 check that he forgot the bishop
was saying I don't think so
but it's disturbing me just a little bit
that he's thinking maybe he's already
thinking about offering a draw this
might be a pretty good moment to do that
yeah
now I just want to show one line
King F4 which he's gonna play
if he misses mate I'm retiring from
commentary Gangsta three Queen F1 B7
Queen E1 check
and after Queen F2 you actually have to
be very careful because if you give this
check
then you lose after Queen F4
and the King tucks away on H2
this is the way to lose
but
black and draw with Queen B4 or with the
simple check on C3 followed by Queen CSA
okay back to the live board
yeah this is okay
this should end within a couple minutes
it definitely should do that I mean is
there any chance that the white king can
try to hide in the open
the king moves not to G3 but to E3
yeah King E3 is
a very interesting possibility
I'll take you'll go B7 I'll check you
from the from the rear
and then you're saying like make a Mad
Dash show at the center
yeah more or less I was like use the
pawn on B7 as a shield because after all
the bishop and Queen Don't coordinate so
well
um together I mean by that I mean that
they're not going to coordinate on the
dark squares they're only going to have
full control over the light squares
it would be consistent with our hom's
winning attempts in this game every time
he seems to reach a dead end he finds
some way to keep the game going
but I think even someone as
intent on fighting as Parham
should take the wise pragmatic route and
just drop the king back to G3 and allow
the perpetual
yeah
oh one minute tense moment one minute
the players have got three moves left to
the magic move 60 upon which they will
be getting some additional time added
it's interesting that Barham has decided
to Garb himself in formal attire usually
he's got that puffer jacket that he
takes with him to every tournament but
today he's looking pretty dapper
and so is that
that puffer jacket that he traditionally
wears is not allowed
isn't that a kind of smart dress code
was any wearing it yesterday
I don't remember
I think he might have been but the
rounds are starting together in my head
he has been wearing it apparently yeah
and he's a well he's got to make a move
in the next 30 seconds he does
oh look at that she does not want the
draw he just doesn't
okay okay Fabby now take the bishop you
have to do that and just let that pawn
get to B7 and then do some check-in okay
he does that
seven
we need one check
and Mr Perpetual is going to pay us a
nice little visit here
move 59 so two moves until time control
and then we've got another 15 minutes
added to the clock
so I I could see Parham taking all 15
minutes and
you know trying to find something that
isn't there but
it depends on its frame of mind it
depends on how tired he is
um and you know
how much he wants Fabi to suffer
I think it's safe to say that this yeah
so go ahead
I was just gonna say personally
I quite like seeing Fabi grovel for a
draw
I mean no not because I don't like
fabulous because I've been in his
situation so many times so say I'm
playing a grand master I get this
position they're like no you have to
prove to me you know how to draw and
often these stupid Grandmasters don't
get that kind of treatment they kind of
they just get their parents saying draw
and they go yeah okay I didn't have to
prove anything but I just love the fact
that Fabi now has to check accurately
and yes it's a draw but Abby has had to
fight
oh he most certainly has and he has to
continue to fight folks as they make
move 60 we are going to leave the
players on camera we're going to take uh
most probably our final break as this
final game of round seven wins down we
hope you've been enjoying our coverage
of the Tata steel chess tournament the
final game enters its seventh hour and
we will take our final break we will
have more Tata steel coverage for you on
the other side of this short break
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
oh what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude idiot I
told you to bring it let's just go get
somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
we're back it's the final game here in
round seven of the Tata steel chess
tournament and the concerned expression
on the face of Iranian giamparha maksudu
who has been trying to win the game for
about 50 moves and the unimaginable is
about to happen he has pressed and
pressed and pressed and he's overpressed
oh my goodness Ivanka he is trying hard
to lose this game and I think he might
have just succeeded no way I think so I
mean we were just kind of commenting
that in the run-up to the opening that
param only had one move to maintain the
balance and that was just to retreat the
king to C4 and just repeat the position
this loses all black has to do is
actually check
but does it lose like outright I feel
like there's no question that if black
gives the right check right now
black is the only one who can win do you
feel that it's hopeless if black gives
the check on E3
according to the computer it's like
minus 2.5
oh m g and yeah listen I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna put on that you know smart
alec commentator how oh you know I said
this is a possibility now he's doing it
but
this is always a possibility when you
get into that frame of mind where you're
playing without risk it's a two result
game you can lose any position in chess
we're too experienced we're experienced
enough to know that literally any
position can be lost anything can be
overpressed and we've seen even the
strongest GMS in the world even Magnus
Carlson has had experiences like this
and what tends to happen to Yogi is that
you start to panic the moment you sense
that you are Suddenly at risk for losing
the game you panic and then you lose all
objectivity you make an impatient move
and that's exactly what just happened we
saw it in the body language King to C4
was the only move to maintain a clean
draw and he said he's gone forward to B6
so why do you think Queen E3 is the
critical check to deliver here
yes the queen E3 forces the king to move
to C7 and from there on the queen can
come to C5 and start grabbing some
squares away from the white king and
remember the white king cannot travel on
light squares it cannot allow this
bishop on B1 to join in the attack and
uh so yeah as you've highlighted King D7
would be a gross mistake and so if you
if you step back sorry if you step where
do you want to go with your king
well I probably have to go to Da I mean
I think the human move is King to B8 but
this loses because black can now drag
his Bishop back Target the pawn
and that's it I mean now black is up a
bishop and we'll find some way to win
this Pawn
because this is the problem yeah he's
done it he's found it and the kid the
queen will come to D6
and after the King goes to E8
yeah you can't go there but if you go to
E8 the queen just comes and blockades
the pawn oh my gosh there's a crazy line
here
you go Queen B8 is what you're saying
but what about the move Bishop to E4 oh
there's no mate I mean this only leads
to a Perpetual miraculously white is
protecting the F6 square with this queen
he's suddenly holding this together by
the skin of his teeth but you're
absolutely right you'll be Queen B8 King
D7 sorry King E7 you don't want to put
it on in a light Square
Bishop B4 that's it
oh you have to go King F7 to threaten
mate
yep
and now there's a beautiful resource
Bishop to AQ check
then Queen to G8 you win the queen back
white promotes but now black can easily
pick off either the g-pawn or perhaps
even more precisely the H5 Fawn and this
should be a winning end game
yeah and uh
can you believe this
we are definitely in for the Long Haul
Queen E3
oh my gosh can you believe this
I I I'm kind of a bit staggered actually
because
I did not dream of this happening and
the King has
planted itself on C7 and
Haram he just wanted to win so much he's
completely overpressed and now the wind
is just miles away from his grasp in
fact it is Fabby who is now going to
start to turn things around and just
look a Fabby look at the I know we're
told by Fabi not to read his body
language but look how he suddenly sat up
and now he's understands that things
have switched Swiss twists turned into
in his favor I was like we've been on on
air for a long time we have we have
and uh our generic icy and sorry uh
nederburg of is cursing in like four
different languages right now he's like
this was in the bag nice solid result
for Parham holding faculty withdraw all
of a sudden you look at this position
and you refuse to believe that this
position
and the position after let's say move 50
or move 40 was one in the same I mean
you have to take your hat off on the one
hand to parhamaksudu for the fighting
Spirit which is really second to none at
the top level the desire the drive on
the other hand from a more critical
perspective you gotta admit that
something like this is just unacceptable
you cannot let something like this
happen you're just leaving a point on
the table out of stubbornness because at
some point you have to know when to
admit hey my opponent defended well time
to split the point rather than digging
myself into a hole and actually losing
the game
it's not over yet that Queen end game we
discussed is very likely
but I don't think Arham will have the
mental energy or the physical energy to
hold that pawn on down end game
yeah I mean also just to talk about the
psychology as well I mean it's very
difficult to adapt you know you being
the one pushing you being the one
pressing for a win and then suddenly
it's all gone wrong and you've made a
terrible blunder and you know what they
say about blunders they always come in
pairs so I agree I think if Carolina
gets into that incredible Queen ending
that you showed us I think there's no
chance for param on a practical level
he's not going to be able to make that
shift
you know what that means a sip of water
he hasn't sipped that water in about 30
moves that means he's satisfied with
this position he knows he is now fully
out of the woods
and this has been one of the wildest
turnarounds that I've seen in recent
times that if carowana completes the
picture
and claims the full point
I I'm already speechless and I will be
even more speechless
yeah bd6 check on Deck here
yeah so
Queen D6 is a possibility queen of Fate
is a possibility uh Queen D6 is a a nice
move
I just I do like the kind of
Grand Master approach of repeating the
position twice
before making a move
but sorry before
making a decision yeah
queen of Fate King C7 yeah if you really
want to rub it in your opponent's face
draw nope just kidding
you had your chance you missed it Queen
D6 is going to happen now the time
situation 10 minutes to 13 minutes that
sounds like an eternity compared to what
they just said and that gives us an
opportunity to review the results from
today
oh my God I can't believe this game is
still going we've had a very violent day
here in tata steel four decisive games
out of the six results thus far Magnus
winning Prague beating Jordan van Forest
that was a sparkling game positional
wire to wire effort and of course Notre
back abdusitorov is in some of the
greatest form that we've seen from
anybody I mean this Rivals right now
gukesh's form from the Olympiad but
speaking of gukesh I don't think I've
seen somebody struggle like this in a
while
now Lucas is really having a tough time
of things and we saw him lose to Wesley
so that and someone else who's
struggling is actually Richard Rapport
who was very creative at one stage in
his gear against Magnus Carlson but it
was just insufficient to the world
champions defensive Mastery and uh
someone who's just rolling for it that's
pregnant under who steamrollered past
Jordan van Forrest and someone who's
having a very tough time of it he's been
riding his luck on a few games but today
Lady Luck did not smile on him it was
Arjun Eric icy who lost a tournament
leader nordebec Abdul sotorov and Abdus
taraf whoa like you said at the form of
his life he's just doing incredible
stuff
he is indeed and he's not done yet he's
got half of the tournament still to go
he leads the field by an entire point
but should should Fabiana carwanna pull
off the unimaginable and win the game
his lead will have shrunk to a mere Half
Point right now Notre back sitting in
his hotel room after dinner he was sappy
everything was going well right now he
must be feeling rather uneasy at the
prospect of Fabiano caruana being only a
half point away okay let's go back to
the current position because I have a
minor Insight which is that if Fabiano
caruana does not see the resource Bishop
A2 check then it makes it more likely
that he decides to force a Perpetual in
this position so just to reiterate Queen
D6 check
you can see it gets mated you have to go
here
the interesting thing is that after
Queen ba King F7 white is threatening
made in one and if not for Bishop A2
check the only other thing that black
can do
is go Queen C7 back to B8 but Fabi could
also choose to reach this position
without seeing Bishop A2 but having
reached this position he will most
certainly find Bishop A2 it is a pretty
Elementary tactic it's a deflection
tactic and at that point I don't see
Parham holding that together I just
don't see it
yeah it's they're going or this line
they are and uh for calculating beasts
such as Fabiana caruana there's I really
expect him to find that nice trick I do
love the geometric geometry of that one
the queen on 38
skewering and picking up the queen on A2
and of course picking up some of White's
king-site pawns and
Fabi senses something as well
oh he knows he knows that this is an
opportunity he might never have again
this tournament
yeah well one thing though is it could
be focused
that the king is on E8 is on a light
square if a bishop gets to C6 is going
to be almost made he might be devoting
his energies into that particular move
of relocating the bishop to E4
well whatever he decides he should
decide it pretty fast he wants to leave
himself I think the threshold is
something like two minutes because you
want to be able to invest a little bit
of time in a critical moment here he
goes the Moment of Truth ladies and
gentlemen will he find Queen B8 yes he
will
yes you will and Bishop A2 is going to
come fast
unbelievable
oh can you imagine having to defend that
pawn down end game if you told that to
param he would have laughed you out of
the room what pawn downtown game I'm not
risking
about
oh this is what Fabiano caruana is
talking about Bishop A2
the whole tournament might be talking
about this game
and you can see the excitement on
Fabiano's face yeah
I I could have sworn he had to suppress
a smile because I think it's just
occurred to him Bishop A2
they go on the board and no this is
crazy
now param is going to be the one in deep
thought
well I'm almost a complete surprise to
Parham
he I don't know again it's hard to judge
by the body language you might have
missed it but I'm afraid he'll go King
E7 which hastens is defeated in fact 87
loses immediately just to be totally
clear Queen takes A2 that resulting
Queen end game is far from a clear-cut
win I mean this game could conceivably
last for another hour if they go for
that end game
and
the only reason I think Fabi will win
that Queen end game has to do with the
psychology of having to defend it and
the fact that they've been playing for
six hours and 20 minutes
if Mike sudlu Plays King E7 he loses
because of the simple Queen C7 check and
he's taken it yeah no choice and there
was a mating construction there
between G8
in E7
pick the queen
our hump remotes
and now a very important detail Yogi
Queen takes G2 is a terrible move
because it allows the immediate
Perpetual with Queen B1 and queen back
to B8
so you want to go Queenie oh Exquisite
filigree Precision from caruana
he's a shark isn't he when
they sense blood they start circling I
mean I mean it's just incredible Queen D
Quinny to take the H Pawn and uh
suddenly
the boot is on the other foot and it
will be param who will have to struggle
on for a draw
what this game is Hobby this is crazy
what this game is showing is that this
kind of stuff you know I think some
people in the chat might relate to this
I remember the time you know I had the
game like this whereas pressing for 60
moves but you know if something happens
to you
it probably also happens at a super
Grand Master Level obviously it happens
at a different caliber in the sense that
our hum didn't blunder anything in one
move it was a slow process first he
sacrificed the bishop that was very
ill-advised he was already Towing the
line and then going who knows where with
this King allowing black to orchestrate
this combination
now uh what a miserable miserable
existence he is going to lead for the
next however many moves his defensive
effort lasts oh my Lance and fabi's the
happiest person on Earth right now
yes I mean no I'm it's very difficult to
shake off the ghosts from the past
because Aram is just going to be
thinking why did I do this to myself
this is totally self-inflicted and then
as the game draws on he'll be thinking I
could be at the pizza place right now
and instead he's having to just defend
cling on with all his might to any form
of Hope for a draw and
Fabby is gonna get a new burst of energy
he'll be feeling relentless
well spell out you know this end game in
just a moment but I just wanted to
remind everybody before we do as Parham
decides where he wants to put his King
the best move appears to be king of Fate
at least trying to keep uh Black's pawns
at arm's length but para maksudu was a
last second replacement for the one and
only Jank stuff Duda uh who was not able
to participate
and obviously Parham jumped at the
opportunity to participate in this
historic 85th edition of todded Steel
really one of the most interesting and
intriguing Fields uh in in the last
decade or so of of Tata but how do we
think Young schistuff would have done in
this field I think he would have had a
chance to win the tournament I mean
yacht shished off in good form
is like Notre back in good form he can
win several games in a row even against
the top guys
yeah absolutely when he plays really
well it's like a work of art you know
he's always fighting for the initiative
he's always generating some kind of
counterfeit never count him out
um his style is just a pleasure pleasure
to watch and I I agree with you if he'd
been on form I think he can do very well
when he's not on on form
it tends to be kind of a little bit
streaky and a bit emotional about his
losses but uh yeah it's difficult to say
it is he had a very very difficult
Madrid candidates I was sort of
expecting more from him there but you
can also remember his sparkling victory
at the world's cup but aha maksudlo he's
handled himself acquitted himself very
very well thus far this game is going to
be an incredibly tough build to swallow
if he does not manage
to save this end game okay so he's down
to 11 minutes the worst thing that he
can do is allow his clock to dwindle to
a minute or two because there's no way
that he's going to avoid allowing an
accidental Queen trade or something of
the sort if he
you know if he doesn't leave himself
with a little bit of time
yeah
it has to be practical and so far so
good he's navigated that thorny issue of
where to put the king putting it on the
best Square I thought that was very
courageous actually I wasn't quite sure
whether he would put himself on that
such a row but uh now after Queen takes
porn
yeah the game kind of game will continue
for a long long time
a very long time and I mean white has a
couple of decisions that he can make the
first of which is where he wants to keep
his Pawn
you have a choice between keeping it on
its initial Square we're trying to bring
it up to a well-defended square on G3
Black's winning attempt
is actually very straightforward here
black doesn't have a choice of plans
obviously if you can trade Queens you
should for example King E8 would be a
blunder because it would enable the
queen to move back to the eighth rank
should white play the correct move first
I would start by bringing the queen to
the best Square on the board and then
finding the right moment to start
pushing your pawns I mean you're gonna
go H5
then you're gonna go G5 and you're gonna
get a position very reminiscent of Abdus
Carlson Queen and pawn against Queen
except the fact that the pawn is on the
H file rather than the B file it changes
a lot and I'm not going to pretend that
I know anything about those types of end
games you know I know literally zilch
yeah they're they're very very
complicated those Queen unborn earnings
and one thing we did learn from that
particular end game was that the
defending king must not be on the first
second or third row and uh there we see
Queen F1 for a second
I thought oh you're allowed allowing a
trade but uh it's okay it's all working
out for there's a funny line
the event of Queen F6 black is what is
going to chase the pawn all the way down
bang bang bang and black can go F3 but
obviously the H Pawn is easily
restrained by White's King Bobby is
definitely not going to yield a draw out
of pity
what is he going to do I am almost
positive that we're going to see H5
there's really no point for black in
Dilly dallying with a series of
meaningless checks if you're fat you
want to get down to business and you
don't want to give our hom a chance to
sort of mentally prepare himself for the
defensive effort there it is
you know Fabi well actually I was gonna
say that he was going to centralize the
queen because one of the important
things about Queen and pawn endings it
all depends on how easily your pawns can
advance up the board and secondly it's a
very very good idea that nine times out
of ten you put your queen in a Central
Square so it controls as many squares as
possible
that's exactly right that's one of the
very important skills
that the best endgame players have they
just have a sense for where their pieces
belong and usually they belong closer to
the center now one interesting idea for
black is to drive this Pawn down to H4
and if white bides his time then Queen
F6 check actually wins the game this is
a very nice line because although it
appears that white does the same thing
he pursues the pawn all the way to its
promotion Square because the H Pawn is
now too far along and the king is unable
to stop it I actually think that this is
a very hard idea to stop because after
black plays H4 well how are you going to
prevent black from Trading Queens it's
not so easy to keep the pawn protected
you might have to play a move I don't
know Queen B7 Queen D5 but you're
already hanging by a thread in that case
and uh
fives that he is winning or that he has
a very good chance of winning and there
you can see I love your line by the way
Tanya
[Laughter]
I mean it's just so sadistic it's uh
part of me feels that it feels like you
know maybe Fabi should just give a Pity
draw but no no no no no no no he's not
these are not Grand Masters for that
reason and uh they know how to
like had to turn things around from a
loss from a draw to a win
every couple of seconds I need to pinch
myself to convince myself that yes they
actually they're actually in this
position para Maxwell has the white
pieces
and you can just tell that he is
disgusted with the fact that he has to
defend this it might not even be
defensible objectively there's one two
three four five six seven pieces on the
board so I suppose that this position is
you can plug it into the table base the
seven piece table base but I don't even
think that's important right whether
it's an objective draw or an objective
win doesn't matter at all because the
Practical difficulty of drawing this
with white is so immense that even if
there is a computer draw here I don't
see Parham holding it with now nine
minutes on the clock
as his clock continues to dwindle down
for the final time no more additional
time move 60 has already been made if
I'm Parham I'm playing Queen F2 and
trying to prevent the progress of Lex H
Pawn I think it's the only move actually
yeah
did plug it into the table base and it
actually says black wins and literally
any move that white comes up with
what is the move after Queen F2
um Queen G5
oh and just H4 amongst many yeah oh gosh
this is actually easier than it looks
for black just push the puns
yep and the King always has the H6
Square so even in the event of some
nasty looking diagonal check the king
just moves up okay F2 of course has been
played
Queen G5 is easy clap
he's gonna play it quickly too isn't he
he has played Queen F2 and yeah I do
think you know once you do see the idea
that it is quite obvious you know put
your Pawn on H4
threatened queen of six check very nice
um I can tell you moves that do draw but
these are kind of a little bit
ridiculous moves so King H6 would be a
draw okay
I don't know why
well I think it allows the white to play
Queen F4 and then G3
ah okay
and the same goes for Queen B1
that also wow
[Laughter]
there's Queen E4
I don't really understand myself
don't really understand that move a
queen E4 actually needs to a draw for
this for the reason that you highlighted
white can now play G3 it's a drop it
allows the driver yes
and I I know that they've been playing
for this long but I'm in total disbelief
that he doesn't play King H6 I mean it
is the only way to make progress here
um
and I assume that what he might have
missed is that after Queen D2 but this
is an easy line there's or wait no it's
not an easy line
no King H6
you had to go 25. Queen G5 oh sorry
sorry sorry that's what I meant yeah
yeah and then King H6 yeah I I swear
this is what I had in mind by the way
King H6 immediately this is really cool
we need to check and if you go Queen G5
you give up the pawn on G7 white holds a
truck first you play Queen G5 to prevent
that
and then you play H4 and if white plays
G3 here then again Queen F6 check is a
win that's the point and that's the
reason why Queen E4 is a mistake it's
because after white plays G3 you lose
the ability to force the queen trade
with Queen F6 such an instructive point
and this is what these types of end
games come down to yovi
yes very small details and uh it's
actually incredibly instructive because
until you pointed out this plan of going
H4
trading off into this uh King and porn
ending I did not have any signposts on
how to win this I thought that black
would have to take the very snail-like
approach of just creeping forward with
his pawns and the King trying to
come as slowly as they could in the game
would last another 100 moves but uh
Queen G5 followed by H4 so instructive
yeah and you have to always keep tabs on
your opponent's main defensive ideas and
uh one thing that we have kept tabs on
is the transformation of this playing
haul these players are maybe the last
two people together with the Arbiters in
the playing Hall which is converted from
a massive gym let's take a look at a
time lapse of this incredible process at
work
laughs
[Music]
but I'll wait
okay well a very very nice video there
the gym in vike on say there just aren't
that many meeting spaces so it's
actually pretty impressive that you've
got a space like that to accommodate all
of the players
and uh all of the fans and all of the
players in the open section we've talked
about it many times vacancy Tata steel
it's not just a super tournament it's a
festival and the atmosphere is what
really caters to the kind of Chess that
we regularly see yo you talked about
this yesterday you you've been to
vacancy right I've actually never been
and uh much to my embarrassment uh I
actually thought that if I can say was
far up in the north and because everyone
who I know who has gone to if I can say
has always said oh it's so windy it's
beautiful but uh it can be bitingly cold
so I in my mind I just went ah it's up
there by grown again so imagine my shock
when I found out it was only 30 miles
from Amsterdam
I never knew
yeah you think of it as this sort of
exotic you know Village somewhere in the
nestled away in the mountains uh that
you have to get to for for hours I I had
a tournament like that in a town called
Forney de sopro but that was Italy you
had to fly into Venice and then take a
um train for like four hours and then a
taxi and then I had another tournament
in banask Spain this is a very
well-known open tournament but ask it's
just impossible to get you it's in the
pyrene mountains you have to take a
plane to Barcelona and a four-hour bus
through the mountains to the nearest
city and then a one hour taxi from that
City to uh the anaska which is a village
of 2000 or so
um not fun wouldn't recommend although
the village itself is beautiful Wake On
say you just take a train
from
Amsterdam to Bay for bike and then you
take like a five minute taxi that's all
that's all there is to it yeah and uh
I've had a popular beach beach resort
and in the summer yeah there are tents
on the beach that you can rent out and
stay
yeah it's really only
I guess it's one of the only cities
that's when you name it you immediately
most people actually think of the chess
tournament
I guess Gibraltar is another place like
that in a chess context
um just the cities and the countries
which are sort of specifically known for
a certain chess tournament
yeah
um when it comes to cities that I kind
of really associate with just chess is
like chevanigan
that's actually a place in in uh I think
it's by
The Hague
foreign Festival
yeah
these are not sounds that I am used to
making as a native English speaker
very unusual yeah
um
[Music]
three minutes to find the only saving
move which is to play G3
think as we were watching that video and
talking about vikon Zay I think I've
understood what Fabi why Fabby wants to
provoke G3 and what's taking Parham so
long it's the fact that after G3 is
played I think Fabi is just planning to
either go back to G6 or go back to E6
and then he will be threatening the
trick that we were discussing earlier
where he forces the queen trade and then
advances the pawn to F4 so in parham's
mind he might actually not want to play
G3 because when the pawn sits on G2 you
don't quite have that Queen trade idea
this
this is now a loss for H4 is one good
move
um other moves that win apparently are
just to move the queen to B1 to D3 I
mean that this is so complicated and any
king move on the other hand will draw
yeah it's not quite King H6 I think
allows uh Queen D2 check ah
no he's gonna go H4 that was why he
played Queen E4 I would be stunned if he
didn't play H4
um and after H4 which he's about to play
there it is
now all Queen traits are going to be
winning for black again
or the reason we are now well acquainted
with because when the pawns are on F4
and H4 you are threatening both H3 and
F3 in the white king is in the worst
possible spot it's behind the Pawns
two and a half minutes the OB I think
this game is starting to come to an end
and not to the end that we thought it
would come to
no most certainly not I mean
but this is the beauty of Chess expect
the unexpected and param two and a half
minutes but do remember that he does get
a 30 second increment bonus time after
every move so it's not too critical in
terms of clock timings two minutes the
remaining Queen
he's taking long thinks here I mean he's
now dwindled down Beyond two minutes and
I would say queen B2 with the queen on a
square where it's not susceptible
to a queen trade but then Fabi he'll
toss the king away and start pushing his
Jeep on I mean the winning strategy here
is so straightforward much like it was
in notorbeck Carlson
be careful with uh Queen B2 has the
hidden threat of Queen takes G7
checkmates
when did he play
Queen
okay same thing
okay so I think he wants to play Queen
to G5
yeah Queen F5 checkers
going to follow pretty quickly Fabi is
not going to waste time because each
individual move from his perspective is
risk-free it's not like Queen F5 is
likely to be a big mistake but he really
wants to check for is to make sure that
there are no forced Queen traits and
there aren't any just yet
and F5 is going to follow
Queen F5 is in fact one of the candidate
moves to win
and there you go
accurate as ever
and King E7 King E8
it's a terrible Choice he goes to the
edge of the board
okay now Queen E6 Jack there is King to
f8 White has to try to cling two black
spawns to make it as difficult as
possible for Fabi to push the Jeep on
which by the way he could do right away
is G5 one of the winning moves
uh yes or is it premature
uh in fact it looks like almost
everything wins I mean the only things
that draws are the moves that just uh
give up the H Pawn
tell you some things that lose
[Laughter]
yes
but what is the most efficient move what
is the fastest mate
I think King to G6
looks to be quite good
introducing the king into the race
and setting up Queen trades Galore
yeah yeah King G6 King H5 just make your
way to G3 oh yeah that is simple you
just you just walk your king to G3 and
that's it
I mean it's as simple as that
I mean this is kind of like the original
plan right when you get into these type
of positions you just think well you
know the queen will stand on an Optimum
square and the King will just come up
the board
hopefully assisted by the queen with
some counter checks and all should be
easy
just under two and a half minutes Fabi
he has just under six minutes
if the king gets to G3 Parham might
resign just like in the Carlson
abducator of game White's King is on a
terrible Square I mean you think well on
the one hand you want to keep it close
to the pawns but the moment black
creates a passer the king becomes
incredibly susceptible to check in her
positions where black covers to check
with his Queen with a check forcing a
queen trade and that's a dreadful
possibility in these end games
but we're gonna get a Blitz game here
Fabi now down to five minutes he's
taking his sweet time I mean the player
is just not in any kind of a hurry here
yeah and uh I have to ask
are there any restaurants that are open
this late at night in Vikings and I
think we're getting to that I'm going to
look up the Tarantella hours
Ella is open until
it is closes at 10 p.m so they're going
to make it to the pizzeria I would hope
if they don't make it to that that means
the game would have lasted for another
hour and 20 minutes something tells me
it won't
and G6 played look at him go
look at him go
and uh Parham just plays immediately
Queen to D6
and what's the best move here
there's a queen to F6
uh yeah no basically anything goes as
long as you don't put your queen on E6
it's all going to win
oh and you know why King H5 yeah
well Queen F6 I'll play Queen to D5
and somehow
there's no way to force the queen trade
there I guess you just go King H6 in
that position and start pushing your
Jeep on that's the point
wow
down to four minutes now is Fabby
careful now here he goes
what's he gonna do
I think he will step up with his King to
G5
and I have
yeah Queen D2 check
Maybe
yeah and then you can kind of move
and he steps up to age five
well now Queen D1 check
um
and again everything wins so you can go
Queen to G4 King to G5
I kind of like Queen G4
I like it as well
now this is now moving
at Breakneck speed toward its inevitable
conclusion
the other issue is that it's impossible
for black to blunder like that there's
just no mistake that you can make every
move wins some to move slower some are
three moves faster
but as long as Fabi moves in generally
in the right direction
playing G5 and then getting the king to
G3
this game is over
steady
when's the right 70 eighth move
six hours and 42 minutes of gameplay
today
how long how long do you think this game
will last do you think it will make move
hundred a hundred no I don't think we're
gonna make 100 moves I would estimate
another 15 minutes or so
okay
I mean unless unless farhum starts
playing instantly which is possible if
he just gets
ultimately exhausted from the defensive
effort
I mean Fabi is playing perfectly right
now King H5 King H6
foreign
that's not a problem I mean he can
repeat the position once and then of
course intercept that check with his
Queen
you know what I think it will break a
hundred
it's possible I mean I think Queen to D2
is gonna happen and then Fabio will
finally set his Jeep on in motion with
G5 you mean you have to take the plunge
at some point
you can't win the game unless you either
get the king to G3 or create a past Pawn
with your Pawns
one minute for Parham yeah and one move
that he cannot play is he cannot give a
check on D6 because that would be
intercepted with a counter check by the
queen blocking it on G6 so don't do that
that would accelerate the result of the
game
yes it would
okay well
Queen
52 check yep yep yep and G5
is likely to follow yeah immediately
Bobby just knows what the winning
approach is and he's not hesitating at
all what should I like
I think just just thinking for the sake
of thinking is
of no use here when
moves are are so risk-free
yeah when everything wins you might as
well just play I mean the most important
things that in these Queen endings to
always remember is maximize your Queen's
potential put it on Ascent in the center
secondly think about King safety always
have a home to hide your king and
thirdly is try and think about the path
that you're going the path of your past
born and so in this case it's just about
you know G4 the king getting to G3 and
then just pushing that pawn to its
destination
you have Parham missing that last
opportunity crazy that he still had a
draw as late as move 74. I mean you
think about it it's so hard to win a
chess game even after he messed up to
this extent
he still had that one final chance to
stem
the bleeding and now he's got 20 seconds
so to add to
his lost position he's got no time and
it's so easy to blunder a queen trade
here
Queen D4
okay
okay I would step up with my king almost
instantly yep
and if King H5 whoops I didn't well I
guess we can play with the now sport
opening H5 check on D1 oh just G4
yep but this is Child's Play
Queen h8 check King G4
and the king is in
yeah the king is there and that's it
Queen C3 Queen E4 check and eventually
just gonna lose the second Pawn Yeah and
once the pawn is captured that I would
say is the threshold what I would call
the resignation threshold in parham's
mind he probably already has this in his
mind like when am I going to reside I'm
going to resign when XYZ happens and I
think XYZ is losing the g-pawn
uh I agree okay
um Happy
we're on the same page
okay
Queen D4 so the moves that do squander
away the win are uh and I don't think
you would play this it'd be Queen F1
you know just breaking the connection
between the king and queen and queen A5
and of course H3
those are the only losing moves and uh
sorry drawing moves anything that loses
basically involves putting your queen in
a square it should not go to
yeah there he goes he's reaching for it
King H5 yes
there we go
okay
our hom with his last seconds on his
last legs
just an unbelievable game and chess is
such a ridiculous game honestly like you
don't have any other sport or Endeavor
where you have this type of game just
this type of Arc couldn't script this
better in Hollywood
yeah
I mean one of the unfortunate things
about Chess is that sometimes you just
can't come back from an error and most
other sports you get given the chance to
try and try again and the players are on
to on their second score sheets
yeah and that's a sign that this game is
is not going to end anytime soon
so what's the move here is it just G4
uh yeah so you can G4 will win
also you have some random moves like uh
Queen H7 will also win but the one that
I like the most is Queen to F4 offering
up at Queen trade and also creating a
bridge for the king to travel to G4
and if the queen goes to D7 you lose the
second Pawn that's out of the question
and uh there's nothing else that can be
done yeah yeah Queen F4 looks great
Fabby though I mean he's down to three
minutes again like I said he should keep
a little bit of time on his clock just
in case something unexpected happens to
calculate a pawn end game you don't want
to play on increment here if you're on
the winning side I think he's going to
go G4 that would be my guess
but I like your move as well you know
four is very clinical
yeah
well
basically most moves will win
and uh it's a good choice G4 Queen F4
yeah I think G4 also
creates the G5 Square which can be used
as a checking point for the queen and
cuts off the White Queen from all sorts
of defensive squares squares
here he goes He seems he's been about to
make a move for like two and a half
minutes now there he goes more on the
board
yeah
I gotta say
carwana's technique apart from Queen E4
which is a totally forgivable mistake
has been Exquisite and something we take
for granted but not something that
everybody would have been able to
achieve after seven hours of chess
absolutely I agree with you I mean he's
just done everything perfectly from
advancing the pawn to H4 and then just
maximizing the queen two seconds King on
H6 oh
sorry I just noticed that he had two
seconds on his clock oh and that loses
on the spot H3 now after H3 you might
resign
and Fabby oh no why King G5
I don't understand why not H3
well he's setting up a check right
yeah I guess this also went oh and
basically whichever way maksudu checksi
interposes with a check 15 seconds this
might be it
this might be it
10. nine eight eight
seven four
three two one move
with two seconds he played that move
with two and that's the best move it's
the only way to avoid the queen trade so
I'm just not giving up
but it's really just a question of when
Fabi wants to play H3 he could play it
now and after G8 he could pick up the
pawn like that but I wouldn't advise
that to him I would I don't like King G5
I think that was a a one move trap I
think you should move the king back to
H5 and just push the pawn down to H3
I think that's what he should do
and uh that's actually the top table
based recommendation just move the key
to the side but instead she gives a
check
okay
still good obviously obviously does not
ruin anything
right yeah
so King E5 I guess
King E5 yeah and
he lets go of the piece and I'm here
checking this table base because
when there comes positions whereas there
are so few pieces on the board the
computers have just simply worked
everything out they can sit there by
sheer maths and just work out that every
single move will lead to a certain
conclusion and uh luckily for us I have
it here up on my screen and I can see
that basically black can almost play
anything here and will lead to a win
and I find it quite fantastic that we
have this thing in existence because
before people just had to know where you
know which games were which in games
were winning which ones were losing and
now with so few pieces on the board
and done for us
I there's just so many things that we
take for granted in in the Chess World
today so many tools that allow us to
enjoy the games more fully to benefit
from the experience and and to watch in
a more deliberate manner of course
engines uh overall but table bases in
particular just allow us to know how the
game should end it allow us to
immediately see beyond a shadow of Doubt
whether the players are pursuing the
correct winning and drawing strategy and
Fabi I have to say is not convincing me
right now he's given the series of
checks with his Queen yes but he might
have forgotten that h3g takes H3 is
actually a terrible move because the
pawn is going to be pinned and if he
moves the queen too far away then he's
allowing White's King to get active so
happy had the opportunity to go H3 and
ended immediately he rushes with a
couple of checks now he's taking his
time again
I don't think the game is totally over
I'm gonna amend what I said just a
couple of minutes ago
I don't think it's over just yet
and one of the things that Fabi really
wants to do is he wants to like walk his
King over to F4 put it on G3 and start
attacking that weak G2 Pawn but I just
love the square that param has put his
Queen on because if King F4 happens then
Queen H2 to check will come and the
black king will have to step back
I still maintain that carwana should ask
himself well what is my goal in this
position there's two ways to win three
ways you can force the queen trade can't
do that here you can get your King
around to G3
not easy to do either the third method
is what I think he should pursue step
away to H5 get the King off of the
checking zone of White's Queen
and then just go H3 and the proximity of
White's gang to the queen is what makes
White's position so hopeless just the
abundance of threats that Force white to
contort himself and allow the H Pawn to
promote 40 seconds for Fabi he's taken
two and a half minutes on this move and
he's not seeing it oh my gosh are we
gonna get another miracle
I think maybe we might see something
because now this has become a real
scramble and uh Fabi well he finds the
correct idea Queen to D2 and in fact the
table base was simply recommended that
the best check was to actually put the
queen on B2 with the queen to kind of
keep some kind of Maximum checking
distance and uh now the king
is going to be asked a question where is
it going to go and it's moved to E4
and once again again the best technique
is simply to give checks furthest away
from the king so you want to go Queen B2
Drive the king away
ah very interesting well fabi's got 16
seconds now to figure it out Queen F4
check I think D3 and Parham has sensed
it and has started to respond instantly
which I like
oh my gosh now Queen C5 is not a threat
because of Queen F5
how do you make that last bit of
progress maybe you go H3 and then G3
maybe you break through
fabby's not going to do that in time
pressure
H3 was a winning attempt according to
the table base and queen F5 check also
doesn't spoil the win so still plenty to
play for but H3 the computer does
confirm was the way forward
well one way to lose here
would be to go King E2 and allow the
queen to sneak into C2 that actually
loses the queen or him correctly
shifts his King down one square to D2
and how is Fabi going to proceed to see
can I go G3 that's a very committal move
yovi but that might be the way to set up
or is that not the move no that is not
the movie your move H3 is still very
much in play
uh anything any other moves other kind
of
Queen checks that don't change the
equilibrium too much so you're looking
at Queen F4 maybe Queen F5 check but H3
is the winning attempt
and he's played a move
oh no apology he he has played a move
Queen D5 check so he continues to give
these checks but where what is the
target Square for his Queen I don't know
if he knows exactly what he's aiming for
here
you need two
still H3 probably wins
uh no gosh not now anymore oh my gosh
he uh has to go back to your original
plan of actually putting the King on H5
and setting it up
think he's trying to win this by forcing
a queen trade rather than by creating a
pass Pawn I think he's afraid to play H3
he's afraid that the king is too close
to the pawn that his King is going to
get too exposed
and again Fabi under a minute here he's
basically playing on increment
it's not so easy to build up a big time
Surplus here because at this point every
check requires some thought you got to
be careful not to repeat moves three
times at this point
oh my gosh
when it comes to creating important
endings it's just impossible to
calculate you just have to visualize the
position that you are staring for and
okay he gives a check on A2 very good
obviously King D3 is literally forced
all other moves lost the queen
and back he goes to B3 he's spotted the
right idea
King
D2 is forced
yep I'd imagine
and is it time for H3
no
apparently not
I'm very much worried that he will play
H3
what is the move here
leads to a draw because of questions
oh I Inspire I didn't see that oh you're
gonna get Perpetual oh my God
are you kidding me
so good moves are just to give a few
checks and just to kind of set up that
construction so that when H3 comes the
king is safely covered from any checks
okay and
now it's now it's Fabby who's under a
minute Fabio who has to make those quick
decisions
you know 45 seconds or whatever it
sounds like a lot oh you know you got
time to calculate but when you're
In the Heat of the Moment when you're
when you're Fabby
you're I mean that time it evaporates so
quickly I've been in so many of these
situations where you know you must be
winning but you're starting suddenly
playing on increment and you're like
mesmerized by your clock ticking down
and your fingers turn into thumbs your
brain just kind of shuts down
Abby has made zero zero progress
in the last X number of moves
yeah
zero time yeah I was gonna say he's been
forced in param to play only moves to
remain in the game and okay he's given a
few checks the King has to move
somewhere D2 C2
as long as it doesn't move to E2 it
should be fine okay I'm gonna move to E2
that was fine
yeah I mean I guess as long as king D4
there would have blundered the queen to
queen A7 but he's not gonna do that
no he's not going to do that so
interesting enough he has to put his
Queen back onto the fifth row he has to
achieve that with check and then he has
to do that very critical H3 Pawn
breakthrough
he's gonna play H3 eventually the real
question is when and which passed Pawn
is he going to emerge with is he going
to play the with a G Pawn or is he going
to play with the H Pawn
and uh it's it's just very hard to say
how exactly
like where your queen should be where
your king should be 30 seconds again for
Fabi
and again he's playing with his last
seconds
okay G3 H3 there we go oh this is a draw
this is a drone instead of Toronto is it
yes okay you have Pawn takes Pawn
oh
no oh my God you can get mated here Yogi
I've seen people get mated if Queen
takes H3 imagine if Black's King is on
G3 and White's king queen lands on F2
you've seen Blitz games like that
I guess Fabi will give a check on F3 but
then the king can stay on E1
no yep
we're gonna get another turn around
we've already gotten
we gotta get the natural result on you
the result that could have happened
many many many moves ago
this might be more heartbreaking
for Fabiano
although he's going to console himself
by saying there was I had no business
even being close to winning but that's
not how you think that's totally not how
you think he will be heartbroken at this
Miss if Parham can stay on his feet and
stay alert I assume the move here is
Queen C5 check or is it no it's Queen C1
check
uh no Queen C1 would actually lose
Queen C5 check is the nice move and uh
it's primarily I think because of your
idea Queen
um because then you can go Queen F5
after King H4 and then you're inviting
the king to come to G3 and you'll say
wow wow thank you for that Queen F2
checkmate
well Tarantella closes in one hour
so the players might have to rush to the
pizzeria if Fabi allows a draw in this
game
that might be the best pizza Parham has
ever tasted
two minutes difficult difficult to read
the emotions of what the players will be
feeling if this does in fact end in a
draw because somehow Fabi will instantly
forget that he was defending an end game
for a long long time and and that was
the result he wanted and he'll feel like
he's been robbed in those closing
moments and param one hour one hour one
minute and 30 seconds yeah he's gonna
take his time here because he's got a
couple checks all of them look equally
tempting
and the biggest opportunity I don't want
to jump the gun here Fabi might still
very well win this game but that
opportunity fabihad to slide his King to
H5 and push H3 that was the cleanest cut
win he had the other wins it was hard to
find the right arrangement of Queen and
pawn but that was a very straightforward
option after which Parham which just had
no way to restrain his pawn and now he's
down to a minute
Arham feeling the burn at this point
less than a minute on the clock he's got
to make a decision soon
clock is ticking
it has to make a move
and uh here this comes a lot of choice
Queen F2 another very clever move I have
to say
I have been very impressed by the
tenacity of Parham because a lot of us
would have just crumbled as soon as we
got into this queen two queen versus one
end game it would have been like why are
we here and then we would have just made
a series of terrible errors and the game
would have finished very quickly but
Forum he's finding these amazing moves
he's defending now like a lion
15 seconds for Fabby crumbled and
crumbled aggressively wouldn't we all 10
seconds and he's made him move an H7
oh my gosh now all we need right now is
for one of the players to lose on time
that's what we're missing
no but but listen Queen E3 check and
King F2 is just a dead draw
our hum is like two moves away when
white gets the king to G2 at that point
Bobby can just offer a draw because even
a queen trade would lead to a drawn Pawn
end game at that point all Parham has to
do is Slide the queen over and shift his
King be in front of the pawn
no this is crazy
here he goes absolutely I don't know why
Queen G3 and not Queen E3 check but okay
it's fine it's okay it's still within
the Realms of a drawer this is all so
good and uh okay and remember moves like
Queen H4 can be met with King F2
oh and that's it because
yeah Queen lands on F4 you take it and
you go King F2 almost all Queen trades
at this point lead to a draw Fabby
almost has nothing to play for at this
point I don't even see any traps just
King E1 literally just shuffle your king
between E1 and E2 Parham does it
immediately
yeah unreal he doesn't Flinch does he I
mean in that particular moment the path
to the draw wasn't that great and he had
to retreat the king or step it forward
to E3 pyro sees it so quickly and Fabi
just cannot believe that he's messed it
up that was
you know it was the opportunity of a
lifetime there but I really do think
that this result is as Fair as it gets
I'm totally on the same page with you
how did Parham do this after a blunder
of that magnitude how do you just hunker
down and hold an end game like this
it should be a dropper here very shortly
are we are we gonna reach and move 100
it's gonna be close
you're a close and just King E1 I mean
there's not a single move
that carwana has here
you went out for draw
there it is
oh look at that look like all right all
right I want to make it to Tarantella
boy
they cannot agree a draw move 99
because I predicted that this game would
pass a hundred moves and oh no no no no
don't
snatch away my victory and the clothes
and the closing seconds of the game
please I think you're safe I think
you'll at least he'll at least try Queen
H4
okay no it just goes back I might repeat
moves
real
you did it Yogi it's a move 100.
at the very least five people make a
move he won't resign
he might go Queen F4
okay but then that's uh
an elementary tour after Queen F4
because they just simply trade of queens
and uh the white King has opposition and
it's there on the board and param
breathes a sigh of relief what an
adventure the pair have taken us on
no but this is just absolutely crazy the
tenacity The Verve the resistance after
six hours and a crushing soul-crushing
series of blunders to just come back
like that it was a perfect or have the
opportunity to play G3
as the players inevitably there will be
stalemate on the board move
106. you called it and this game has
lasted seven hours and nine minutes
definitely the longest game I think of
the tournament thus far
what a marathon and the players still
have enough left in the tank to exchange
their brief thoughts about the game I
would be running toward that Pizzeria
yeah unreal I mean what a roller coaster
I mean but I have to say it's been a
very instructive game from start to
finish I mean we we saw Aaron put
Fabiana under pressure and at the end
you know he overpressed and then we had
this fascinating Queen upon ending where
we all learned that the winning
technique was actually to put the pawn
on H4 and move the king up the board it
was just fascinating
well that is going to make it to some of
the textbooks but it's time to draw some
conclusions as the players continue to
discuss the end game let's review
today's results we have had four
decisive games I would have bet my
entire savings back soon was going to
lose but no that game ends peacefully
aronian and kymer both draw dingley run
great defensive effort we've been
through noterbeck's amazing win reported
in benforest loose to Carlson and
prognananda respectively and that
funnels us directly into the standings
no Rebecca Dusseldorf could not be
happier at parhamaksudu's incredible
defensive effort Yogi
uh I mean it has uh kept some of the
leads intact so you have nodded back
with five and a half points out of seven
Fabiana caruana Anish giri where's Lisa
I'm pregnant under it's crowded at the
top all have four and a half points and
uh lavono Rooney in there on Fourth but
look who's climbed all the way up to
Seventh Place Magnus Carlsen he sniffed
around for three and a half points don't
write the world champion off
sniffing around is the right Magnus with
one more win will make his way to a plus
score and now tomorrow we have an
absolutely mouth-watering lineup of
pairings as usual we have caruana
Carlson something always to look forward
to Fabiana car one will have to put this
game behind him because he has a very
tough task ahead of him other
fascinating pairings include noterbeck
who faces an on formal of honoronian
then Forest era geising of course Wesley
so let's not forget about him he's
suddenly plus two tied for second place
he faces dingley run who's shown himself
to be capable of some mistakes in this
tournament
yeah definitely some exciting matchups
we had I really can't wait for them to
happen and I can't wait to see how
everyone is going to cope with yes well
today's
dramatic turn of events we saw a lot of
decisive games and tomorrow I think it's
going to be a real shake-up in terms of
standings I think we're going to see a
lot more surprises
well Monday is a rest day we're going to
see a lot of tired players tomorrow but
they're gonna have to put out all of the
energy that they have left and folks we
don't have too much energy left and
we're going to wrap up but before we do
we wanted to remind you to mark your
calendars because bullet brawl Arenas
are coming back to your screens starting
January 28th just a week from now titled
players compete in a two-hour arena with
twenty five hundred dollars on the line
watch as your favorite streamers battle
it out in monthly bullet brawl Arenas
starting Saturday January 28th use x
Glam brawl the chat for all the details
well
Ivanka I could not have chosen a better
person to survive these seven hours with
what an incredible round I'd like to
thank you for bringing the energy each
and every hour
oh my gosh I don't even know what to say
but I think it's time to wrap up
everything good must come to an end
most certainly does and as always the
feeling is very much mutual and uh yeah
that's it will be all for us right
it will indeed thank you to everybody in
the chat we had over 40 000 as usual
bringing the contingent I know you have
busy weekend plans so thank you for
taking the time to watch tomorrow's
round it'll be round eight tomorrow
Sunday at 5 00 a.m Pacific the usual
start time 8 A.M New York time and 2 p.m
Central European Time and now for uh
International Master Ivanka Huska and
our entire amazing team at chess.com GM
Daniel nerdinski saying goodbye from the
85th status steel chess tournament we
will see you tomorrow bright and early
around eight so long
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
around
[Music]
foreign